Good morning, everyone.
Seeing that board members are now, President Brooks, will you please call the roll to establish
a quorum?
Member Sun.
Present.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Present.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Present.
Member McQuillan.
Here.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Present.
Member Darling-Hammond.
Here.
Member Burr.
Member Bonacca.
Present.
Everyone's present.
I hereby call the November 2021 meeting of the State Board of Education to order at
8 31 a.m.
I'd like to commence by saluting the flag and ask our student board member, Bonacca, will
you please lead us to the Pledge of Allegiance?
I'd love to.
Can everyone please stand for the pledge?
Ready, salute.
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the United States of America and to the Republic for
which it stands, one nation, indivisible, with liberty and justice for all.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
I want to share as we begin the morning the bittersweet news that Pam Castleman has accepted
a full-time position as associate faculty and coordinator of graduate research in the
School of Education at Chesapeake University starting in January of 2022.
In addition to supporting students conducting their master's research, she will help address
the principal and teacher shortage by preparing the next generation of school leaders.
She helps to focus her university research on her passion, which is the marriage of core
academics with CTE.
Pam began her work at the State Board of Education in 2017, and during that time she has been
involved in numerous curriculum projects as well as CTE, and I want you to please join
me in wishing her well.
We appreciate all that she has done and look forward to this next chapter in her career
in which she'll connect with us in a new way.
Thank you, Pam.
In terms of our own recruitment and selection in the State Board, we're seeking additional
applications for two appointments to the Instructional Quality Commission from currently practicing
teachers and or leaders with experience and expertise in mathematics, physical education,
English language arts, English language development.
As you know, the mathematics curriculum framework is coming through the process and will be
followed by instructional materials adoption and recommendations, so that's a particularly
pressing need.
And applications will be screened based on the need for current upcoming IQC projects.
The State Board is also seeking applications to fill one position on the Advisory Commission
on Special Education.
Preference will be given to applicants who are teachers or individuals affiliated with
transition services or students with disabilities.
The recruitment window for both the IQC and ACSE will be open from October 29th through
December 1st, 2021.
For more information, you can visit the SBE website under What's New.
There are three items on the agenda that have agenda associated with them.
Item one, the State Board of Education Screening Committee recommendations for appointments
to the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, California Practitioners Advisory Group, and
the Instructional Quality Commission.
Item two is the 2022-23 Student Board Member and the recommendation of three finalists
for submission to the Governor for consideration and appointment.
And item three is reports from the 2021 Student Advisory Board on Education.
There are two public hearings on the agenda.
Item eight, the 2021 Arts Education Adoption of K-8 Instructional Materials and Instructional
Quality Commission recommendations.
And item nine, the 2021 World Languages Adoption of K-8 Instructional Materials and Instructional
With respect to the consent calendar, the proposed waiver consent items are W-1 through
W-11, and the proposed regular consent items are items 10 through 15.
There are a couple of changes in the agenda.
After item one, we will take up item four, the assessment contract, and then take up
items two and three.
And then we'll reopen item one for the State Superintendent's report when he arrives before
resuming the agenda order with item five.
And then later this afternoon after the regular consent vote, we will reopen item one to take
up the SBE Screening Committee recommendations for appointments to the Advisory Committee
on Charter Schools, California Practitioners Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality
Commission.
At that time, we'll also take up action on the September minutes and receive the State
Board Liaison Report.
Members of the public wishing to call in for public comment should view the live stream
of the meeting to know at what time public comment will occur for each item.
Public comment may be provided by dialing the phone number, entering a participant access
code, and then following each of the operator's prompts.
Upon dialing in, callers will be added to a caller queue.
The operator will notify callers when it is their turn to provide public comment.
We'll also ask callers to please turn down the speaker volume of their computers if they
are following the live webcast to avoid an echoing effect.
Public comment will be limited to one minute for each speaker.
And item 16 is the general public comment item, during which members of the public may
provide comment on matters that are not specifically listed in the Board agenda.
Board members, please mute your microphones when not speaking and keep your cameras on
at all times, except during the scheduled breaks to ensure that we maintain a quorum
throughout today's virtual meeting.
For each item on the agenda, there will be an opportunity for you to raise your hands
using the Zoom participant window if you'd like to ask a question or make a comment.
And item one is our State Board priorities item, and I will give a brief report and then
State Superintendent Tony Thurman will arrive in person shortly and later in the agenda
will give his report.
So at our last board meeting in September, I spoke about the successful efforts that
we had undertaken to open schools safely in the midst of the Delta variant surge.
The amazing efforts of our state's educators who have acted with such courage and determination
and resilience, along with our focus on supporting schools with testing, vaccination supports,
and universal masking have made us the safest state in the country for most of this intervening
period with declining cases throughout most of the fall and one of the lowest rates of
school closure due to outbreaks in the country.
In fact, while California has 12 percent of the students in the country, we've had fewer
than one percent of the nation's schools closures.
Now as the weather is turning colder and more of our activities go inside, it is critically
important that we continue our vigilance to end this pandemic.
Case rates have begun to tick up again nationally and in California, almost entirely among the
unvaccinated population, and we cannot afford to take our foot off the gas.
With more than 75 percent of all Californians at least partially vaccinated and 83 percent
of our 12 to 17 year olds vaccinated, we are making good progress at getting to the moment
when we can get put this pandemic behind us.
Yesterday CDC advisors recommended the Pfizer vaccine for children between ages 5 and 11
and within hours of this vote, the CDC director signed off on the unanimous recommendation.
This is exciting news.
We're now awaiting the Western States Scientific Safety Review workgroup to weigh in and it's
possible that children could start to be vaccinated by as soon as tomorrow.
I'm hearing from many people that they are planning birthday vaccinations for their children.
What a great present.
And I personally hope that when my grandson turns five on September 6th, he will be able
to get his birthday vaccination as well.
As you know, California has been leading the nation in work to educate and engage families
to provide accurate information about COVID to make vaccines as accessible as possible.
There have been more than 3,000 school-based clinics to help get the vaccines to staff
and families.
We've offered districts funding to sponsor vaccine clinics.
We've brokered partnerships with pharmacies and medical clinics, as well as after school
programs, including a partnership between the Sierra Health Foundation and the Alliance
for Boys and Girls Clubs to do 84 pop-up clinics statewide that are upcoming.
We've worked with pediatricians to be sure they have vaccines on hand and more is planned
for the coming months.
If we can stay focused on mitigation measures in schools and vaccinations for all eligible
Californians, we will reach the light at the end of this tunnel.
And I just want to encourage everyone to stay focused, persevere, and keep our foot on the
gas to get to that goal.
In another major challenge, there are also some signs of progress, which I hope our education
system here in California will contribute to in some major ways.
This week, the United Nations Climate Conference has been convening in Scotland, with historic
agreements being forged to cut methane emissions and stop deforestation and a renewed commitment
on the part of the United States and many other countries to seriously address climate
change.
There is much more to do, and all of us need to play a part.
In our state, we know well the dangers of climate change, and we experience them increasingly
each year.
In my first president's report in 2019, I acknowledged the one-year anniversary of both
the Camp Fire in Paradise and Woolsey Fire in Ventura County, and I noted that six of
the ten most destructive fires in California's history had occurred since October 2017.
Here we are two years later, and now eight of the ten most destructive fires in California
history have occurred since October 2017, including this summer's devastating Dixie
Fire.
Children who are growing up in California have experienced far too many days of hazardous
air, evacuation orders, and in too many cases, loss of homes and even loved ones.
The wildfires are only one impact of climate change in California.
The drought that is deepening is another one, and the wild storm that dropped what
meteorologists called a cyclone bomb on California and our neighboring states just a week ago
is yet another.
Our children are aware of these dangers and want to be part of the solution.
When I gave that first report, the board took time to honor a group of energetic and impassioned
Sonoma County middle school students who formed schools for climate action to urge and empower
educators, students, and elected officials to speak up about climate change and to take
all the steps we can at the state and local level.
In addition to what our governor and legislature have done to set emission standards, incentives
for solar power, and development of green technologies, schools have a very large role
to play, both in the greening of campuses and the greening of the curriculum.
I learned more about the possibilities and the role that we can play through my membership
on the K-12 Climate Action Commission, sponsored by the Espen Institute, a bipartisan commission
co-sponsored by former New Jersey Governor Christie Todd Whitman, a Republican, and former
U.S. Secretary of Education John King, a Democrat, who convened others across party lines to
consider what schools can do to arrest climate change.
A little-known fact is that the nation's 480,000 school buses are the largest transportation
fleet in the country.
Moving to electric buses would be a transformational contribution to clean air, and Stockton Unified
District has partnered with companies to transition to electric school buses through grants from
the California Air Resources Board, the California Energy Commission, rebates from the local
utility company, the district has built charging stations, acquired its first set of electric
buses, and supporting more districts in making plans, accessing funding and building needed
charging infrastructure could help our schools transition their school bus fleet to electric.
Stockton also helps students promote energy efficiency within their schools through the
Student Energy Patrol Program.
When he spoke to the commission, the district's energy specialist, Gilbert Rosas, noted that
the district is on track to save $22 million over the next 10 years through energy conservation,
solar panels, and solar battery storage at schools.
Students were part of the process of auditing the system and coming up with some of the
strategies that the board was able later to adopt.
In Santa Barbara Unified, the district has prepared schools to serve as community hubs
in the event of power outages and extreme weather after experiencing a mudslide after
a wildfire in 2018 that shut down the city for two and a half weeks and prevented students
from getting to school, community and district leaders transformed the school buildings into
solar microgrids that can use solar energy to maintain core functions in the event of
power outages.
The state and a number of districts are tackling another key issue associated with food production
and waste.
In addition to the farm to table incentive for schools initiated by the governor and
the first partner, districts are taking up this mission.
Oakland Unified has a sustainability manager who focuses on reducing food waste, creating
a food share program at every school and increasing compost programs.
San Diego Unified has a love food not waste program that takes food that's been prepared
but not taken by students and makes it available for local hunger relief organizations.
In the last few years, the program rescued more than 500,000 pounds of food from schools
and eliminated 275,000 pounds of greenhouse gas emissions.
I'm not sure if everyone understands the relationship between food preparation and
disposal and greenhouse gas emissions.
These are just a few examples of climate action ongoing at our local levels, supported by
state resources like the California Air Resources Board grant funding to help increase access
to electric school buses, Proposition 39's K-12 program, which provided five years of
funding to increase energy efficiency and clean energy use in schools and help California
achieve one certified, six verified, and 72 emerging net zero energy schools by 2019.
And there are many student led actions to raise awareness.
Just two months ago, high school students in San Diego County marched in downtown Chula
Vista in San Diego to demand policies that would reduce carbon emissions.
To deepen students' understanding of the issues, California state science standards
include teaching about sources and solutions to climate change through the next generation
science standards and two CTE pathways that explicitly address clean energy.
We're also working to integrate environmental principles and concepts into the entire curriculum.
So you'll see guidance on climate change instruction in the language arts and history social science
curriculum frameworks, as well as the science framework.
The state recently provided funding to San Mateo County to develop open access climate
change and environmental justice curricula for all grades that are aligned to the concepts.
We urge educators and local boards to be aware of and to use these curriculum resources,
as well as to consider greening strategies as they make investments in infrastructure
buses transportation.
Looking at all of these existing successes, we have the opportunity to be a national leader
and help support schools to become models for climate action, to reduce the footprint
of this very large public sector, and to prepare students to lead a more sustainable future
and succeed in the clean economy.
And while we are working at the state level to expand these opportunities, educators and
school board leaders at the local level can also ask themselves about whether their districts
have a policy to ensure that school infrastructure, renovations, retrofits, systems replacements
will support healthy sustainable learning environments, and we'll have more opportunities
to ask those questions and to spend those resources when the infrastructure bill gets
passed in the next few days and supports that kind of work throughout the country.
We can ask ourselves about transportation and how to transition school bus fleets.
We could ask ourselves about food and sustainable food use and composting and how we are using
existing curricula and developing more ways for students to participate in evaluating
and contributing towards sustainability in our schools.
This is an important moment as more federal and state resources will be coming to support
these questions to consider how we can, in our various roles, support our schools in
providing a safe and healthy environment now and for our students' lifetimes.
You all know how fragile mental health for our children has been over this last year,
and these are factors that play into their view of their future and their mental health
and capacity for hope and optimism as well as for a strong and bright future.
So I wanted to raise these issues for us this month as we continue our task both to make
our schools safe places and enable our students to move forward in productive ways in school
and in their lives.
And with that, I'm going to return to the agenda and take up Item 4.
So we're jumping ahead to Item 4, which is the California Assessment of Student Performance
and Progress and the English Language Proficiency Assessments for California.
This is for approval of the proposed contract with Educational Testing Service for the
administration of the CASP and the LPAC Assessments for California, and the CDE recommends that
we approve this proposed contract and authorize CDE staff to make technical edits to the documents
as needed prior to its execution, and the item will be presented by Cheryl Cotton and
Mal Vang of the department.
Cheryl, please begin.
To Superintendent Thurmond, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Strauss, and esteemed board members.
I'm Cheryl Cotton, Deputy Superintendent of Instruction, Measurement, and Administration branch.
I'll be co-presenting again with Mal Vang, Director of Assessment Development and Administration Division.
We'll be presenting Item 4 as an action item seeking approval on proposed assessment contract
with Educational Testing Service, or ETS.
Today I will provide background information on the procurement process that led us to
the proposed contract and budget being shared with you today.
Mal Vang will share the recommended, I'm sorry, Mal Vang will share the recommendation being
brought to you for approval and go over a high-level summary of the contract scope of
work and budget.
On April 20, 2020, the CDE released the California Assessment System Request for Qualifications,
or RFQ, as a four-stage process to procure its next assessment contract for five administrations
of the California Assessment System, the CASP and the LPAC, which is projected to begin
July 1, 2020, I'm sorry, July 1, 2022, and continue through December 31, 2027.
In June 2020, an evaluation team composed of staff from different divisions of the CDE
and staff from local educational agencies, or LEAs, located in regions across the state,
met to score the RFQ Stage 1 submissions.
Two potential contractors successfully met the evaluation criteria to progress to Stage
2 of the RFQ.
In early August 2020, the CDE provided the California Assessment System RFQ Stage 2 mandatory
demonstrations criteria to the two potential contractors who passed Stage 1.
Using an evaluation process similar to Stage 1, the evaluation team composed of staff from
different divisions of CDE and staff from LEAs from different regions across the state
met in November 2020 to score the RFQ Stage 2 submissions.
The two potential contractors that passed both Stages 1 and 2 moved forward to Stage
3, were Educational Testing Service, or ETS, and National Computer Systems, NCS, Pearson,
Inc.
At its January 2021 meeting, the California State Board of Education, or SBE, authorized
the CDE to request of Stage 3 a formal written submission from the potential contractors
containing a proposed scope of work, a draft proposed budget, and a transition plan.
The CDE received approval from the SBE to include the following goals and priorities
in the Stage 3 draft scope of work from the potential contractors.
1.
To enhance the development and administration of high quality assessments of the California
assessment system, i.e. summative, interim, and formative assessments, through the 2022-2027
school years.
2.
To continue to improve the robust assessment system to ensure efficient, effective, and
accurate results, with enhancements to support multiple administration modes.
And 3.
Explore and advance technology solutions that meet system capacity, performance, and usability
to the greatest extent possible.
On February 5, 2021, the CDE provided the California Assessment System RFQ Stage 3 formal
written submission criteria to ETS and NCS Pearson.
The formal written submission requirements included a proposed scope of work, a draft
proposed budget, and a transition plan.
The formal written submissions were received by May 3, 2021.
As was done for Stages 1 and 2, the evaluation team met to score the RFQ Stage 3 submissions.
First, the evaluation team rated each proposal for pass or fail on whether the submission
met the RFQ Stage 3 criteria.
Then the evaluation team scored the technical proposal for each potential contractor.
During that step, the evaluation team scored the budget proposal for each potential contractor.
After the RFQ Stage 3 submissions were scored, the evaluation team added the total scores
for Stages 1, 2, and 3 to reach an overall technical score.
To conclude the RFQ Stage 3, the evaluation team took each potential contractor's overall
technical score and overall budget score and combined them to get an overall submission score.
The potential contractors were then ranked on the basis of the outcome of this process,
as was presented to the SBE in July 2021.
ETS was the highest ranked potential contractor.
At the July 2021 SBE meeting, the CDE received approval to begin Stage 4 negotiations with ETS.
Representatives from the CDE, the SBE, and the Department of Finance held negotiation
meetings with ETS in August, September, and October 2021, which culminated in a proposed
contract, CN 220002, including the negotiated scope of work, the budget, supporting documents,
and provisional items, I'm sorry, provisional terms and conditions.
In that, you would see in Attachment 1-9.
Mal will now cover the outcome of these negotiations in her portion of this presentation.
Thank you, Mal.
Sorry, gotta adjust my height here.
Give me a minute.
Thank you, Cheryl.
As Cheryl mentioned, I'm Bao Vang, Director of the Assessment, Development, and Administration Division.
Thank you for having me today.
The recommendation is as follows.
The CDE recommends that the State Board of Education, or SBE, approve the proposed contract
with Educational Testing Service, or ETS, for the administration of the California Assessment
of Student Performance and Progress, or CASP, and the English Language Proficiency
Assessments for California, or LPAC, collectively known as the California Assessment System,
and authorize CDE and SBE staff to make technical edits to the contract documents
as needed prior to the execution of the contract.
So, to set the context for the new contract, I will highlight some key information about
the California Assessment System, which operates year-round with minimal downtime.
So, it serves all 6.2 million of our students in the K-12 system, about 250,000 educators,
our students in the K-12 system, about 250,000 educators access the system,
and at about all of our 2,000 local educational agencies.
It really delivers about 200 plus separate test titles, being administered about 20 million tests
administered separately, and about 11 million scores reported year-round with online testing.
This slide provides the estimated number of test takers across all of the assessment programs
with the estimated number of test takers in the last column.
And what we have in terms of these assessments is the Smarter Balanced Interims for
English Language Arts, Literacy, and English and Math, or ELA and Math, excuse me.
And this is really available to all 6.2 million students, even though it may be aligned to grades
3 through 8 and 11 standards. Then we have the summative assessments, the Smarter Balanced
summative assessments for ELA and Math, and that's available for grades 3 through 8 and 11.
And then 3.2 million students access those assessments. Then we have the California
Alternate Assessments, or CAAs, for ELA and Math. Again, in those similar grades of the same grades
of 3 through 8 and 11, about 39,000 students take those assessments. And then the California
Science Test is administered in grades 5, 8, and high school, once in high school, and about 1.4
million students access that test. And then our California Alternate Assessments for Science,
again in those same grades, grades 5, 8, and once in high school, about 16,500 students access that.
We do have a Spanish assessment, California Spanish assessment, and it is estimated that
about 40,000 students would be taking that test. And then we have summative LPAC, and that's
available for K through 12. About 1.1 million students access that on an annual basis.
Our initial LPAC, that is an assessment for new students to our state or the country,
and has a language other than English, and about 200,000 students access that on an annual basis.
We are operationalizing our summative and initial alternate LPAC in the current year,
and we'll continue to offer that in future years. So going back to the, so to start off with in terms
of the negotiated contract, I will explain how we are continuing the development administration
and scoring and reporting of the current assessments that I've just mentioned.
And all of these assessments are covered in this new contract. So having said that,
since I've already mentioned all the assessments, let's just go on that in terms of
the services for the assessments. In addition, the contract will also continue to do the reporting
for all the assessments, including Lexile and quantum measures for the Smarter Balanced
ELA and Mathematics, summative and interim assessments.
And also, in addition, we will provide growth model reporting using the SBE
approved methodology. While this list is not exhaustive, it provides a high-level summary
of the continuity of the services for the California assessment system.
And then on the next slides, I will share the expansion of services and innovations in the new
contract. So the negotiated process has also produced a proposed contract that includes
the needs expansion of services and innovations. For example, we're going to expand the California
Spanish assessment to include speaking and extended writing. This includes the contractor
scoring the extended writing. We are in the process of, we will be envisioning, developing,
and providing interim assessments for the California Science Test or CAST in the LPAC.
And then we are also enhancing customer care because we want to make sure that we do specific
outreach to our educators and administrators and LEA coordinators to support them in their
implementation of this contract and the programs. And then continuing to improve accessibility
or expanding and improving accessibility and integration of assessment data into our state
or CDEs and the state data systems. Sorry, furthermore, this contract includes piloting
and scaling new assessment types and features. As you know, the future is, in terms of future
assessment innovations, there's a lot to explore. And some of these research-based strategies are,
for example, continuing implementation of the assessment innovations that we are beginning
this year with our Smarter Balanced ELA and math study. And then improving,
another example is improving accessibility of test questions and performance tasks.
And investigating new technologies that support different ways to assess the standards.
Another thing, another expansion is conducting special studies to support the validity of the
assessment system. And examples of that is conducting a validation study to support
reclassification using the alternate LPAC and continuing longitudinal analyses on the impact
of the COVID pandemic. And also exploring the remote testing, test administration options and
score comparability studies. And then furthermore, using research-based strategies to consider
augmentation of our CASP and LPAC student score reports to increase parent and guardian engagement
and to provide more information for them about how to support their students.
And another very important negotiated component is that we will envision, develop and provide
a multi-step approach to assessment innovations for embedding performance tasks in learning,
for the California Science test or CASP, with input from our interest holders,
our partners and approval from the State Board of Education or SBE at various and key
stages of the development. So adding all this to the contract allows us to explore future
assessment innovations and work with our interest holders and the SBE to conceptualize innovative
strategies throughout the life of this contract.
So all this work does not come at a cost, which I will cover in this slide. The budget is broken
down by fiscal year here with total costs for each role in the last column. So these costs
cover the five administrations that Cheryl referred to earlier, as well as the transition cost in the
last year of the contract. So during the July 2021 SBE meeting, we shared the results of the Stage
3 costs. ETS's cost for this task, outlined in Stage 3, is reflected in that first role.
And then in Stage 4, the negotiations included the
continued reporting of the lexile and quantile measures for ELA math in the second role. That
component was not in the Stage 3 requirements, so it had to be negotiated in.
And then furthermore, to extend the SBE's goals of evolving the assessments to the next level,
the negotiations included conceptualizing assessment innovations for CAS, as I mentioned,
and the cost is shown in the third role with strategic opportunities at various stages for
SBE approval. And then the overall budget will be $449,870,786 in total.
And at this point, I'd like to stop and see if there are any clarifying questions.
Just double-checking to make sure there are not any hands up. I think you can continue.
Okay, so here we are back at the CDE recommendation. Again, the California Department
of Education recommends that the California State Board of Education approve the proposed
contract with Educational Testing Service for the administration of the California Assessment
of Student Performance and Progress and the English Language Proficiency
Assessments for California, collectively known as the California Assessment System,
and authorize CDE and SBE staff to make technical edits to the
contract documents as needed prior to the execution of the contract.
Okay. Should you need to reach our programs?
For LPAC, send your questions to ELPAC at cde.ca.gov, and for CAS, send questions to
caaspp at cde.ca.gov. These are program questions. And you could continue to follow us on Twitter
at CDE assessments, and we are providing the assessment spotlight link for should you want
to be a part of our listserv. Subscribe to caaspp at mlist.cde.ca.gov. And I'll turn this over
back to you, Board President. Thank you so much for that and very informative
briefing. And I'm going to call attention now to the public comment slide so that we can open
the phone line for public comment queue. Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this
item can do so by calling the phone number and using the access code provided on the slide that
is shown now. And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask Member
Son if she has any initial comments before I make my comments, and then I'll ask Board Members
for any clarifying questions before we go to public comment, following which we'll get into
discussion and a vote. Member Son. Thank you. Yeah, I want to thank the CDE staff for this,
what must be, I think, a year-long process now of going through this multi-stage procurement process
and gone through a lot of conversations I know and hard negotiations where we have arrived.
Where I'm most excited about this is what was outlined around envisioning and developing
innovative approaches to assessment. It was really important that we just don't do,
that we entered into this next stage of our California assessments, not with
doing the same old, that we're keeping up with research and innovations in how we assess how
students are doing and beyond just kind of the same template we've been using. So I'm very
excited that we have this opportunity in this next phase, in this next contract to
expand how we do assessments in California. And I'll just add on that, you know, Mal and her
team have done extraordinary work on this very complicated process, the very intense
process as well. And we've been very pleased with the ways in which Educational Testing
Service has responded with willingness to adventure with us as we may need to evolve
our assessments to be as supportive as possible to teaching and learning. So we're enthusiastic
about the next stages. Are there any public comments at this? Well, first, let me see if
there's any clarifying questions before we go to public comment. Not seeing any. And so
with that, are there any members of the public calling in?
Yes, currently we have four members of the public. This is for item four,
first caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Caller, we are unable to hear you. Control booth.
Hello. Yes, we can can barely hear you, caller. Could you possibly turn your volume up?
Hello, can you hear me? Just barely, caller. Could I get you to call back in and we will
pick you up again? All right, I will do some. Thank you. Thank you. Next,
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello, my name is Lorraine Richards. I'm a classroom teacher representing the California
Teachers Association. CTA appreciates the work of the California Department of Education and the
State Board of Education in evaluating the state's assessment contract. On page 48 of attachment two,
it is mentioned that the hourly rate for scores is $20 per hour for California educators
and $13 per hour for other educators. Given that this is a half billion dollar contract for ETS,
CTA would like to recommend that the State Board of Education request that ETS raise the hourly
rate for educators so that it can be at least comparable with their contracted hourly rates.
We have asked a lot for educators throughout this pandemic and it only seems fair to provide
equitable compensation for this important work. Thank you very much. Thank you, caller. Next,
caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and board. This is Liz Guillen with Public Advocates for
the Equity Coalition. We're in support of this item. We really appreciate the inclusion of the
upgrading of the California Spanish assessment with the addition of the speaking and extended
writing components. These components will give our schools and parents a much more complete profile
of a student's developing academic proficiency in Spanish and they could also serve as a tool
for eligibility for pathway and seal of by literacy awards and hopefully inform our
accountability system. We request that the writing component be comparable to the CASP ELA
assessment in rigor and scope. We note that the development of LPAC interim assessments
will be very valuable allowing schools to measure English language proficiency growth
during the school year to better target instruction and identify needs for additional
support. Thank you. Thank you. Next, caller, thank you so much for calling back.
Please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
I am Marta Hernandez representing Californians Together and we are in support of CDE's recommendation
to approve the proposed contract and budget with ETS for the administration of the California
assessment system. We appreciate very much the upgrading of the California Spanish assessment
to include speaking and extended writing components which will give our schools and parents
a much more complete profile of a student's developing academic proficiency in Spanish
could serve as a tool for eligibility and hopefully inform our accountability system.
We are hopeful that the blueprint and design of the extended writing component will be of the same
rigor and content as the ELA CASP and again I echo what others have said about the LPAC interim
assessments. They will be very, very valuable to allow schools to measure growth and better
target instruction and identify needs for additional support. Thank you. Thank you.
Next, caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning. Martha Zaragoza Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education.
CABE supports the approval by the board of item four. We are very pleased with the upgrading of
the California Spanish assessment with the addition of the speaking and extended writing components
as well as considering augmenting the CASP and LPAC student score reports to increase
parent and guardian engagement. It is our hope that the writing components will be comparable
to the CASP ELA assessment in rigor and scope. Thank you. Thank you.
Callers, if you can turn your volume all the way up we could hear you just a little bit better.
Next, caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Okay, that person just disconnected so thank you. This concludes public comment for item number four.
Thank you very much. And at this point, we're open for board discussion. Board members,
remember to raise your hand in the participant panel of Zoom if you have a question or comment.
And Patricia Rucker, please start us off and we'll be followed by Vice President Strauss.
Very much, Board President Hammond. First of all, I do want to make sure I congratulate and
thank the department staff for their due diligence, but also the exhaustive process
that they put in place to not only vet and review the intent of the vendors, but also to create a
very transparent and public process to help us understand not only how we came to create
and approve this relationship with the vendor recommended, but the rigor of the application
process so that we know we can be satisfied not only with the scope of the work that will be
developed, but with the opportunity to broaden the conversation about assessment. California
continues to process and purchase and contract for not just paper and pencil assessment,
but a system of practices for assessment and testing that opens our conversation to broader
policy. And so I preface my comment, and it's more common than a question,
for how this actually also, this contract also extends the scope of the charge for this board
and for the department. I'd like to encourage the board and the department to revisit the language
in this document to look at how we have expressed our expectations for metrics and growth targets.
While the vendor can only set aspirational goals related to closing the achievement gap,
it's the work of this board and this department to provide the guidance, support, and direction
to districts on how they should be using these outcomes and these metrics to do that work and
address planning for school achievement. For example, on page 25, under measuring and reporting,
it says the results only encourage districts to set metrics that would close gaps. The current laws
don't mandate this, but the intent of the LCFF should at least allow us, either on the board or
the department, to at least suggest that districts should use this data to set goals and targets that
would close the achievement gaps. And I know that's a fine point about, that's separate and
distinct from what we're approving here, but I just think we should pay attention to the
danger in compartmentalizing, approving the contract, and then the work we do on approving
and developing the LCFF. They are integral and connected, and I think that the approval of this
contract also has some implications for the further work we're doing on developing the LCAP.
So I do want to make sure we continue that conversation and continue thinking about how
we identify student subgroups and research-based standards aligned to practices that to close
achievement gaps. I think it's an important conversation, and while we're charging this
assessment contractor merely with the responsibility to help us explore this concept and explore
these ideas and the furtherance of developing our assessment system, I think that the language in
this contract has some implications for work we're already undertaking to approve and update
the LCFF template and the guidance that we're currently giving districts. Thank you very much.
Thank you. And Member Strauss, you're next in the queue, and then Member Escovedo.
Yeah, so I want to again follow up with Member Rucker's comments and really thank the department
for the thorough process and the clarity, and as you explained it today, of all the steps we went
through, I actually just really want to make some comments about how pleased I am with the effort to
move forward in our assessment practices so that this contract includes innovation, includes some
validation studies to continue to look at our practices, some expansions of the practice of
assessment, and I think what we know is it's not just the year-end time when we do our assessments,
but the interim assessments that provide so much feedback and also help teachers with their
matching of alignment of their classroom practices to the standards that we assess
at the state level. So again, I feel that this is the next five years, it really sets an evolution
and continued improvement and growth, and so I appreciate the components of the assessment
contract and the practices, and I look forward to the continued improvement and implementation.
Appreciate the comments of our interest holders who spoke on the phone comments today,
and that we have good support for the efforts moving forward in assessment,
which is obviously an important essential part of our instructional program. Thank you very much.
Thank you, and Member Escobedo.
Yes, I want to appreciate the amount of work and the expediency that now districts and parents are
receiving this data. It's really, really critical, and I appreciate the outreach to parents, and
because getting the data and then how to use the data and implementing it is just as important as
the quality of the assessment. So really appreciate that outreach that you indicated to parents and
and to staff as well. Just a point that hopefully as technologies and language recognition
improves, you know, dual immersion is growing quickly in California, but also encompasses other
languages. Spanish, as you well know, is the most predominant, but Mandarin and Tagalog are
increasing. So hopefully in the future, we may be looking at assessing other languages besides
Spanish as well, but really, really proud of the stance of California expanding the
Spanish assessment and hopefully beyond.
Terrific. I don't see any other hands up, and so at this point, I wonder if I could get a motion.
I am very happy to move CDE's recommendation.
And a second.
I'll second. Thank you very much. We'll hold a roll call vote. Brooks, can you call the roll?
Member Sun.
Aye. Vice President Strauss.
Yes. Member Rucker.
Yes. Member Rodriguez.
Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes. Member McQuillan.
Yes. Member Glover-Woods.
Yes. Member Escobedo.
Yes. President Darlene Hammond.
Yes. Member Burr.
Aye. Member Bonacca.
Aye. Motion passes unanimously.
Terrific. Thank you, Cheryl and Mao. And we'll move on to agenda item number two.
Item two is regarding the 2022-23 State Board of Education student member recommendation of
finalists for submission to the governor for consideration and appointment.
The State Board screening committee recommends that the State Board approve the three finalists
for the position of 2022-23 SBE student member as identified in the item addendum.
The approved finalist will be forwarded to the governor for his consideration and appointment
as the 2022-23 State Board student member. This item will be presented by screening committee chair,
Vice President Strauss. Please begin.
It gives me great pleasure to present this item. This is actually one of the highlights of our
state board work in November. We've worked very, very hard. We met, the screening committee met on
Monday, October 18th. We reviewed 37 applications that were submitted for consideration. These
students will be part of the recommendation for the board member for the next school year, the
2022-23 student board member. So we selected 12 semi-finalists. So the semi-finalist then attended
the 2021 Student Advisory Board on Education, better known as SBE. We're going to hear from
these students in a minute. You're going to be so amazed and so hopeful for the future when you
listen to what our students have to tell us about things we should be considering. The conference
began on October 30th where the student delegates listened to presentations by all 12 semi-finalists
and then they voted to give us six candidates. So on Monday this week, on November 1st, we
interviewed the six candidates and with a huge challenge we identified three finalists. That's
actually required by legislation. We actually wanted to identify more but we are required to
narrow it to three. If the board approves these names will be submitted to the governor's office
for review and consideration and then the governor will appoint one as the student board member for
2022-23. So first on behalf of the screening committee and the state board, we wish to thank
all the students who made the effort to apply and would like to encourage them to continue to offer
their impressive abilities to their local, regional, and state activities. So the students who are
being recommended, you're going to meet them in a minute, as finalists and state board by the
screening committee in alphabetical order are Katherine Chang from Dublin High School within
the Dublin Unified District in Alameda County, Naomi Porter from Palos Verdes Peninsula High School
within the Palos Verdes Peninsula Unified School District in Los Angeles County, and Sissy Zhang
from Irvington High School within the Fremont Unified School District in Alameda County.
In addition to the finalists that we named above, the following students were candidates for student
board member and you're going to meet them as well. Allison Dana from Albany High School within
the Albany Unified School District in Alameda County, Risa Jane from Montevista High School
within the San Ramon Valley Unified School District in Contra Costa County, and Enuel or Esther Kim
in Chino Hills High School within the Chino Valley Unified School District in San Bernardino County.
We also identified semi-finalists for the student board member for 22-23 and I want to introduce
those. Dylan Choi from Chaparral High School within the Temecula Valley Unified School District
in Riverside County, Dawson Kelly from San Marcos High School within the Santa Barbara Unified
School District in Santa Barbara County, Mana Kola-Gatla from Christopher High School within
the Gilroy Unified School District in Santa Clara County, Tony Martin International Polytechnic High
School within the Los Angeles County Office of Education LA County, Ella Mitchell from Tesoro
High School within the Capistrano Unified School District in Orange County, and Amber Zhao from
Walnut High School within the Walnut Valley Unified School District in Los Angeles County.
So now this is the best part. We're going to ask each of the students and I'll call on you
because I can see you on the screen if that's okay and we're going to have you introduce yourself
and tell everybody, the audience who's watching and hopefully your families as well,
where you come from and actually what the board should know is many of these students serve as
student board members in their own school district so it is just my pleasure to introduce them and
I'm going to call on each student and have you unmute and introduce yourself to the public and
then our board president will be making a couple of comments before we go on the recommendation.
So Allison, would you start? Yes, of course. Hi everyone. It's an honor to be here. My name is
Allison Dana. I'm a 16 year old and I attend Albany High School in the Albany Unified School
District where I am a student board member for the district and this is all located within the
Alameda County. So yes, pleasure to be here. Thank you very much. So Katherine, would you like to go
next? Sure. President Darling-Hammond, Superintendent Thurmond, Vice President Strauss and esteemed
board members, we're so honored to be here. I'm Katie Chang and I'm a junior at Dublin High School
in Dublin Unified School District which is in Alameda County as well. I'm in my second term as
student board member here in Dublin. Thank you. Naomi, you can go next. Hello everyone. It is a
pleasure to be here. My name is Naomi Porter. I'm 16 from Palos Verdes Peninsula High School in
Palos Verdes Peninsula Unified School District which resides in Los Angeles County. Thank you.
And Risha, would you go next? Hello everyone. It is an honor to be here. I'm grateful for opportunity
and I am truly thankful for everything that I've learned over the past weekend and more.
So again, my name is Risha Jain and I am from Montevista High School in SRB USD which is in
Contra Costa and I am also 16 years old and I've been serving on the SRB USD Student Senate for
two years now. Thank you. Esther, would you like to go next? Of course. Hello everyone. It is such
a pleasure to be here with our incredible student leaders. My name is Esther Kim. I'm a student from
Chino Hills High in the Chino Valley Unified School District and I currently serve as the student
board member of the Chino Valley Unified School District. It's great to be here. Stephanie, would
you like to go next? Hello. My name is Stephanie. I'm actually a senior from Tesoro High School in
Capuchin Unified School District in Orange County. I am the director of the student advisory board
on education so I'm not a top 12 semifinalist this year but I was last year so it's really,
really amazing to see all the students here today. So I know Michelle, you're going to be
part of the next part of the process but would you like to introduce yourself at this time?
Hello everyone. My name is Michelle. I'm not sure why it says Michelle Kim Kim but my name is Michelle
Kim. I am a senior at Portola High School in Irvine California in Orange County and I serve as
the state president for the California Association of Student Councils. And Sissy, would you like to
go next? Yeah, of course. Hello everyone. It's such a pleasure to be here and I've learned so much from
these past few weeks. My name is Sissy Zhang. I'm also 16 and I'm from Irvington High School in the
Fremont Unified School District within Alameda County. I'm currently serving as a student board
representative and it's so great to be here. So thank you. I just have to, so we're going to ask
the public if they wish to provide comment on the item they can do so by calling in on the telephone
and access code number that'll be shown on the screen in a minute. But while we're waiting for
that I'm going to turn it to our board members to first our president Darling Hammond and then to our
screening committee members who may want to make a comment about the interview and selection process.
So member Darling Hammond, would you like to make a comment? Oh, I'm so glad to have the opportunity
to congratulate these students. All that you've accomplished and will accomplish, you know,
for your communities and for us within the state, it's an exhilarating moment. We really appreciate
you in both this learning process and in the work that you're doing in your schools. So
big congratulations. We're looking forward to hearing more from all of you. So I'm going to
call on our screening committee members first who participated in this amazing process. This actually
was a real highlight and we're going to start with our student board member Rana Banaka who
was incredibly helpful and valuable in this process. Rana, I'm going to turn it to you first.
Thank you. Well, first and foremost, I think I speak for the entire screening committee when I
say this was an incredibly difficult decision because all of the candidates were so talented
and so accomplished. Personally, this was one of the hardest decisions of my life to make because
it was just such an amazing group of students. And I have full confidence that all of these
students are not only going to be the future leaders of our state but also the future leaders
of our nation. Once more, I want to commend all of these students for all of the hard work that
they put into this process. Not only did they have to give speeches and participate in interviews and
answer plenty of delegate questions but they also had to be a delegate at the SAVE conference and
they were making proposals all the while going through this really tough process. So I want to
commend all of these students. They're truly incredible and I have full confidence that the
next student board member is going to do an amazing job. So next I'm going to call on member
McQuillen who's the liaison to the SAVE and was part of, is going to help with the next item that
you're going to hear about. So I'm going to turn it to member McQuillen next. I just want to
congratulate all of you. It was a challenging process for both sides of the table but you were
all fantastic and very difficult decision to make but I just want to congratulate all of you. You
know, our future is in good hands with all of you as our leaders in the future. I just,
I learned so much throughout the day from all of you and just want to say thank you and congratulate
all of you. Thank you. Member Glover-Wiz, I'll turn to you next. Thank you so much. I just would like
to underscore what member McQuillen said. Our future is definitely in good hands. This was
the most phenomenal group of scholars that we had an opportunity to meet through their applications
and also through the interview process. We have young people who are entrepreneurs,
who are advocates in so many important areas for our state as well as our nation and just to again
echo what has already been said, it was quite the difficult process. I think if we did not have
that strict guidance on what we needed to do as far as selections, everyone would be selected
because everyone who applied as well as those who were semi-finalists and finalists just did such a
phenomenal job. So quite excited. Congratulations to all of you. It's so good to see those of you
on the screen again and looking forward to just hearing more about the wonderful things you'll be
doing as you move forward in your educational career and in your life. So Member Sung is the
other member of our screening committee so I have to ask you to make a few comments so that everyone
understands what an impactful experience it was to interview all these students.
Absolutely. As Vice President-General said, this is really the highlight of the year for me on
the serving on the state board is to go through and talk with these wonderful students. Look at
these powerful young women. It was amazing and I think we commented over and over again that
these students should be 28 and 26, not 16 and 17 and 18. So you guys just were wonderful. It was
such a difficult decision. I think we deliberated almost longer than we had time for the interview.
Thank you all for your participation and I just want to commend you all for
the application process and going through this very rigorous process.
Thank you. So let's put up the slide for the public comment and
I don't know if we have any public comments on this recommendation.
There are no public comments at this time so I would like a motion then to approve the state
board screening committee's recommendation for the finalists for the next student board member for
22-23. I still move. Do I have a second? I second.
Okay, let's see. Is either a member Escobedo? I think you got the second. I'm not sure but
I'll give that, we'll give it to you. So okay, so Executive Director Allen, would you take the
roll call vote, please? Member Sun? Aye. Vice President Strauss? Yes. Member Rucker? Yes. Member
Rodriguez? Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson? Yes and congrats to all of you. Member McQuillan? Yes.
Member Glover Woods? Yes. Member Escobedo? Yes. President Darlene Hammond? Yes. Member Burr?
Aye. Member Bonacca? Aye. Passes unanimously. Congratulations.
Terrific. Thank you so much Vice President Strauss, all the members of the screening committee
and to all the students who took the time to apply and participate in this process.
We're going to move on to item three and I'm going to pass the gavel to Vice President Strauss
for this next item. Thank you. So right now we're going to take up the item regarding the 2021
advisory board on education conference. This item will be presented by the student representatives
who participated in the 2021 student advisory board on education, the SABI annual conference.
This item has an addendum which is the 2021 SABI conference report. So let me just say again,
the students, things that students recommend to us at board meetings every November sometimes end
up in legislation like a student member on the instructional quality commission. The students
have incredible voices which you're going to hear now and at this time I'm going to ask
board member McQuillen and student board member Bonacca as this year's liaisons if they have any
comments to share given that they participated in the SABI conference earlier this week. Then after
their liaisons then we'll hear the presenters. So member McQuillen I'll call on you first.
Right, thank you. I would really ask our board to pay attention to these students. I learned so much
from working with them. I got to spend the afternoon with them this week at their conference and
helping to listen and prep them for the presentation and give feedback on these very
good presentations and I learned so much and it was fantastic. It was my pleasure to be a part of
it. You'll notice the topics they've chosen are very near and dear to our hearts and what we've
been working on these past 18 months through the pandemic. Diversity, equity and inclusion,
post high school preparation, student wellness, civic engagement, equitable education and
socioeconomic support. Very important topics to us all and I just want to congratulate all the
students for their work and it was fantastic. So thank you. Thank you. Member Bonacca do you
want to make any comments before the presentations? Yeah I just want to take a second to commend all
of the hard work and effort put in by every single delegate, every researcher, counselor and staff
member that were involved in making these proposals. I was able to see it firsthand this
past weekend at the conference and they never failed to impress me with their passion and
dedication to advocacy. Let's not forget that these students spent their precious weekend,
their Halloween weekend at that to create these proposals and I think that says a lot about their
character and just how determined and dedicated they are to improving schools not only for
themselves and their peers but also for all of the six million students in our state.
So again I just want to thank everyone involved in the SABE conference for their commitment to
ensuring that schools are equitable and instructional quality is ensured in our schools.
So at this time we have various presenters for the item. Each presenter will be introduced by
Stephanie Hu. We met Stephanie. She's the educational policy director of the California
Association of Student Councils, CASC and we'll have a brief introduction by Michelle Kim,
this year's state president of CASC. So I'm going to turn it over to Michelle and Stephanie
and would ask you to please begin. Thank you. Thank you so much. So good morning. My name is
Michelle Kim and I serve as the state president for the California Association of Student Councils
and I'm a senior at Portola High from the Irvine Unified School District. Two Superintendent Tony
Thurmond, President Darling Hammond, Vice President Strauss and esteemed members of the board,
I am honored and elated to introduce CASC proposals today with the support of our
incredible delegates and Director Stephanie Hu. I'm sure CASC already holds a dear place in all
of our hearts but as a refresher CASC has had the privilege to present proposals to the board since
1963 and has been instilling leadership and advocacy values in students since its establishment
in 1947 by the California Department of Education and the Association of California School
Administrators. As the primary beneficiaries of the education system and as youth in a generation
whose motivation for the improvement and advancement of public education seems to never end,
the students of CASC would like to extend our warmest gratitude to the board for continuing
to champion student voice through the Student Advisory Board on Education. We would especially
like to extend our thanks for keeping student perspective and wellness at the front of difficult
decisions especially after the pandemic's impact on our communities. Actions such as expanding
flexibility with school districts by continuing to use the shortened CASC test blueprints and
developing the ethnic studies model curriculum shows students and CASC delegates that the board
and Department of Education continues to prioritize youth before everything else.
This conference is significant for various reasons but I'd like to commend 12 exceptional
students who have served both CASC and their respective communities this weekend. To the
student board member semi-finalists, thank you for your contributions to our education system
and to our current student board member Rana Bananta, thank you for facilitating and mentoring
each of our semi-finalists as they progress through the SPM process. Before I pass the
virtual stage onto Stephanie, I'd like to take some time to recognize our amazing panelists
member Jim McKillen, Dennis Myers, Jonathan Peterson, and Sean Tenenbaum, as well as our
experienced consultants Margaret Ruiz and Hilva Chan. Finally, I'd like to send another thanks
to our extraordinary CASC State Council for all the hard work we've put in behind the scenes
and now Stephanie and our speakers. Thank you so much for that introduction, Michelle. Good
morning and thank you to the esteemed members of the board for allowing this amazing opportunity
once again. My name is Stephanie Hu and I am a senior at Tesora High School in the Capistrano
Unified School District, the education policy for the California Association of Student Councils,
the director of the Student Advisory Board on Education Conference 2021, or SAIP. Since 1963,
students from all of California have critiqued, assessed, and evaluate the state of their public
education and school systems at SAIP. During a normal year, we would all be in Sacramento
right now and the delegation of students would be sitting behind me, filling every available seat
and dress in their business professional attire. But today is different. Today, I sit before you
in front of a computer screen. As with the majority of everyday tasks and events, the
COVID-19 pandemic has forced us to adapt. This year's conference, too, took place virtually,
with each student connecting from their own home. It has been an absolute honor witnessing the
growth of our 60 delegates over the past three days. Their passion for their education, their
willingness to be flexible, and their desire to actively work for change are so evident,
even from a computer screen. As many students begin their transition from distance learning
to in-person learning, we are increasingly reminded of the critical perspectives of the
student voice. With COVID-19 and this transition amplifying the faults in our education system,
student feedback within education has never before been of greater consequence.
Because we are the ones who experience a California education system, the ones undergoing this
transition in learning, and the ones who wake up early in the morning to attend school,
every single proposal presented today was created entirely by students.
With this in mind, this year's delegates have had complete control of the topics presented to you.
Delegates debated, voted, and decided on six topics that truly embody what the delegation
views to be areas of concern in the California education system. These include diversity,
equity, and inclusion, post-high school preparedness, student wellness, civic engagement,
equitable education, and last but not least, socioeconomic support. Over the course of three
days, they took it upon themselves to compress all of our different perspectives, ideas, passions,
wants, and needs into six thorough proposals. I am confident that as the Student Advisory Board
on Education presents a proposal to combat the issues within and concerning our education system,
the members of the State Board of Education will be hearing the most pressing concerns
of the best student representatives of California. Our first presentation will be on the topic of
diversity, equity, and inclusion presented by Kavya Suresh. Thank you.
Good morning Superintendent Thurmond, Board President Darling-Hammond,
Vice President Strauss, and esteemed board members. My name is Kavya Suresh and I am a
sophomore attending San Marcos Senior High School in the Santa Barbara Unified School District.
On behalf of the Student Advisory Board on Education, the Diversity, Equity, and Inclusion
Group recommends that the State Board of Education collaborates with the California
Department of Education to create and recommend a framework for diversity, equity, and inclusion
professional development training for all employees of the California education system.
My first experience discussing my identity was in my English ethnic studies class in ninth grade.
Until that class, I had no idea how to describe my experience in the California education system.
I didn't know what to call it when teachers would pause before reading my name out loud and announce
it's too complicated so who is K-A-V-Y-A in front of the whole entire class. At the age of five,
being told I don't really belong here and my English will never be good enough by my teachers
and other school staff damaged my self-esteem and enabled my peers to be racist and xenophobic
without consequences. Though my ethnic studies class is one of the most valuable classes I've
ever taken, it could not reverse the years I had spent questioning the validity of my identity.
But we cannot continue waiting until students reach high school to teach them that their
intersectional identities are valid and beautiful. The important conversation about
anti-discrimination must start earlier. While there has been significant process in diversity,
equity, and inclusion, such as the passing of AB 101 regarding ethnic studies, these actions
are primarily relevant to high school students, meaning that the 68% of the California students
in elementary and middle schools remain without any instruction on important topics of identity.
A 2016 Stanford study found that a one-time intervention to help teachers and students
empathize with each other halved the number of suspensions at five diverse California middle
schools, and it significantly helped students who had previously been suspended to feel more
connected at their school. It's critical that we provide these necessary tools for all educators
to practice anti-discrimination, especially in early education, to promote empathetic educator
student relationships. Therefore, the Student Advisory Board on Education advises that the
State Board of Education work alongside the California Department of Education to create a
framework for DEI-centered professional development training for all California K-12 faculty,
staff, and board members. This comprehensive framework will further be made available to
all local education sites to be adapted on a district level and complement measures the
state has already taken, encompassing important topics such as racism, sexism, transphobia,
ableism, and religious discrimination. To ensure the impacts of all school faculty and staff
contribute to a positive school environment, we must provide educators the necessary training
to handle critical student issues surrounding DEI in California schools. Introducing topics
like identity to students from elementary school will help them build a better relationship with
their peers, trusted adults, and themselves. By encouraging educators to reimagine their
instructional practices and actively combat discrimination, we can empower marginalized
students to be advocates for their own education. As we continue to make revolutionary change in
our education system in resistance to oppression, we must train educators to properly facilitate
conversations surrounding identity starting in primary education. Through our solution,
I hope that stories like mine do not need to be repeated. I hope that every child gets their
preferred name read aloud correctly, that every child is able to proudly speak their native
language, and that every child develops a strong connection with their identity from an early age.
It is our greatest hope that you consider this proposal an opportunity to promote the development
of a more inclusive education system for the students of today and leaders of tomorrow.
Thank you for your time and consideration, and we welcome any feedback.
So I think what we're going to do is take a comment because we have six different topics. So
on this topic of diversity, equity, and inclusion, do we have any board
comments or questions before we go to the next one? And I'll start with Board Member Bonacca.
Well, first and foremost, I just want to thank you for creating this comprehensive proposal and
for all the work that you and your team put in throughout SAVE to create it. I really love the
fact that you're focusing on this issue through the lens of professional development for school
staff because they have such a significant role on setting the tone in the classroom and really
ensuring that all students feel included. I can personally still remember the days in elementary
school when my peers would call me a terrorist and what they saw as jokes. And I remember when
I reported this to my teacher, the best case scenario was that she would give them a light
warning and the worst case was she told me that they were just kidding and that I shouldn't take
it too seriously. But I remember that in neither scenario did she explain to them what they said
was wrong. And the more I've talked to students of color and marginalized groups, the more I realize
that this is essentially a universal experience that so many students have and it's truly unfortunate
to see. And that's why I think it's so important to approach this through the lens of professional
development because it's utterly important to see that all school staff are trained on how to
foster diversity and inclusion in our classrooms. And I can just say this from the perspective of
our district. We recently had a presentation from a researcher who's been studying our district.
His name is Dr. Aquanafua and he actually did something very similar. He researched the effects
of a teacher professional development training program which aimed to promote equity in schools
and every single outcome was improved after this program. So I know this is just one district but
it definitely gives me hope for this proposal. Again, thank you so much for all the hard work
that you put into it. Thank you board member Menaka. Member Glover-Woods. Thank you. I'd like
to also just thank everyone who worked so diligently on this proposal. It is such a critical one. As we
think about our steps in California into a society where everyone's lived experiences are
not only recognized but respected and valued where everyone in the diversity and identities of
all those who make up our great state again are respected and valued. A critical aspect of that
is in providing all of the educators and all of those who touch students with the professional
development and training and understanding respecting and valuing the lived experiences of
all who live in our state. So I just again thank all of you for this very timely proposal. It
definitely is a next step in our work to move forward so that no one has to experience some of
the experiences that many of you shared just a while ago. Thank you so much for this.
Thank you member Glover-Woods. Member Rucker. Thank you very much. I'm so pleased to be able to
meet all the students on this panel. As you pointed out last year we were not able to meet
in a face-to-face meeting. We were virtual and the same is true this year. If we were in the room
together I would have asked all of you to stand so that you could be recognized. I do appreciate
that we get a chance to see all of you and I also want to congratulate you for taking on and
choosing to tackle a very tough topic because this has very deep personal meaning for so many
students and your recommendation is coming at a time where legislators and school leaders
and other states are making connections about issues of diversity to conversations about
critical race theory or even seeing legislators outlawing the use of words like diversity
in education conversations at schools. So for you all to take this step and to be out front and so
forward thinking in your proposal is very important particularly at this time and I really do want to
congratulate you not only for the innovation but for the bravery that is required to be willing to
have this conversation and to be willing to be the face of that conversation. I personally in my
own work as a student as a teacher and then sitting on this panel there's always the means
about African-American women as angry black women that any woman who chooses to be assertive there
must be something wrong with you. For you all to take this step and to make these assertions
not only so intelligently but with such sophistication is not only a hallmark of
what your leadership skills are but also a fantastic note and representation not only
for the young women that you are representing on this panel but for all of the students whether
they are students who are students of color or not who could benefit from the work and the
initiative that you're recommending. So thank you so very much for this conversation and Kavya
I just want to tell you you did a fantastic job thank you very much. So thank you member
Rucker member Rodriguez. Yes hello I want to thank you for such an eloquent presentation
and I think that your beautiful words encapsulated so much pain students go
through when they don't feel like they're included in school. Myself included I got a
little teary as I was listening to your story and touching and this is very powerful and necessary
work because we want to make sure that all of our students feel like they belong that they're
included and that their sensitivity and receptivity reception with the adult in the room right that is
managing the the inclusion and for you to to bring out the statement is so important and so timely so
I last last year I geeked out a little too much listening to you all so I'm gonna I'm gonna tone
back a little bit but thank you. So just so you know we are really we have five more items that
are going to be equally as engaging and for those of you in the meeting just so you know we had the
a denim is attached to the item with the full report with all the specifics. I know our students
are so articulate but they also wrote that well as it's also effectively written as well so it's a
document I think all of us can look forward to to referring to and using going forward so at this
time we're going to hear topic two post high school preparedness presented by Mina Li.
Good morning esteemed board members my name is Mina Li and I am a senior attending John Marshall
Senior High School in Los Angeles Unified School District. I am here to speak on behalf of the
students of California who struggle with the lack of post high school preparedness. The Student
Advisory Board on Education has identified that students do not have easy access to the counselor
resources their school offers. We propose that on-site high school counselors are equipped with a
digital post high school readiness handbook approved by the California State Board of Education.
Each year hundreds of thousands of California students like myself are faced with the
predicament of what to do after high school. Notably most students are not aware of the many
routes they can take after high school. There seems to be only two clear options go to college
or don't go to college. While schools do provide counselors to help students there are often not
enough counselors to support everyone. Thus most are not properly counseled on deciding what they
will do after high school. For example at Bettman High School of Tustin Unified School District in
Irvine many students are unaware of the on-campus college and career resources. At Santiago High
School of Corona Norco Unified School District students are frustrated that counselors are not
able to provide the necessary resources and guidance for college application process.
Not only that at my school of John Marshall High School in Los Angeles Unified School District
career pathways are not widely promoted to students leaving those who are interested in
certain work fields with no support or resources provided by the school. Many of my friends are
interested in a career pathway post-graduation but could not find the resources being promoted
on campus which left them with no adult guidance at the beginning of the school year. Thankfully
our advisor teacher has been aiding them through the process. This shouldn't be happening. My
friends just like any other students in California deserve to have an adult support regardless what
path they choose to take. Counselors possessing and providing these resources and information
is vital for students. While counselors have access to resources this information is not enough
to help all students. For example there's little material surrounding topics such as interviewing,
resume building, and job training leaving students with no proper support or education.
These issues can further divide the racial and socioeconomic gaps within the school system.
For example students of higher income are able to afford private college preparatory classes
and counselors. However those who cannot afford these luxuries like myself and my peers are left
to fend for ourselves. To address these critical problems we strongly recommend that the California
State Board of Education to administer the creation of a digital handbook via the California
Department of Education. One that focuses on counselors rather than student conduct.
This digital handbook created by the California Department of Education shall not only be
distributed and directly introduced to counselors as part of their training
but shall also be accessible on the SBE website for the public to view.
Local school district boards will also be encouraged to utilize this resource via email
and other means of outreach. Topics in the handbook will include but are not limited to
guidelines for counselors on detailed office hours and school-wide meetings that counselors
can set up to ultimately help students make a rational and well-educated decision.
Educational partners such as students, counselors, administrators, and CTE industry workers will
contribute to the development of the handbook to ensure that it contains relevant and well-rounded
information on how counselors can guide their students. Every high school counselor in California
should be strongly recommended by the state and local board alike to use this resource to help
students in choosing a post-secondary school path that will set them up for success. The implementation
of the digital handbook is critical as existing counseling practices regarding post-secondary
education is less than adequate. On average, California schools hold a student to counselor
ratio of more than 600 to 1 respectively while the American Counselors Association recommends
a ratio of 250 to 1. The limited one-to-one interaction between students and counselors
is apparent and thus counselors must have reliable easy to access resources at their disposal.
We urge the state board to adopt this proposal. Counselors must know how to properly support and
communicate the resources available to students as they discern their post-high school path in
order for our students, for my peers, for myself to be well prepared. With this digital handbook,
students will not only feel empowered to make educated decisions about their future,
but will also be motivated to educate themselves with the different paths that await them post
graduation. Thank you for your time and consideration.
Mina, thank you so much. I will open it up for board comments starting with our student
board member, Manaka. Go ahead, please. Again, I want to thank you for this well
researched proposal. I really love the fact that you focus on the population of students who
aren't planning on attending college, because what I've observed as a student is that we place
such an emphasis on college, college, college students who aren't planning to go to college.
That's simply not just a bad thing that they're not going to college. I think it's somewhat
villainized in some students' eyes. If students want to go into a career that doesn't involve
college, then there's no need and they need to be educated about the alternate pathways.
For those students who aren't planning to attend college, they really don't need those counselors
telling them how to get into college. They really do need counselors who can help them navigate
post high school life and inform them about all the different steps that they can take to pursue
their ideal careers. I just want to underscore the fact that the pitfall of not emphasizing this
education enough is that the students who do plan to choose an alternate pathway that isn't
college don't have enough information to make well informed and good decisions moving forward.
They might end up with neither a college degree nor a career, which is not a great situation to
be in. I think this is a really great way of supporting those students who choose to pursue
these alternate pathways. Again, I want to thank everyone involved in creating this proposal.
Thank you. Member McQuillan.
Great presentation, Mina. Great job. I just think this topic is so important. Speaking as a
PPS credentialed person, my training was many years ago, well over 20 years ago.
A digitized handbook to standardize some of the model practices would be fantastic for
California schools. Great recommendation. Thank you for presenting this. Thank you very much.
Okay. I'm going to see if we have any other board comments. Again, we have
four more, so stay tuned. Here's our next one. We're going to hear about student wellness,
and that's going to be presented by Alicia del Toro. COVID-19 has been a time of loss
for all of us. Many of us as students have had to navigate our education while facing traumatizing
personal hardships. I think this is best demonstrated by the experiences of my good friend
whose father is a doctor. There have been periods in the past year where you could not see him for
weeks at a time. Worrying about his father's safety, his own academics, and an unsure future
understandably pushed him into a terrible mental state. Although coming back to campus had its own
struggles, he was finally able to return to a safe place, the wellness center. It was so important
for him to have someone to listen to his story and provide support. I can say with confidence
that a wellness center saved his life and the lives of many others.
Good morning, esteemed board members. My name is Alicia del Toro, and I am a sophomore at St.
Francis High School. We recognize that the state has already made efforts to strengthen the mental
well-being of students, as well as the implementation of various task forces. However,
in my experience, mental health has still deteriorated within my high school as well
as many others across California as we return to in-person education. Recent statistics show
that 32% of students who were not receiving mental health support feel that they are now needed,
and over half of California students need mental health support. In addition, 23% of students have
rated their mental wellness at a three or less on a scale of one to ten post-pandemic, which
requires immediate attention. Upon further investigation into the wellness of the student
body across the state, the most recurring vocabulary used to describe one's mental state
were words such as lonely, overwhelming, and anxious. In my own friend group, I've heard jokes
about serious mental health consequences, including suicide, on a frequent basis.
As a student in the current education system, it is heartbreaking to see my peers share these
feelings. As opposed to the current state we are in, K-12 schools should strive to foster an
environment that destigmatizes mental health, while providing students with access to resources
and facilities that support their well-being. The overall wellness of students should rise
by addressing issues present in both school and home environments, while actively encouraging open
communication and trust between teachers, parents, and students. Students should be able to feel that
their well-being is prioritized in the education system. My counselor group and I dove into the
question of, why is this not the case? We concluded that this is due to a lack of prioritization of
mental health in schools, which has led to a lack of awareness within parents, students,
and administrators. As a result, seeking help for mental health is stigmatized in schools all over
California, where many students think they can only receive help for severe mental health illnesses.
Thus, in direct relation to the issue at hand, the Student Advisory Board on Education strongly
recommends that districts implement and customize a blueprint for wellness centers that provide
professional help, education, and overall support for student mental health. We recommend that
schools utilize pre-existing resources and blueprints from the Community Preventative
Services Task Force, California School-Based Health Alliance, etc., that will outline the basic
functions and organization of a wellness center, including lounge areas or rooms for relaxation,
readily available counselors, snacks, medical supplies, and music functions.
The center itself will vary based on different districts, but the goal is to provide an area
of safety and comfort for all students. Although student well-being will never be in a perfect
state, wellness centers take a step in the right direction by helping students across California
reach a healthy state of mind. By establishing wellness centers, we are setting up a tangible
pillar of support for all students, ensuring that no student feels alone in their struggles.
In my high school, the wellness center is a popular hub that many students turn to when
feeling stressed or need advice from a mental health professional. There have been multiple
cases where a friend was having a mental health crisis, but they were able to visit the wellness
center, collect themselves, and return to class. Had the center not been an option, they would have
had to leave school and miss out on their education. Due to the long-term implications of the pandemic
on mental health, it is a necessity, not a luxury, for schools to provide student wellness centers
as a designated safe space students can turn to and receive adequate support, ultimately allowing
for students to reach their maximum potential. Thank you for your time. I will now open the
floor to any feedback. Thank you so much, Alicia. I'm going to turn the comments over first to
member Escobedo for his comments. I just want to say how I applaud you, Alicia. The mental health
not only is the stigma, but also the access to services. Our board will be looking at this
community school concept, and hopefully this could really push forward the whole aspect of
minimizing the stigma and having immediate access for students and adults who are suffering from
mental health issues. Thank you for bringing this to the forefront. Thank you, member Escobedo.
Member McQuillen. Good job, Alicia. I really appreciated your presentation. Fantastic.
For bringing this topic to our attention, we know some schools have wellness centers, others are
just starting out, and some have not even begun to do it. Thank you for bringing this important
topic to our attention. The wellness of our students coming out of the pandemic is so important
in order to get to the reading, writing, and arithmetic. We know mental health is so important,
so thank you and great presentation. I'm going to turn it over, and I apologize to Stephanie
Hu and Michelle Kim, who are our liaisons, to introduce the next one. I apologize.
Our next presenter will be Jennifer Tran on civic engagement.
Good morning, President Darling-Hampton and esteemed board members. My name is Jennifer Tran.
I'm a senior at Bolsa Grande High School in the Garden Grove Unified School District.
I'm here to present to you the student advisory board's education civic engagement proposal.
I am not speaking to you today as just another student, but as a first-generation student,
as a minority student, and as a student living below the California poverty level. Statistically,
immigrants, lower socioeconomic status, and minority children are considerably less likely
to grow up into informed and engaged citizens. Historically, these groups have significantly
lower voter turnout and community participation rates as adults. These differences can be
drastic, with voter turnout rates for higher-income citizens almost doubling that of lower-income
citizens. All the odds, all the statistics say that I shouldn't be here right now,
in front of you, civically engaged, and trying to better our education system. But I am. How is this
possible? It's because I was able to find the necessary resources through networking, friends,
and honestly mindless internet scrolling to find my voice in the system early on. My civic
participation today will undoubtedly translate to a bright future of civic engagement. A 2019 study
by the University of California Los Angeles shows that student civic engagement breeds citizen
civic engagement. By encouraging students to be aware, knowledgeable, and especially engaged in
systems of power as young adults, we can almost completely eliminate the disparity in participation
of marginalized groups. In the past, through programs such as the Seal of Civic Engagement
and the Civic Learning Award, the State Board has recognized civic engagement as an important
factor of a quality education. But many of these programs are just simply not accessible to all
students. We must acknowledge the ever-growing achievement gap when it comes to opportunities
in or even knowledge about civic engagement. In many of these marginalized groups, there's a
misunderstanding of what civic engagement is and what it pertains to. Being a district student
board member myself and consistently engaging in systems of power around me, I realized that
civic engagement can be something as simple as working on a student advisory board or being in
a voter registration drive. However, some students may unintentionally politicize civic engagement,
causing them and others to stray away from it due to the stigmatization. That is why we need to reach
into these groups, redefine civic engagement as an everyday action, and redefine the student role
not as subjects but as collaborators and stakeholders within our own education. We, the
Student Advisory Board on Education, recommend that the State Board of Education implement an
additional seventh goal regarding civic engagement within the equity section of the Quality Schooling
Framework. We recommend this seventh goal read. Goal seven, quality schools will provide equitable
access to civic engagement opportunities and applicable civic education to all students.
High quality schools recognize the need for equitable access to civic engagement opportunities
and applicable civic education, understanding that is a key aspect of people education and
post-high school civic preparedness. In fulfilling this goal, LEAs ensure that students have accessible
avenues to participate in civic engagement, including but not limited to school site councils,
voter registration, district board meetings, and advocacy training. Reward students who demonstrate
excellence in civics education and participation and understanding of the United States Constitution,
the California Constitution, and the democratic system of government and equip students for a
lifetime of civic engagement. We hope the solution can act as a stepping stone, creating a ripple
effect for the statewide recognition of civic engagement as it sets a concrete goal for districts
regarding civic engagement, encouraging LEAs to promote and record present levels of student
involvement. Despite its simplicity, its fundamentality is ever-present. Civic engagement
must become a priority and a goal for districts. I know from firsthand experience that civic
engagement not only encourages academic success and extracurricular involvement, but also prepares
students to be lifelong active and informed constituents. This is especially important for
lower socioeconomic status students, such as myself, who may struggle with school because of
that lack of connection to their community. This additional goal in the quality schooling framework
reaches out to schools, reaches out to districts, and really portrays and emphasizes the importance
of civic engagement within a quality education, laying out the base for a future of total immersed
student civic engagement. We must remember that we are not just teaching the students of today,
but raising the citizens, the voters, and the constituents of tomorrow, and thus must make their
participation and knowledge of the system they live ever so presently in a priority and an aspect
of a true quality education. Thank you. Thank you, Jennifer. So we'll turn to board member
comments. So we'll start with member Bonica. Well, first I want to thank you and your team
for creating this detailed proposal. Just in terms of the technical parts, I really love how
you approach the implementation of civic education and civic engagement through adding a goal in the
quality schooling framework. I think that's quite a unique way of approaching it, and I also love
that you give a lot of flexibility to LEAs to determine how they want to implement it in the
way that they see best fit. But just in general, I think civic education and civic engagement
is so important to students and the wider community because it not only informs decision makers and
policy makers on student perspectives, but I think it also really empowers students to stand up for
themselves and others, and that's not just in, you know, politics and policy, but just in every
other aspect of their life. Really, it teaches them how to stand up for what they believe in,
and I think it just gives them confidence in themselves and in the systems that are affecting
them. So again, I want to thank you for this proposal. I think it's really great.
Ronna, thank you so much. Member Escobedo, you have your hand up?
Sorry, I forgot to take mine down last time.
Okay. Okay. Do we have any other board member comments on civic engagement? Member McQuillin.
Great job, Jennifer. I appreciated this presentation so much. You know, it's made
me think about all the different ways that different groups can be civically involved,
you know, and for tribal members throughout California, it's very different to be involved
in your tribal government or your ceremonies and giving back that way to the community and
being involved that way. So I really appreciate this presentation. Thank you. Thank you, Member
McQuillin. So seeing no more hands, I'm going to turn it back to Stephanie and Michelle for the
introduction for the next item. Next presenter will be Lynda Nong on equitable education.
Good morning, esteemed members of California Board of Education. I'm going to be quite open here.
I'm a person that zones out a lot. I found myself zoning out during the lecture in my AP United
States history class, and when I eventually returned to Earth, I realized that I have just
missed an important topic and I'm forced to rely on my peers to catch me up to speed.
It is not that I don't care about school. I love being able to learn alongside my peers,
but when the information being taught does not connect to me or allows for engagement,
it is hard for me and so many other students to stay focused. My name is Lynda Nong and I'm a
junior at Portola High School in the Irvine Unified School District in Orange County.
I am honored to be representing the California Association of Student Councils and promote
equitable education within California. It is apparent now more than ever that not all students
in California are receiving an equitable quality of education. Many students are disengaged with
their curriculum since it often does not connect to them personally or it does not feed their
learning needs. For example, at Portola High School, there is very little required reading
written by authors of colors in the English curriculum. Additionally, some students struggle
to sit through hours of lectures because they experience ADHD symptoms that go ill-advised and
unaddressed. In these cases, students' learning needs are often voiced but not properly acted upon
by school's faculty. Additionally, many schools have poor communication between students and
counselors, making the course selection process very inconvenient. This situation leads to a
general dissatisfaction among students regarding their academic future. We also notice the trends
of students being uncomfortable with taking surveys that ask for student feedback because
their personal information is collected or that they're not aware that the results are anonymous
and this deters the students from providing their honest opinions. In light of these concerns,
we recommend that the California Department of Education provide a blueprint called Race in
School Equity or RISE for short, which function as a general guideline that champions a more
equitable education in the California schooling system. Considering that there is no one-size-fits-all
solutions, local school districts are given the ability to implement RISE as they see fit.
Once approved, the RISE blueprint will be shared with all California school districts
through usual distribution methods, providing them with resources to improve their existing systems.
A core part of our vision for RISE is outlining tangible and feasible practices that can be easily
integrated with existing curriculums. The California Department of Education will take
into account of the voices and opinions of students, teachers, administrators, and parents
from various cultures, races, genders, language abilities, disabilities, socioeconomic statuses,
and academic proficiencies to create this blueprint. This blueprint recommends professional
development courses for teachers that allow students to choose multiple forms of learning
and promote more frequent and accessible means of communication with faculty and students,
catering to our students' preferences. For example, allowing anonymous forms of communication
between students and administrators will allow for more honest feedback. Additionally, this blueprint
will peel red districts with survey templates that gather data and voices from the students.
By accommodating the learning needs of all student groups, these students will have a chance
to receive information more equitably and comprehensively. This will translate into an
increased student motivation to engage with the school curriculum, making the overall learning
environment more inclusive and effective. By improving communication, schools will better
understand student needs and opinions, which will ultimately enhance productivity. We believe that
all students deserve equitable educational opportunities holistically by having a class
and setting curriculum that best suits them. Students should feel and be supported by the
school staff through the use of diverse teaching methods and efficient methods of communication.
Thank you for your time. Thank you so much for that presentation.
I'm going to first call on Member Darling-Hammond for comments.
President Darling-Hammond? Yeah, I have to get myself off of mute.
It's always the challenge, right? First, I just want to say I've been enjoying all of the
presentations and really appreciate all of the great thinking from, you know, civic engagement to
diversity, equity, and inclusion, and all of the other topics. This one is near and dear to my
heart because I'm an educational researcher when I'm not sitting at the state board table, and I
just want to say that I think your recommendations are very thoughtful, and they're really rooted in
a lot of research on both how people learn and how, you know, effective teaching unfolds. So
I think you're on very solid ground, and your examples are very telling and very much rooted
in what we know from the science and the research on learning, development, and teaching. So I
appreciate you raising this, and I think that, you know, to the degree that we've got a lot of
additional resources finding their way to the field for professional development, as you called
for, and how we shape that, I think, should be informed by the thinking that you presented. So
thank you very much. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. Member Rucker.
Thank you very much. I hadn't commented on the previous couple of presentations, but I'm glad
to follow our board president in commenting on this because not only is the topic you raised
about student support and paying attention to student learning needs important, but it's also
very, very prescient. With California doing an annual healthy student survey,
a lot of the recommendations you made also, to me, has impact and even informed some decisions
about the kinds of items or questions that are included for students in the survey. Because while
we make a lot of assumptions about what students do and how students make decisions about school
and coursework and even the relationship they have with their parents and supporting them through
school, there are some critical relationships at the school campus that really do not get full
consideration in the kinds of school planning we are currently doing to improve student support for
our school. So I really appreciate not only the thoughtfulness for your recommendation, but the
attention to this particular topic that doesn't always get the full consideration for school
planning and school improvement that we really should have. And while we may not be able to act
on it for a separate item, we'll be looking at content item five and updating the LCAP template.
I think our future conversations about student support and student support services will really
be informed by your recommendations. So Ms. Nong, I do really want to thank you and appreciate
your ideas and your very, very important recommendations in this report. And thank
your team as well. Member McQuillin. Great presentation, Linda. Good work. I agree with
what's been said so far and the feedback. And I remember some of the feedback in our prep for this
that some of the training you're talking about is involved in teacher preparation programs now,
but we know so many of our professionals have been out of their training for a few years,
so we need to make sure that this professional development is incorporated to all districts
currently. So again, thank you for your presentation and great work.
Thank you. Stephanie and Michelle, I'll turn it over to you for our final item.
Our final presentation will be on the topic of socioeconomic support presented by Audrey Hong.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond and esteemed board members. My name is Audrey
Hong and I'm a junior attending Beckman High School in the Tustin Unified School District.
On behalf of the Student Advisory Board of Education, we strongly recommend the State
Board of Education develop a plan for local education agencies to better communicate to
both students and parents about accessible resources. As a student from Beckman High
School, I'm not always exposed to the struggles of socioeconomic setbacks on a daily basis.
Growing up on this bubble led me to be unable to identify the countless struggles
experienced by students of low socioeconomic status. This all changed when I partnered with
Skyview three years ago. Skyview is a public school in Anaheim that serves homeless families
throughout Orange County. My many experiences with this organization, from cleaning the resource
center to partaking in reading workshops with special needs students, my eyes are truly open.
I was able to connect with these students and I felt their passion for their education and how
they have fought through countless socioeconomic setbacks that the education system predisposed
into. When discussing educational issues with nine students from different and diverse areas
in California, exposed the disproportionate struggles students of low socioeconomic
backgrounds face. I'm sure all of you are aware that schools lack adequate methods of relaying
information on accessible resources such as scholarship opportunities, job opportunities,
or peer tutoring to help students of all socioeconomic backgrounds, especially students
coming from low-income families. At Northwood High School in Irvine, a student wanted a Chinese
dictionary for the PSDT but was unable to access it. In Solano County, a student wanted to join
extracurriculars such as cheer but was unable to join because they could not afford the gear.
In Lincoln High School in San Joaquin County, a student was unable to buy the textbook and felt
too uncomfortable to ask the teacher for accommodations. Many students throughout California
are unable to pay for the AP exams that they want to take, afford private tutoring, or even spend
adequate time on schoolwork as they carry the additional responsibility of financially supporting
their family. This sets different students on different tracks for success from the very beginning.
We do not believe that it's the school's resources that are causing these issues,
but the lack of awareness of the free and equitable resources that our schools have been
given to students. We are not proposing to create new resources or implementations in California
schools, but to recommend the State Board of Education to develop a plan for local education
agencies to better communicate to both students and parents about these accessible resources.
This framework is geared towards all students in K-12 to help them navigate their education
through free and equitable resources and therefore shaping a more independent generation of the
future. This implementation of this communication plan by the California Department of Education
will not only ensure that students are aware of these opportunities, but will acknowledge
and respond to students' concerns and struggles. The communication plan would provide various ways
to promote opportunities for students that give districts options to what would work best for
the student population, ensuring better awareness of opportunities given to students. We are wanting
to improve the evident achievement gap in California education. The California Assessment of
Student Performance and Progress revealed that nearly two-thirds of students from low-income
families did not meet grade-level standards, while one-third of students not within the low
income category exceeded standards. As these findings show, it is critical to ensure that
one's income does not determine their quality of education. Our proposal will ensure that all
students have access to educational resources including scholarship opportunities, job resumes,
tutoring services, and financial support. Today, I'm speaking on behalf of that student who's unable
to access free tutoring, for that student who's working every day after school to support their
family, and for those students that I met at Skyview who are not conscious of their limitless
potential that they hold. As we, the students, are the primary partners of our education,
it is crucial that all students are given the tools to succeed. And for these reasons, in order
to better communicate to both students and parents, we recommend the State Board of Education develop
a plan for local education agencies regarding accessible resources. I hope that the State of
California can open the way towards an education system that gives equal opportunity for all
students, regardless of their socioeconomic status or their identity. Thank you for your time and I
welcome any feedback. Thank you so much, Audrey. I have to say I so appreciate all the students
making this a personal connection to their own personal experience, giving us specifics from
their own school and district experiences, and then adding resources and research that they did
to support the proposal. So I just think it is so articulate and well prepared and I just so appreciate
listening to it. With that, I'm going to call on board member Banaka first. Please go ahead with
your comments. Thank you. And again, I just wanted to thank you all for creating this really
comprehensive proposal. I know coming from a school where a vast or rather an overwhelming
majority of students are socioeconomically disadvantaged, I have personally seen the
extent to which socioeconomic status affects academic success. And I think that most of this
is really it boils down to a discrepancy between the resources and opportunities that wealthy and
not wealthy students utilize. And the reason why I think this is such a great proposal is because
many students simply aren't aware of the resources that are already in place. And that doesn't do
anyone any good if no one knows what resources are already in place, because then they'll never get
used to their fullest ability. So I really like the way that you approach this issue. And I again
want to commend you for all the hard work and effort that you put into this proposal.
Thank you for your comments. President Darling-Hammond.
I also want to thank you for the proposal and just note that we've been on a path in California
toward trying to invest more equitably in schools through the more progressive formula for funding
from local control funding formula and the recent allocations of funds for recovery from the
pandemic from both the federal and state governments. And I think your comments
really put a fine point on how those resources should be spent to really most effectively
support students who deserve and require the kind of supports that other families
can sometimes purchase from disposable income. So I think you've raised some really excellent
points. And we're actually in a position to take advantage of that kind of advice
as we think about how to allocate these new resources. Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
Member McQuillen. Great presentation, Audrey, and a great topic. You know, it reminds me of
all the channels we need to make sure we're using to get the word out to families that resources
do exist. You know, there are alternative channels that need to be exercised. You know,
not all of our families have good stable internet. You know, there's embarrassment to consider
of students and families who don't ask. And then what you brought up, there are other things
happening for families where maybe the student has become the caretaker. So you brought up so
many good points that we need to be reminded of throughout California. So thank you for your
presentation. Great topic. Thank you, Member McQuillen. Member Rucker. Well, thank you very
much for your comments and your report on this very sensitive topic. And I agree with everything
our board president and my colleague, Jim McQuillen, stated about this issue. My entire teaching
career, I worked in a low wealth district. Low wealth because that was the size of the budget
in that district. When I started teaching, my salary was $9,000 a year. And that wasn't back
in 1940. It was in the latter part of the 20th century. That's still a long time ago, but that's
beside the point. But also it was a low wealth district because the majority of students
came from families that received some form of public assistance or even were in foster care.
So the issues and conditions for student learning and the issues and conditions that I worked in as
a teacher were not unknown. And surprisingly, they have not changed really over time. But while it's
not unknown, I have to say I have never heard the issues and those conditions so eloquently
addressed as you did today without politicizing the disparity in economic opportunity and resource
equity issues that low wealth schools and the students that attend them have. So not only do
I appreciate the way that you framed the issue, but also how you very clearly articulated the very
specific examples of what the impacts are and what's not being considered and planning how to
support and provide resources to these families without embarrassing students, without requiring
students and their families to respond or have to ask, you know, why do you need to have people ask
for something when we already know what the circumstances are that they are dealing with?
So I do appreciate not only the report that your team put together, but the way you framed how the
recommendations can actually be successfully implemented as a function of doing their LCAP
planning for any school side of school district where these issues are not only clear and apparent,
but are actually the norm, not the exception. I also appreciate your sensitivity and your attention
to the privilege that you've been able to enjoy and why you're concerned personally about why this
should make a difference for everyone. I was actually moved emotionally when you made that
point. So thank you so very much and congratulations on a job well done.
So thank you very much for your comments, Member Rucker. I really appreciated that and I know the
students do as well. Do we have any other board member comments before we go to public comment?
Stephanie and Michelle, do you have any comments that you want to share as the coordinators?
Yes, I would just like to once again thank the esteemed board members for listening to our
proposals from this year's SAIP Conference and for providing such valuable feedback and support. I
sincerely, sincerely hope that very shortly we can turn these ideas that started in Zoom breakout
rooms into actions implemented by you, the SAIP Board of Education. Thank you again.
Well, I have to say to the students, the energy they put in over Halloween weekend
weekend and I know they spend days and nights and hours writing and drafting the presentation.
We're going to now stop for public comment on item three. The call-in number is on the slide,
712-770-4991. There's an access code 396-1805. So we will now turn over to public comment.
So please turn your volume of your computer down and when it's your turn, then operator will
announce that it's your time to speak. Do we have any public comments for this item?
We do not have public comment for item three. So Pam, do you say there are no public comments?
There are no public comments for item three. Okay, thank you so much. So we'll go back to
board members for final comments on this. If there are any. Member McQuillan.
I just want to congratulate all the students, you know, and I learned so much from all of you.
You know, this is what it's all about, you know, the work that we do to serve you, the students,
and you're the voice for the California students. I'm just so pleased with all the
presentations. So thank you. Thank you very much. And UROCs would say walk thou,
walk thou, and that's a heartfelt thank you in the UROC language.
Member Banaka. Yeah, I would just like to echo Member McQuillan's remarks. I want to commend
every single person that was involved in creating these proposals. As I said before,
I got to see firsthand how much hard work and effort went into this. It's incredible and
baffling, and I hope that everyone could see it at one point in their lives because before then,
I had never seen so many students that were so dedicated and so hardworking, willing to spend
their Halloween weekend, as I said before, their Halloween weekend, creating these proposals. So
again, a big congratulations to all the students involved. Member Rodriguez.
Also, I want to echo what's been said, and my hope is that you can look back in a few years and see
how your dedicated leadership has created change, and I really appreciate your sensitivity,
your compassion, your experiences, and especially your voice. Thank you so much.
So I just want to comment that we had six amazing teams. So for all the students who are
did this remotely on top of all their schoolwork and commitment, I want to thank our group one,
Diversity, Equity, Inclusion. Amazing work. Great message. Again, this is on our addendum
attached to the board agenda for the public to access for additional follow-up.
Topic two was post high school preparedness. Topic three, student wellness.
Topic four, civic engagement. Topic five, equitable education, and topic six, socioeconomic support.
So relevant to the work we're talking about and all the connections to all the work in schools.
Students, on behalf of the state board, we thank you so much for your time and commitment,
and trust us that your message and specifics will carry forward into our work.
So thank you very, very much. And with that, this does end our presentations
for this item, and we will now take a 10-minute break. So it is 1045 on my clock, so we will
come back at 1055. So thank you all very much. Board members, please turn off your cameras
and your microphones. Thank you. Thank you all back, and we need to reestablish
a quorum, so Brooks, please call the roll. Member Sun. Here. Vice President Stroud. Here.
Member Rucker. Present. Member Rodriguez.
I can see member Rodriguez. Member Petillo-Brownson. Here. Member McQuillan.
Here. Member Glover-Woods. Here. Member Escobedo. Here. President Darling-Hammond. Here. Member Burr.
Here. Member Bonacca. Here. We have a quorum.
Terrific. At this point, I will reopen agenda item one and turn it over to the state superintendent
to provide his report. Good morning, Madam President, Vice President, members of the board.
Thank you for the opportunity to share with you just a few key highlights and to take any questions
that you may have about a number of initiatives that are taking place at the Department of
Education. Many of them you already know because I've seen many of you at many of the meetings,
board liaisons and others present at the meetings. As I begin, I want to just recognize the moment
in time where we are. Still probably the most difficult time that we'll experience in our
lifetime, but our schools are open and we're keeping students safe and families safe and we're
doing all that we can to make sure that they can be safe and can learn. In that respect,
I want to commend our students. I want to commend educators, family members, the entire
community for being resilient and doing the things that we need to do to overcome
what the coronavirus has presented to us. As I mentioned, our schools are open and have been
open and as I said at the last report in the last board meeting, I've had a chance to visit
many many of our schools as they reopen. As you know, some schools have experienced challenges in
how to deal with quarantine conditions and but overall our schools have found the way to stay
open and stay safe and to do so at a rate is much higher than almost any other state. When it comes
to school closures, school closures in California happen at about 1 12th the national rate and I
emphasize that to say that what everyone is doing is working. Using vaccines, rapid COVID testing
and all the things that social distancing, disinfecting our schools, every aspect of our
school community is making this happen and so we're grateful for that. Obviously big things are
happening around the questions of vaccines. By some October numbers, nearly 60 percent of
California students between the ages of 12 and 17 have received a vaccine. We're pivoting our focus
to more vaccines because the delta variant demands it. We have learned that that the delta variant
is more resistant to many vaccines and so Californians are beginning to get their boosters.
I had a chance to get my booster last week at a great event at La Clinica, I'm sorry, at Ultimed
in Southgate and a chance to really say to the world let us lean into vaccines especially now
that we have approvals for students between the ages of five and 17. And so we need to work to
amplify the importance of vaccines and of course foreshadowing where we think the state will be
heading with the vaccine requirement that will be for students. By my notes, we expect that in just
in several months, students in grades seven through 12 by 2022, in July of 2022, will be
required to have a vaccine and that shortly thereafter that grades K through six will have
the opportunity to have a vaccine according to the requirement. And we look forward to working
closely with everyone, every aspect of the governor's office, the state board of education,
the department of public health, and school leaders on how that rollout will take place.
We've had many conversations already with school leaders to hear their thoughts, their questions,
their concerns about what a new mandate might look like. And we have some run-up time,
we have some lead time to really work through what implementation might look like. I also want to
commend our school communities that have been impacted by fire. As if the coronavirus challenges
weren't enough, many of our communities have been impacted by fire. As if dealing with racial
injustices was not enough, we have probably some 19 counties that have seen that they've been
impacted by fire. I want to give a great shout out to our emergency services team that has worked
with these school communities to get them resources, to connect the resources, to work
through the requirements for FEMA, for other agencies that offer support, to work with the
various offices like the Office of Emergency Services and others that have been providing
support, and that who've worked with our CDE Foundation to raise a few dollars to provide
gas cards and you know cards for food and hotel expenses and things of that nature.
We know that it's a huge challenge, but again we want to commend those who are showing resiliency
and finding ways to ensure that our students continue to learn. As we think about this shift
of approvals for young children between the ages of five and 11 to get a vaccine,
we are accelerating our outreach efforts. Many of you know that I've been working with a group
called Andele Que Esperas, hurry up why you wait, hurry up why wait. This is a statewide campaign
that is reaching out to 4.5 million Latinos in the state to ensure that there's great outreach
in English and in Spanish to support vaccine outreach. And so as I mentioned, four and a half
million folks will be reached. Anyone can get information at 855.yaandele or andelequeesperas.com.
It's been a great partnership with organizations like AltaMed and other federally qualified health
clinics that are supporting vaccine outreach to some of the communities that are facing the
highest level of risk for COVID infection. And so we hope to reach four and a half million folks
throughout our state and to engage many many. I want to think aspirationally for a second.
Many of you know that during the last weeks we have announced some new initiatives at the department
that the state board has been a great partner in. We're excited to talk about an effort to
ensure that all students read by third grade and we've given ourselves a homework assignment to
say that that should happen by 2026. And so with that we have a task force that will be making
recommendations on how to get us to reading by third grade by 2026. And we've made a part of
that strategy getting a million books in the hands of students who have need. Many have already come
forward and made donations. Thank you to those who've heard our call for books. We'll continue to
work with groups like First Five California on how to get book donations to support California
students. For those who would like to support by making a donation, send us a note at state
literacy campaign at cde.ca.gov. We're grateful for those of you who've already stepped up. And
of course I want to thank Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond for being among those who will be helping us in
leading this effort as one of our co-chairs of this task force on reading by third grade.
I've also named a task force that is focused on supporting the needs of black students in our
state. And as you all know, I'm deeply committed to supporting all of our students. But recognizing
that gaps have not closed at the same rate as they have for other groups, that gaps for black
students have not closed at the same rate, we are going to accelerate our efforts in supporting
black students and be explicit about the need for addressing disproportionality, the impacts of
systemic racism, the impacts of segregated schools, and the impacts of poverty and other
conditions that affect the socioeconomic status of many of our students. And so this task force
will also be making recommendations for how we will look at every single item where there's
disproportionality affecting black students, whether that's graduation rates, chronic absenteeism,
suspensions and expulsions, how do we provide more professional development and diversification
of our school workforces to support them. I'm grateful that we also have board member Patil
Bronson working closely with this task force and helping us as a member of the task force
and helping us to move forward. Many have asked why. Why name these task forces now?
If you take a look at the most robust state budget that I think we have seen for education
and who knows how long, I feel as though we have the resources and we have the will to get this
done. When you think about $4.3 billion for mental health, when you think about universal TK
available for every four-year-old, universal meals for any hungry student, universal expanded
learning, $10 million for anti-racism grants, you think about all these things linked together.
There are many, many investments in the state budget that focus directly on professional
development to support literacy. I was grateful to be with board member Burr about a week ago
at CCEE where we had a robust discussion about grants that will be available for expanded learning
with a focus on reading and math and science. All that to say that we have the resources
that we need to move this forward. And certainly none more important than nearly $3 billion
in community schools investments. I know that that is scheduled to be discussed at a later
point in this meeting. I just would be remiss to not recognize the important transformative effect
that community schools can have, both on wraparound services for students as we try to
recover from the trauma of the pandemic, but also to address issues around racial justice
and social justice. These will be important resources. And you will hear in the days and
weeks to come that I'll be appointing a steering committee that will speak to, you know, a broad
representation of interests and how to guide the community school strategy. All of these things
together, I believe, will help us to have a breakthrough in how we support black students,
how we reach reading by third grade. I thank all the board members who have been in these
conversations so far. Thank you, Board Member McQuillin, for joining the meetings that we've had
with our American Indian Education Oversight Committee, really helping us to center our
efforts to support our Native American students. It was an honor to give testimony in a specialized
committee, a joint committee, through the Assembly Education and Select Committee on Native American
interests and needs, and to continue to figure out how we change the narrative about reducing
chronic absenteeism, about increasing graduation, about supporting Native American students,
and about recasting what gets taught in our schools as it relates to Native American studies.
We know that there is an opportunity for us to broaden what gets taught there. And again,
thank you, Board Member McQuillin, for joining those meetings. Thank you, Board Members, for
hearing these highlights. Thank you for your interest and your energy in supporting our students.
Thank you to all of the staff at the California Department of Education,
and all of the staff at the State Board of Education for continuing to do incredible work
in these very, very difficult times. I just want to show my appreciation and acknowledgement for
all of you. And then, Madam President, this concludes my report, and I'd be happy to take
any questions that you and board members may have. Thank you very much. Seeing no hands raised,
we'll go on to item number five, which is the Local Control and Accountability Plan template,
the adoption of the revised Local Control and Accountability Plan template,
and the template for the one-time supplement to the annual update to the 2021-22 Local Control
and Accountability Plan. And the CDE recommends that we adopt the proposed revisions to the
LCAP template and the proposed draft of the supplement template and instructions,
and allow the CDE, in collaboration with State Board staff, to make any necessary
typographical or formatting corrections as the documents are prepared for posting
on the CDE website. And this item will be presented by Lindsay Ternetour
and Josh Strong of the CDE. Lindsay, please begin.
Good afternoon. Sorry. Let me get the height adjustment.
All right. Good afternoon. Good morning. Sorry. Good morning still. President Darling-Hammond,
Chief Deputy Nicely, members of the board, Executive Director Allen. It is my pleasure
to be here with all of you again today. My name is Lindsay Ternetour, and I'm the Director of the
Student Achievement and Support Division. I am joined today again by my colleague, Joshua Strong,
who is the Administrator of the Local Agency System Support Office, or LASSO, in the Student
Achievement and Support Division. Josh and I are here to provide an update on the five proposed
revisions to the Local Control and Accountability Plan as prescribed by SB 98 and AB 130,
which were introduced and discussed during the September 2021 SBE meeting. Specifically,
we will revisit each of the five revisions and focus on the following three questions.
Since the September SBE meeting, what have our educational partners been saying about the
revisions? How is our educational partner input included in the proposed revisions of the templates
and instructions? And how will the CDE support capacity building to implement the proposed
revisions following the anticipated board adoption today? During the September State Board meeting,
we heard the concerns and comments from all of you regarding the length and complexity of the LCAP.
We have prepared for all of your consideration today a few areas that will help to reduce the
length of the plan effective for the 22-23 LCAP. Finally, this presentation will conclude with an
overview of the CDE's next steps for supporting all LEAs in implementing the new requirements to
the LCAP following today's anticipated board action. Item five today is an action item,
and therefore the CDE respectfully brings the following recommendation for your consideration.
The CDE recommends that the State Board of Education adopt the proposed revisions to the
LCAP template and the proposed draft of the 21-22 supplement template and instructions.
In addition, the CDE recommends three additional revisions that are not in the template and that
were discussed after we posted the template and instructions. The first is within the increased
or improved services section of the template, the CDE recommends including the dollar amount
associated with LCFF carryover in addition to the percentage. Within the instructions for the
goals and actions section, the CDE recommends including a hyperlink to the list of LEAs that
are required to include one or more required goals in the LCAP. And third, within the instructions for
the increased or improved services section of the template, the CDE recommends that the reference to
October 6 be replaced with the first Wednesday in October. The CDE also recommends that the State
Board allow the CDE in collaboration with State Board staff to make any necessary typographical
or formatting corrections as the documents are prepared for posting on the CDE website.
The next few slides will set the context before we dive into each of the recommended revisions
in the LCAP template and instructions and the one-time supplement template to the annual update
to the 21-22 LCAP. The slide displayed here provides an analysis of the CDE's engagement
with the field since July of 2021. Approximately 1,000 individuals have participated in webinars,
small group feedback sessions, statewide meetings, and submission of public comment.
We want to thank our educational partners for their continued commitment of sharing their unique
perspectives about the LCAP and the LCAP process. The proposed revised LCAP template and instructions
along with the proposed draft of the template and instructions for the 21-22 supplement
reflect the collaborative efforts of CDE and SBE staff, the LCAP advisory group,
and educational partners throughout the state.
This item has six attachments, so I want to provide a quick overview of what each attachment's purpose
is. So attachment one provides a summary of the revisions to the LCAP template and
instructions and the requirements for the 21-22 supplement along with a summary of educational
partners feedback. Attachment two provides the current LCAP template and instructions that was
adopted by the the state board at its January 2020 meeting. Attachment three provides the initial
draft of the LCAP template and instructions as required by SB 98 and AB 130 that was presented
to the state board during the September 2021 meeting. Attachment four provides the initial
draft of the 21-22 supplement and instructions that also was presented to the state board during
the September meeting. Attachment five provides the proposed final draft of the revisions to the
LCAP template and instructions as required by SB 98 and AB 130 and attachment six provides the
proposed final draft of the proposed 21-22 supplement template and instructions.
So today we'll be mainly focusing on attachments five and six.
The five revisions listed on this slide were presented during the September meeting and
introduced to the field beginning in July of 2021. The five revisions are proposed revision to
replace the term stakeholder throughout the LCAP template and instructions, requirement to include
specific goals in the LCAP, a requirement to calculate carryover, a requirement to use
concentration grant add-on for increased staffing, and a requirement to complete
one-time supplement to the annual update to the 21-22 LCAP.
During September state board meeting we walked through each of the five revisions by answering
five big questions. Why is this revision being proposed? When does the requirement begin? Who
will this impact? What do they need to do? And how will they do it? But for today's meeting we'll
focus on answering three new questions regarding each of the five revisions. What have our educational
partners been saying about these revisions? How is our educational partner input included
in the proposed revisions? And most very importantly, how will CDE support capacity building
to implement the proposed revisions? To remain mindful of the time and the very packed agenda
today, we will present all five revisions before pausing for questions, public comment, and board
discussion. At the September 2021 meeting, the board gave very clear direction to the CDE
to provide recommendations that could reduce redundancy and simplify the LCAP to ensure that
the plan is accessible to all interested parties. In response to this request, the CDE has made
several revisions in the proposed final draft LCAP template and instructions which is posted
as attachment five. These changes include whenever possible, new information required to be included
in the LCAP template and action tables has been added in a way that limits the increase in size
of the LCAP and reduces duplication of effort for LEAs. Also, the CDE proposes that the instructions
requiring LEAs to copy and retain the increased storm proof services section for each of the
three years in the LCAP cycle be removed as this will decrease the length of the plan.
Removing this requirement will not impact transparency as education code requires LEAs
to post any LCAP adopted by the local governing board or body of the LEA on their website.
The reason that the CDE did not make broader sweeping changes to the LCAP template for this
round of revisions is because we received feedback from many of our educational partners
who requested that we wait until the next three year cycle to make additional changes to the
LCAP. It is the shared perspective of our colleagues in the field that to change the
LCAP template and instructions amidst the three year cycle would be overly burdensome for LEAs
even if they were not also managing an ongoing pandemic. Therefore, the CDE would like to propose
that we in collaboration with our educational partners continue to evaluate the LCAP template
and instructions within the coming year to identify other areas in which the LCAP could
potentially be streamlined for the next three year cycle beginning in 2024. And I just will mention
you know we've already begun leading this conversation with our LEA partners. Just yesterday
afternoon we we had a conversation with our county office education partners and discussed
where we could streamline the LCAP. Also working with our our agencies and I think we have a list
of about 12 places to start so far and to grow. All right so let's dive into the the five proposed
revisions. So the first one that we will start with today is to replace the term stakeholder
throughout the LCAP template and instructions. And the reason that we are bringing this proposal to
all of you is because we received some feedback in speaking with some of our LEA partners
that the term stakeholder is creating a barrier of participation for some of our community members
particularly our Native American communities. Primarily because the term the current term
does not acknowledge the fact that Native American tribes are sovereign nations with
constitutionally protected rights and thus created a barrier to engagement.
So the CDE created an online survey to ask members of the public what they thought the new term should
be. The survey was live from October 4th through October 14th and it collected 647 responses.
Respondents included administrators, educators, parents, or family members, school board members,
researchers, advocates, students, and policy makers. Respondents ranked their preference
of a new term from four options and also had a write-in option. The four options were educational
partner, educational collaborator, educational community member, and interested parties. And
the number one preference from the survey respondents across the majority of the roles
was educational partner. So therefore the CDE is recommending that the term stakeholder be replaced
with the term educational partner throughout the LCAP template and instructions.
And the one-time supplement to the annual update to the 21-22 LCAP.
As far as capacity building all divisions and branches throughout the California Department
of Education are committed to equity. We are currently working on implementing the replacement
of the term stakeholder with educational partner. You can see this outward facing through our local
agency system support office who have already adopted the use of educational partners
in their daily correspondence and during their professional development series or their Tuesday
at two webinars. Okay, moving on to the second revision. The requirement to include specific
goals in the LCAP. The reason for this requirement is that the legislative intention is twofold.
One to ensure that LEAs are addressing the needs of consistently low performing student groups
and two to ensure that higher performing LEAs are addressing the needs of low performing schools
within that LEA. Feedback from statewide educational partners centered around the need
for additional clarification related to the criteria for identifying LEAs that will be
required to include a specific goal, clarity related to what the specific goals must include,
and a desire to see the required goals identified as supporting the improvement
of chronically low performing student groups and or schools.
In response to our educational partners requests you will see updates to the instructions on page
24 of attachment 5. Specifically the instructions related to the required goals have been revised
to provide greater specificity about what must be addressed within the required goals
including identification of student groups or schools and metrics and actions specific
to reach the student group or school. Instructions were added to the identified needs prompt within
the plan summary of the LCAP requiring that LEAs identify if they are required to include a goal
and the student groups or schools that led to this requirement. In October the CDS analysis
measurement and accountability reporting division provided an information memo to the state board
related to the identification of low performing student groups and low performing schools.
The lists for the 22-23 LCAP have been posted on the CDE's local control funding formula webpage
and will be updated annually. Additionally we have a recommendation for a revision that has come up
since posting and that is the CDE would like to add the link to the list of the LEAs required to
write the goals in the LCAP in the LCAP instructions which would be on page 24
in the goals and actions section of attachment 5.
Regarding capacity building the most important step in completing this requirement is knowing
if you are required to complete the requirement so therefore the October memo submitted by our
colleagues in the analysis measurement and accountability reporting division was the first
notification to the field. The lists are posted on the CDE's LCFF webpage and will be updated
annually each year that we have the data to update and the CDE will also include a link to the list
in the LCAP template instructions. Also the CDE will be hosting a Tuesdays at 2 webinar on Tuesday
January 13th 2022 to provide training for LEAs that must include a required goal in their 22-23
LCAP. Through this training there are a couple of key messages that the CDE will be reinforcing
to the field. A very important component of completing this section relies on LEAs understanding
that while the data that has been used to identify the LEAs who are required to include specific
goals in their LCAPs is based on 2017, 2018 and 2019 dashboard LEAs should use the most recently
available data to assist in diagnosing and addressing student needs. This message aligns
within the larger statewide system of supports efforts to build up LEAs local data literacy
capacity. We will also be emphasizing the instructions that require these goals to
include metrics, outcomes, actions and expenditures specific to addressing the needs of and improving
outcomes for each of the student groups or schools whose performance outcomes triggered identification.
And also finally well another emphasis point not finally in the explanation of why the LEA developed
the goal they did there are two big areas that we will be highlighting that how actions and metrics
in the goal differ from previous efforts to improve and LEAs are also required to explain why
the LEA believes actions metrics and expenditures included in this goal will help achieve the
outcomes identified in the goal description.
So before I turn it over to Josh to take us through the revisions related to the requirement
to calculate carryover I want to provide some context to the history of how this requirement
to calculate carryover came about and how we got to where we are today. In September of 2020
Governor Newsom made a promise to address the issue raised by AB 1835 and the California State
Auditor related to ensuring that our low-income English learner and foster youth students are
being provided the level of services they are entitled to. In the 21-22 budget the administration
followed through by proposing a statutory change that would ensure LEAs are both planning for
and following through on actions and services that increase and improve services for students from
low-income families English learners and foster youth while working within the increase and
improve framework that was established during the inception of the LCFF and the LCFF expenditure
regulations. In July of this year that proposal became law. The language not only represents a
compromise struck between the administration and legislature but also responded to a critique of
LCFF made by the California State Auditor. The passage of this statutory language and required
work by the board this fall led to K through 12 education being recently removed from the
auditor's high-risk list. We acknowledge that the steps to calculate carryover seem complex
and technical but we know that it is worth it working through this complexity to achieve a
clear and transparent accounting of how our unduplicated student groups are being served
over and above the level of services provided to all students. So with that important background I
will now turn it over to Josh to walk you through the improvements and changes to this piece of the
LCAP. Thank you Lindsay. Good morning President Darling-Hammond, members of the board.
As Lindsay mentioned my name is Joshua Strong. I'm the administrator of the local agency
system support office here at the CDE. So in terms of the requirements to calculate
carryover the feedback that we received from our educational partners requested additional
a need for additional clarity within the LCAP instructions related to how LEAs would calculate
the required percentage of planned qualitative improvements. That was one of the things that
was touched on in the September presentation is the quantitative improvements and the
qualitative improvements. Additionally there was a desire for the calculations being performed
within the action table to be provided within the instructions and clarification related to
the carryover requirements. Next slide please. Thank you so in terms of how educational partner
input was included within the template there's been a revision to the contributing actions annual
updates table which more closely aligns with the statutory requirements and in addition to this
within the LCFF carryover table which is on page 15 of attachment 5 there's an alignment of the
LCFF carryover percentage to the LEA's estimated actual LCFF funding as opposed to the projected
LCFF funding. This not only holds LEAs accountable for the funding that they have received through
the year but it also has the added benefit of ensuring that LEAs that have experienced or are
experiencing a declining enrollment are not held responsible to carryover funding that they didn't
actually receive during the school year. In addition to this we provided specific instructions
related to the required calculations and included an example of how an LEA might calculate the
required percentage of planned qualitative improvement. The instructions provide the required
to provide the required calculations really provide transparency for the field in terms of
how this would be done. The example provides LEAs with one method of how they might determine
the proportional percentage without locking an LEA into a single formulaic response seeking to
strike that balance between ensuring that LEAs are meeting the requirement but also have flexibility
that was been part of the hallmark of of LCFF. And then third the revision of the increased or
improved services section we're recommending provide the projected percentage to increase
or improve services for the coming school year the proportional LCFF carryover percentage
that will be calculated and the total percentage to increase or improve services which would be the
combination of the projected percentage for the coming year plus the LCFF carryover percentage
that would be the total LCFF increased or improved services percentage that the LEA would
be required to demonstrate that it's meeting in the coming LCAP year. As previously noted
we're also recommending that the dollar amount associated with the LCFF carryover be included
in addition to the carryover percentage. So if we can move to the next slide how is it that the
department's going to be supporting LEAs in building capacity related to these new requirements.
We're going to be providing training webinars two specifically related to the new increased or
improved services requirements and how those calculations work. Those will be those are
scheduled for December 14th and December 16th. That's also going to touch on the carryover
requirements. In addition the CDE will collaborate with county offices of education and other
educational partners in terms of building out trainings and partnering in communicating with
the field. The CDE is also going to hold regular office hours during the spring of 2022 to support
LEAs in development of the 22-23 LCAP and we're we continue to be available to support LEAs
through the LCFF inbox email account. Moving on to the required use of the concentration grant add-on
what did we hear from our educational partners if we could move to the next slide.
Thank you. So educational partners had a recommend there were a number of recommendations
and proposals of tables to help more clearly report the staff to student ratios at each of the
school at the school sites related to this requirement. There were also requests for
additional guidance or instructions in for how LEAs would handle a situation where the amount of
the additional concentration grant add-on that additional 15 percent is not sufficient to provide
additional staff or in an instance where an LEA doesn't have comparison schools from which to
describe how it's using the additional concentration grant add-on. So specifically an example of that
would be an LEA in which all of the schools within that LEA are serving above or have schools
that are serving above 55 percent enrollment of low-income English learner and foster youth
students. How is it that they are implementing this requirement and then in addition we we've
had requests for additional clarification is how to determine the staff to student ratios
in terms of how those will be those will be used. So how does this show up then within the template
The
table that would there's been a table that's been included to enable LEAs to identify the staff to
student ratios as applicable to the LEA. It allows the LEA flexibility depending on what type of LEA
it is whether it's a k-12 elementary high school district whether it's a single school district
etc. The instructions for the prompt have also been revised to address instances where the amount
of the additional concentration grant add-on is not sufficient to provide additional staff
to address instances where the LEA doesn't have comparison schools and how to determine the
staff to student ratios that will be used in identifying the required staff to student ratios.
Again the why of this requirement and the reason behind doing this is to ensure that those LEAs
that are receiving this additional 15 percent concentration grant are using that in order to
provide direct services to students at schools where students that are low income English
learner or foster youth make up 55 percent or more of the student body and so we think that
these additional components within the template and within the instructions are going to allow
LEAs to communicate this how they're meeting this requirement how it is that they're
they're implementing this in a way that provides flexibility based on the local context of the LEA
but also does so in a way that that is clear and understandable to the LEA's community.
So how is the CDE going to help support LEAs in terms of implementation of this new requirement
as previously noted where we have a number of webinars that are coming up specifically
December 14th and 16th related to the increased or improved services requirements
that also will include this additional concentration grant add-on again the regularly
scheduled office hours and supporting LEAs through questions responses to questions received through
the LCFF email account and so at this point I'll turn it back over to Lindsay
to discuss the one-time supplement to the annual update to the 2021-22 LCAP.
Thank you so much Josh. So the reason for the requirement to for LEAs to complete the
one-time supplement to the annual update to the 21-22 LCAP is to provide local governing
boards or bodies parents families and other educational partners with additional information
related to the additional funds provided to LEAs in the 21-22 school year.
As we all know the 21-22 budget act increased educational funding throughout our state at
historic rate. The one-time supplement will give LEAs an opportunity to share their story of how
they are using the funds received through the 21-22 budget act and federal emergency relief funds
mainly the ESSER funds in a manner that is consistent with other applicable plans
and in alignment with their 21-22 LCAPs. Feedback from statewide educational partners
requested clarification related to the report that is required to be provided to the local
local governing board or body of the LEA on or before February 28, 2022. Also a need for
additional guidance as to the meaning of the phrase funds provided through the budget act of
2021 that were not included in the LCAP and what the requirement entails.
In response to this feedback the instructions for the 21-22 supplement have been revised to provide
additional specificity related to the reporting requirement and these can be found in attachment
six. Additional information has also been provided in the instructions to clarify the meaning of the
phrase funds provided through the budget act of 2021 that were not included in the LCAP and the
intent for this requirement and specifically we highlight the instructions highlight that LEAs
have flexibility in deciding what funds are included in the LCAP and to what extent those
funds are included. If the LEA received funding through the budget act of 21 that it would have
typically included within its LCAP the funds provided in the budget act of 21 that were not
included in the LCAP and provided description of how the LEA has engaged its educational partners
on the use of funds. The instructions also clarify the reporting requirement for LEAs and
provide LEAs flexibility to refer to other planning documents to reduce duplication of effort.
Regarding CDE capacity building and support the CDE will be hosting a Tuesdays at Two webinar
series on Tuesday November 9th at 2 to provide training related to the one-time supplement to
the annual update to the 21-22 LCAP and the related requirement to provide a report to the
local governing border body of the local educational agency on or before February 28th of 2022.
The CDE will hold regularly scheduled office hours throughout the spring of 2022 to support
LEAs in development of the 22-23 LCAP and the CDE will continue to support LEAs by responding
to questions received through the LCFF at CDE email account.
So we just want to acknowledge that there are a lot of changes and this is a year of constant
changes and we know that more changes are burdensome for all of our LEAs and so that is why we are very
committed to leading a really strong technical assistance period after board action today.
To start we have 11 scheduled webinars between November 9th and January 18th with more to come
based on LEA and the field needs and requests. We will continue to add more Tuesdays at Two
in response and we also thank our partners especially CECESA who generously invite us
in to listen, present, calibrate, and collaborate with our county office of education partners
and we will also be continuing to present updates to state and federal program directors meetings,
the bilingual coordinators network just to name a few. Also LASSO will continue to offer office hours
and we are very excited to announce that in the LASSO team we are adding one additional consultant
to help support all of you in the field and also we are working on releasing the guidance
documents created in collaboration with the Region 15 Comprehensive Center at West Ed.
These sections specifically will focus on well-written LCAP sections and will be inclusive
of all new requirements. We will also have guidance on how to use local more than state data as metrics
in the LCAP and also support in timely posting of additional guidance documents to accompany
our Tuesday at Two webinar series. So many more things to come and with that I will pause and
turn it back over to you President Darling-Hammond.
Thank you very much for that very thorough report. We really appreciate it. I was myself
particularly excited about the dozen suggestions you have for streamlining already
lining up. I want to ask that we have the public comment slide up and I want to
begin to get the public comment queue going. Members of the public wishing to provide comment
on this item can do so by calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the
slide that is shown now and while we're waiting for members of the public to call in I want to
ask Vice President Strauss and Member Burr as our accountability liaisons if they have any initial
comments and then if we have any clarifying comments from board members we'll take those.
We'll hold substantive discussion until after the public comment. So Vice President Strauss.
So thank you President Darling-Hammond. So Lindsay and Josh thank you so much for a really clear
succinct presentation really outlining all the changes that are happening and why we need to do
it and also what lies ahead. I just so appreciate feedback from our local LEA saying wait till the
next three year cycle don't change it in the middle now but that our LEAs are already suggesting
and requesting things like charts and explanations and guidance. So I think the feedback for local
LEAs continue to make this process better and we understand that the items today that are changes
are required from new statutory language with the new carryover requirements and that there
reflects a compromise that's taken shape over the last couple years. Secondly that the change the
template that we're considering focuses on the actions and services that increase and improve
services for students from low-income families English learners and foster youth. This will
really help LEAs realize one of the fundamental goals of the local control funding formula
and I just appreciate again that the feedback from the local LEAs is supporting these recommendations
and again I look forward to the continued streamline efforts that President Darling-Hammond
talked about and the changes in the next three year cycle because I think we all realize that
while we've improved the template and the questions and the prompts it has gotten too long and there's
a lot of redundancies. So I would support your plans and Lindsay I know you said you have several
steps already planned and I know we're looking forward to that. So with that I'll turn it over
to Member Burr. Thank you. Thank you Eileen. So I'll just associate myself with Eileen's
gratitude and appreciation. It's so clear the level of solicitation of feedback that you've
taken from all of our educational partners on what is not an easy task by any sense of the word.
I just I do want to ask one clarifying question to either Lindsay or Josh just so that we know
what's on the agenda for LEAs going forward. As I understand what's being proposed here
there will be a supplement that's required for years 2020 and 2021 and that that has
I'm sorry 2021-22 and that has to be completed by February 28th of 22. Just want to clarify that
and the second thing is the revision of the current template and that is for the 2022-23
school year so that any proposed changes wouldn't happen until after that. So if you could just
clarify kind of the timing and people can have a sense of what the scope of work will be before
LEAs if we adopt this item. I would appreciate that. Sure so the thank you for that question
clarifying question Member Burr. So for the February 28th 2022 requirement LEAs must complete
the one-time supplement to the annual update to the 21-22 LCAP. This is a template and it is
attachment six. This template once adopted by the board anticipated today will be posted on the CDE
website and our Tuesday at 2 this coming Tuesday on November 9th will walk LEAs through that final
template and the requirements for that presentation to their board. Another important note about this
one-time supplement is that it does not need to be submitted after February 28th. It will be included
in the 22-23 LCAP for the typical review and approval cycle when that happens this summer.
Regarding the LCAP template update and revisions that is attachment five and all of those
anticipated revisions once approved today will be posted and prepared and those revisions will be
implemented as LEAs complete their 2022-23 LCAP. Does that clarify your question Member Burr?
And just and when is the 22-23 LCAP just for everybody's edification when does that have
to be completed? Completed oh by by it must be reviewed and adopted by July 1st of 2022.
Okay thank you.
All right I do not see any hands raised for further clarification at this time
and I do know that we have 15 or more callers in the queue so I think maybe we'll go to public
comment and then we'll come back for board discussion and further questions that board
members may have. That's correct we do have 15 callers for item five. Caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
SBE members my name is Michael Juba and I'm a classroom teacher representing the California
Teachers Association. CTA is part of a coalition of labor and education management organizations
that submitted a letter on the LCAP template. We urge the board to consider the recommendations
outlined in the coalition letter and reinforce that the LCAP should be a strategic planning
document. Any efforts to further evolve the LCAP into a compliance document
disregarded. We appreciate that the template provides examples on how LEAs can increase
or improve services for unduplicated students either qualitatively or quantitatively.
We also urge the board to simplify the template as much as possible
and not include additional requirements beyond the current law. 2021-22 school year well underway
the pandemic continues to place substantial stress on students families teachers and
administrators. Thank you. Thank you caller. Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Thank you for allowing my comments. I'm Pete Ahern president
of the California Association of Science Educators. I want to thank President Darling
Hammond in her opening comments today for highlighting the importance of the next generation
science standards in helping educate California students about the science of climate change.
However we have just released results of a statewide survey of teachers showing that NGSS
implementation was never completed and has stalled. There are deep inequities in the
implementation of NGSS. Most teachers do not yet have NGSS aligned instructional materials
and have not had adequate professional learning to address the needs of consistently low performing
student subgroups. What does this have to do with the LCAP template? Since districts set LCAP
priorities based on the dashboard and science isn't on the dashboard NGSS implementation gets
ignored. The LCAP template is a three-year plan but districts won't be seeing CAS results on the
dashboard until 2023 which means they won't plan for science. As currently formatted the template
does not adequately support the implementation of NGSS. We would suggest that we could have an icon
on the dashboard that says CAS results coming in 2023. This would indicate the district that
they need to support NGSS. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now. Good morning Carlos Machado with the California School Boards Association.
We support the templates uh templates proposed for adoption today. These templates balance the
new statutory requirements with valid concerns about how the already lengthy LCAP is received
locally. Approving the templates will help ensure these documents continue to be useful
to our school communities and spur involvement by local educational partners in their development.
We thank the board and its staff for their work on these templates and ask the board to
approve the templates as drafted. Thank you. Thank you caller. Next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Good morning LeAngela Reed on behalf
of the Small School Districts Association. Thank you Dr. Downingham and members of the board for
hearing our testimony. SSDA supports the revised LCAP and one-time supplement. I want to thank
the staff for their interaction with us for hearing our concerns and and for meeting in
attempting to to you know help us to make us be part of the process. We also want to thank you
and the other state board members for your ongoing recognition of the difficulties and uncertainties
schools and districts continue to face. Our districts our small districts face difficulties
that while not unique are certainly amplified. Our staffing shortages are more severe because
it can be difficult to recruit in our areas. Our attendance and enrollment fluctuations are more
pronounced because of our small numbers and that confounds our ability to plan appropriately.
I say this not to complain but to give you to illustrate our environment however we are
committed to the accountability system created and believe in it. We are integral parts of our
communities and with generations attending the same school. We don't just know our students.
Thank you. We know their families. Thank you caller. Your time's up. Next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Honorable state board members I am Sylvia Hodge assistant director at LMU Center for Equity for
English learners. I offer these comments to advocate for changes to the measuring and reporting
results section of the LCAP template. Currently LEAs are encouraged to identify metrics for specific
student subgroups to narrow gap. Instead language should be amended to state LEAs should identify
metrics for specific student subgroups. Three previous studies by the center reflected that
district LCAP exhibited minimal mention of metrics and analysis of English learner outcomes.
We are currently conducting an additional study with a sample of statewide district LCAP.
Unfortunately preliminary findings reflect similar trends in the absence of identifying metrics
and analysis to support English learners. A 2021 brief case research partnership study showed that
English learners were the student group most affected by the pandemic. Therefore we recommend
that the state board of education require that specific metrics for English learners be included
in the LCAP template to support this vulnerable student subgroup. Thank you for your time.
Thank you caller. Next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good morning Andrea Ball on behalf of two groups. First the Central Valley Education Coalition.
Over 100 LEAs serving over 400,000 pupils and the California Association of Suburban School
Districts. Large districts across the state support the recommendations of the CDE,
request the state board adopt these revisions to the LCAP template and the one-time supplement.
We are firmly in support of the LCAP and the accountability system and think these proposed
changes will do much to balance out the statutory requirements and as well as allow these to be
meaningful documents for the community. Thank you. Thank you caller. Next caller please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Honorable board members,
Shelly Spiegel-Coleman, California Together. We urge you to revisit the language and expectation
for inclusion of metrics and growth targets to establish goals to close achievement gaps
beyond DA districts and CSI school. Reflecting on Superintendent Slurman's comments today about
closing gaps and board member Rucker's comments about language to set expectations,
we call your attention to page 25 of attachment 5. The language under measuring and reporting
results only encourages districts to set metrics that would close gaps. We believe the equity
attempts of LCFF allows us at least to suggest that districts should set these targets. At the
September board meeting several of you expressed the need to name student subgroups, research-based
standards-aligned practices. Reading LCAP with the Center for Equity for English Learner for
four years, this is an area that needs direction, not just encouragement. Please vote to change the
word encourage to should in the template. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller please state your
name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. My name is Lexi Lopez from EdVoice.
We along with the Alliance for Students remain very concerned that beyond the calculation itself,
the proposed template is vague with respect to what LEAs must report on specific expenditures
and actions supported with unspent carryover funding in an ensuing year. EdVoice urges the
board to direct CDE staff to develop explicit instructions with examples in the template that
aligns with AB 130 to ensure unused LCFF carryover funds are additive and expended to benefit
targeted students. In addition, EdVoice recommends that the board ensure districts report by school
the staff positions supported by the 1.1 billion in targeted additional concentration grant funding
to ensure staffing levels at schools with a higher concentration of unduplicated students have
improved. Thank you. Thank you caller. Next caller please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Sarah Botches at the California Association of School Business
Officials in support of the template proposed for adoption today. We're very appreciative of the
support of the staff as well as the state board members. Thank you for hearing us out. We've we're
very appreciative of the conversation taking place today. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello, Leimani Aguinaldo on behalf of the Association of California School Administrators
and our organization supports the draft templates as proposed. In light of the challenges faced by
LEAs at this time, we appreciate the attention paid to streamlining the templates and ensuring
that changes included in the template reflect statutory requirements and nothing more. The
template as drafted is consistent with existing particularly with the requirements to demonstrate
increased or improved services for unduplicated students. We have additional points in our accent
letter as well as a coalition letter that we submitted for this item. Thank you. Thank you.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good morning. This is Sarah Lilas, Executive Director of Teach Plus California. We first want
to associate our comments with a letter sent by both the LCFS Equity Coalition and the Alliance
for Students. In particular, we appreciate staff's revision to add the carryover dollar figure to
increase or improve services and the recommendation that if any qualitative percentages are used that
LEAs justify how that percentage corresponds to the amount of SNC allocation it's covering.
We would recommend that the template go one step further to identify any planned actions or services
which are being supported by the carryover funds. More broadly, our Teach Plus teacher leaders want
to again elevate that their hope for LCFS to address educational inequity was rooted not
only in directing additional resources to students who've been underserved but in the promise of
community engagement and accountability to ensure local leaders are truly meeting the needs of their
communities and the LCAP and how it is used is essential in doing that. We look forward to
working with you and ensuring that it's both a tool for planning as well as transparency and
accountability. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record. Your time starts now. Hello, it's Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We too are in support of approval of the template as proposed and thank CDE for their hard work and
outreach. We are though very much concerned that the template has grown to the point where it's
largely incomprehensible to school staff and especially to parents and other education partners
and we really strongly in the strongest possible terms urge the state board to lean on Governor
Newsom, state superintendent Thurmond and especially the legislature to fundamentally rethink the
length and scope of the LCAP and turn it into something that is much more practical
and comprehensible. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Good afternoon, Colleen Pagter on behalf of Los Angeles
Unified School District. LA Unified supports the new templates and feels that they balance the
statutory requirements for changes to the LCAP template, the challenges that LEAs are facing
today. With that in mind, we ask that CDE and the state board develop and circulate resources to help
LEAs and our communities with understanding these changes. Updating the FAQ page on the CDE website
and creating a toolkit for LEAs with materials that can be shared with our families and partners
would be very helpful in ensuring consistency and understanding of this revised LCAP. Again,
we appreciate the work of CDE and the state board and support the final draft. However,
we also want to urge that more work be done to help streamline and shorten the LCAP to make it
more accessible and transparent for our communities. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state
your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now. Hi, Leticia Garcia on behalf of
the Riverside County Superintendent of Schools. We're part of a coalition of LEAs and education
organizations in support of the proposed revisions. Notwithstanding our support,
we offer additional input. Our districts embrace accountability for student outcomes,
but they also need flexibility to meet their obligations, especially now with a windfall of
one-time COVID funds with expiration dates that LEAs are spending as quickly and wisely as local
capacity allows. The proposed template only allows for LEAs to receive credit for their
proportionality obligation if they increase services by funding in action with LCFF funds
or improve services by including actions without funds, but not in action funded with other
sources. We believe districts should get credit when they blend funding. Lastly, we agree the
template has become too complicated and support efforts to streamline the template while folding
LEAs accountable. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Hello, Madam President. This is Brian Rebus calling
on behalf of the Education Trust West. We agree with our partners in the equity coalition regarding
the specifics, but I wanted to offer a high level comment. For those of you who may be wondering,
how did we get here? We think the problems with LCFF transparency are rooted in some administrative
policy decisions regarding the lack of a standardized account code for supplemental and
concentration dollars and some decisions related to per-pupil reporting, per-pupil expenditures
reporting under federal law. That's resulted in researchers and the state auditor finding that we
really don't know what's happening to LCFF dollars intended for unduplicated students and we think
that's a big problem going forward. When the governor and the legislature talk about LCFF,
they immediately talk about the amount of funding going into supplemental and concentration.
The general public thinks those dollars are being spent and that we know where they're going.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Good afternoon. This is Liz Guillen, public advocate for the LCFF equity coalition.
Want to repeat from our comments our many thanks to the department for an open revision process
and the opportunities for weighing in and most importantly for hearing us and acting on our
comments where they have. We appreciate the department's emphasis, the fact that got us
here today. That is LEAs not meeting their equity obligations. The student advisory board
comments this morning echo the voices of many marginalized students who deserve more, not the
same resources. We support revisions, in particular today's recommendation by the department to provide
the projected percentage to increase or improve services for the carryover and that we want to
keep pushing on the importance of identifying in the action section which actions are being
supported by carryover funds. That is not too much to ask. It takes merely an asterisk to note that
this action is being supported by funds that were unspent. Thank you. Thank you. Next caller,
please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hi, this is Robert from children now. I want to associate myself with the comments of the
LCFF equity coalition and the alliance for student success and focus my comments on one
specific issue. But first I wanted to highlight the findings of the public policy through the
California study that shows that only 55% of dollars distributed through supplemental
concentration grants actually get to the school sites where the kids are that generated those
funds. We have concerns with that general finding and steps like the carryover provisions are one
small step in improving that process. We think there are many more that need to be done.
In terms of the template itself, we want to focus on the 1.1 billion that's available for
staff at high concentration schools. AB 130, the authorizing legislation for this,
focuses on the LCAP being the enforcement tool for ensuring those dollars get to those school sites.
We don't believe that there's sufficient information in this template to ensure that
the dollars are getting to the school sites and the additional staff is being either hired
or transferred to those schools. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the
record. Your time starts now. Hello, it's John Affeld from Public Advocates. I want to
appreciate all the work the department and the state board staff have done. I think in terms of
instructions in the template, it honors the original statute that allows for proportional
increases or proportional improvements directed toward high need students.
It's been our experience over the last eight years that quality improvements, while they may exist,
are the exception rather than the rule and I think that will continue to be the case
as we move forward. It is important though that any qualitative improvement percentages be
demonstrated to correspond to the supplemental concentration dollar allocation amount.
That's what the statute calls for and AB 130 reinforced.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Hello, honorable board members. My name is Melissa Elder with the Rincon Indian Education Center
located on the Rincon reservation in what is now known as San Diego County. I would like to reiterate
comments that were made today and during the last board meeting discussion about
broadening what is considered as subgroups to include Native American students and additionally,
students should be setting specific goals, not simply encouraged to do so. We know Native
youth are not performing as well as their counterparts. They have lower graduation rates
due to being pushed out of school through excessive suspension and funneled into the
adult criminal system. As stated in the education codes, Indian children have not succeeded well in
California public schools and we're still seeing them being left out and our school districts leaving
out Indian education centers from meaningful planning processes and necessary in school
programming as educational partners. Native American and American Indian students have unique
situations and specific needs and in order to address those needs they need to be specific goals
to address those. Thank you.
Thank you caller. Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Caller, you're live.
Next caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record. Your time starts now.
Afternoon, Martha Zaragoza Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education.
CABE also associates itself with the comments and recommendations made in the equity
coalition letter. We also support CDE staff recommendation, their additional revision
regarding the increased or improved services section of the template to include the dollar
amount associated with the LCFS carryover in addition to the percentage. We would like to
make sure that if any qualitative percentages are used those percentages need to correspond
to the amount of the SNC allocation and discovery. Lastly, we also associate ourselves with the
comments made by representatives of the Californians together regarding the specific EL information on
the LCAP template. It is requested that the board clearly include. Thank you caller.
Thank you caller. Your time's up.
This concludes public comment for item number five.
Thank you very much. I want to appreciate all of the callers who've called in and their comments
and the work of the staff on this complicated and important item. And I want to open this to
board commentary.
I see member Glover Woods.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. Just to echo your thanks to CDE staff for really working with
wide diversity of educational partners to really try to have a template that
addresses the statutory requirements and the concerns that that statute was addressing.
That addresses the statutory requirements and the concerns that that statute was addressing.
It was definitely not an easy job to do. And I think based upon the comments that we've received
in writing and during public comment, many of our educational partners do feel heard
and are appreciative of the revisions that were made for both the template for the LCAP as well
as the supplement. I just want to again say that as we move forward, I appreciate that the
streamlining of the LCAP template will be front of mind if you will. Definitely think it is
important to wait for the next cycle to just allow for LEAs to get used to the template that they
have in front of them. One piece just to as we keep in mind and as we go forward with streamlining,
just to remember that it is essential that all educational partners understand what's in the
LCAP. So the more complex it becomes, the more likelihood we have of disenfranchising some of
the educational partners. And of course we want for time to really be spent on implementing the
goals, actions, and services that are in the LCAP template, not completing the template itself.
So I do look forward to the upcoming actions in relation to the streamlining. And again,
thank you so much to the CDE staff for just a phenomenal job in implementing the revisions
that were necessary to the LCAP template. Thank you, Al. Move to Member Sun and then
Member Burr. Thank you. I appreciate Board Member Gloverwood's comments, you know,
echo those absolutely. And I think I've mentioned this in the past, but I think we are beyond
paper for this LCAP. And I would really encourage as we are looking forward to the evolution,
continued evolution of this LCAP, that we look at another means to display it other than through
a paper system that it could be either web-based in some way because of the complexity and the
layers and trying to relate goals to the budget and all of that. It just seems like a 2D paper
format that we've been using is just not effective and it's not understandable,
as has been mentioned already several times. So I would just encourage us to look at new
ways of how we might display the LCAP in a more futuristic way rather than the paper
that we're using now. Thanks. Thank you. Member Burr and then Member Patio-Bronson.
Thank you. I actually will defer to Member Patio-Bronson.
I just wanted to make some closing comments before doing a motion.
And I'm going to try and talk and if it gets too loud with the gardener in the background,
maybe I'll continue later. So I also wanted to share in the chorus of appreciation,
there's just been a tremendous amount of work and progress, I think, that has been made in,
I think, relatively short time in terms of many of the amendments that have been coming both
legislatively but also in conversation with so many of the partners from community, from the
Equity Coalition, from the LEA community as well. I want to also offer a very clear appreciation
for the inclusion and the instructions of language reflecting some of our legislative
changes from this last cycle around TK-12 being named. I was reflecting back on my own time as
an advocate working with local school districts and having had many conversations where school
district leaders were not then familiar or confident that TK students, for example,
generated ADA and should be included within LCAPs. So having that specifically called out,
I think, is absolutely a step in the right direction of clarifying how much TK students
are a part of the school community and should be a part of the strategic planning effort.
I did want to ask, and this is I think a relatively small change, all of the references to TK-12 as
applicable appear in the instructions as distinct from the template and it largely
replaced or referred to previously to its students. The one place that I think that it could be
frontlined in the actual template itself is really just on page one where there is language saying,
describe the LEA, its school and its students, and if we could just add, comma, TK-12 as applicable.
I think that would actually really make it clear for LEAs that this is part of the planning
responsibilities just as much as any other grade. I also wanted to lift up, I think, that the table
that has been included on carryover, I think, is also very much an improvement and it gets to
this idea of what is going to clearly and transparently communicate to local community
members, parents, and equity groups around what the carryover calculation looks like.
I think many public comment folks have also suggested that there could be an accompanying
table to say what are the planned actions for that carryover calculation. Again, to this idea
of what makes it clear, what sort of, in the absence of going all not yet going completely
virtual and having it on your phone or pop up as a hologram, however the technology might be next,
tables communicate very succinctly and I think it's an easy fix.
And then the last suggestion, which I also think was raised by several public commenters,
the idea of moving from an encouraged goal for subgroups to something that is
firmer in saying that they should in fact have goals. Certainly as a parent, I think the idea
that if you know that there is a massive gap in terms of how children are faring, you would want
your local LEA to have aspirations that are clear and specific and to see those in bright lines and
clear text. Thank you very much. I'm going to go ahead and recognize member Rucker, member
Bonanca and member Escobedo and then come back around to member Burr as I think you're
holding out for the last spot there. So member Rucker. Thank you very much. When we had a
conversation about the changes and recommendations at the previous board meeting, there were a lot of
questions raised as to how the valuation and the explanation about how services would be
reported and how expenditures would be shown. I mean it became a very complicated and at some
point confusing discussion. So I do commend the department for the efforts they've made
to address a lot of the concerns that I know my colleagues on the board raise and I know that I
asked very explicitly about as a way of addressing. I remain concerned that while this is a reporting
document, I remain concerned that the accountability that is in the title of this plan still is not
evident or as apparent as it could be for the districts that will begin using this to develop
the supplementary report that will be turned in in July. We heard from a number of stakeholders
about the need to recognize student subgroups and as I sit here I am very aware
that African-American students are the lowest performing subgroup in all of the subject areas
that we currently test in every single subject, I mean in every single grade level and so I have
that concern because we're not requiring as a factor or an element of accountability,
there is no mandate to require districts to pay attention to their high need students. We give
voice to or we give an expectation that they should be addressing these high need students
yet we continue to see reports like an Ed source where only 55 cents of every dollar that's supposed
to go to support these students is actually being spent at the schools where these students attend.
So and in being careful to make that criticism, I'm not criticizing the efforts of schools as
if to say this is not occurring, what I am saying is that if it's not evident in the accountability
plan that we are paying attention to the most needy students by making absolute assertions
not only about how the money is being spent but it's being spent on these students because they
are the target, they are the reason why the sites and the districts receive these funds,
then what is the school actually holding itself accountable for? So while the mandates in the
statute can ask us to continue to revise and live with the question of what stating school improvement
looks like and how to articulate that with our community of partners and with the engagement that
creates consensus about where our priorities are, I want to remind you about the report we just heard
from our student advisory committee. Student voice has done more to articulate some of the issues of
concern that are directly related to what's being revised in this template and issues concerning
diversity and addressing diversity in school planning but also in supporting students who
are in low wealth or who come from low SES backgrounds. While it's not a requirement in
the LCAP to address that, I just have to wonder if these are the students who are the reasons why
districts are receiving an unprecedented $21,000 per pupil expenditure by the state from multiple
resources, including from the federal government, why would it be so difficult to make plain in a
chart, in a summary, or even in prioritized statements about these students what these funds
are for? So while we have come a long way, the LCAP that will be created by the changes we will
approve today is a significant improvement from where we started when the LCAP was implemented
all those years ago. We still have a long way to go to help districts understand that they have,
they are accountable for how they close the achievement gap and address the support
constraints for the students that need to be targeted and identified as their highest need
students. We still have not sufficiently closed the gap on how that should be addressed in these
plans. I'm going to member Banaka. Thank you. Thank you. Well, first, I want to thank the CDA
staff for such a comprehensive presentation, and I just wanted to echo some of the remarks of many
other board members thus far in that I really appreciate the emphasis on clarity and conciseness
in this template. I think that in general, the more clear and concise and understandable that
we can make the LCAP template without sacrificing the intent or the purpose,
the more educational partners are going to be willing and able to engage in the LCAP
process and give their feedback. And especially for students who are generally newer to education
policy, I think the LCAP can be extremely daunting, saying that it's a giant document
full of a lot of complex terms. And I think that the more complex it gets, the more it deters
students and scares them away from giving their valuable input. And I think that just generally
takes away from the whole purpose of LCAP, which is to hear the local input, especially of students
who are the primary educational partners. And just furthermore beyond that, I think this year,
especially we're all a little burnt out because of the pandemic. So I think having a more streamlined
template really helps to ease the weight on the shoulders of not only staff, but the educational
partners. Moving forward, I think I'd like to see the LCAP represented in newer forms as stated by
Member Sun, other than the paper template. And I think especially for students, this may be a bit
easier to follow, because especially after this year, we're all very familiar with technology and
viewing documents on our computers. And so that's something that's kind of, you know,
right up our alley. But again, I really appreciate all of the great work that the CDE staff has done
in listening to the educational partners and really trying to streamline this template as much as
possible. Terrific. Thank you. Member Escobedo, then Member McCullin. Yes, I'm not going to repeat
what my amazing colleagues, especially Ms. Rucker, Trustee Rucker, highlighted the importance of
having stronger language, but also I would like to add, yes, it's great that we're looking at
streamlining the process, but I think just as important is that coherence of effort, right?
We heard Superintendent Thurmond talk about literacy by third grade, enhancing the educational
environment, learning environment for African Americans. So there's any way to have, yes,
that local input, but at the same time, that coherence with the state. Not sure how we can
do this in the LCAP, but I think coherence is exceedingly important for all systems to work
together and to see California as a whole to move forward in the area of accountability.
Thank you. Member McCullin. Yes, I'll be brief. I know it's lunchtime now, but
I want to thank the staff at CDE for all the work on this, also monumental, but I agree with
Member Rucker's statements that we still have a ways to go in ensuring that this plan
covers the students that most need it, you know, those groups and using language that the goals
should be set, should, shall be set on those students who are in most need.
I also want to say thank you for listening to the educational partners, such as the
tribal organizations that wanted to move away from a certain language in the instructions and in the
document and moving towards calling those partners, educational partners that we are,
so I appreciate that move. Words do matter. So thank you and thank you for all the efforts.
And then all the help sessions, the Tuesday, Tuesday at two help sessions, I appreciate that.
I know districts want to have as much access as possible to for additional help, technical
assistance, so thank you. Member Rodriguez. Yes, thank you and I won't repeat everything
that's been said, but I do want to thank staff for incorporating our educational partners
feedback. I think that's incredibly important and also for the transition to educational partners.
I was left with a question about the NGSS and if that is, if there's a way to,
from one of the callers who mentioned that, and if there's a way to incorporate that, if,
like he said, it's just a checkbox, so is it possible to do that? And also member Rutgers
comments about, you know, the ensuring that we have specific information and
holding our educational partners accountable. Thank you.
Thank you and as I pass the ball to member Burr, I just want to associate myself with the comments
that have been made about how important it is to be strong in our expectations that students who
have the greatest needs should be attended to in the discussion in the LCAP about the allocation
of funds and so I want to be sure that there's a clear concern communicated about that ongoing
need and its reflection in the document. Member Burr, coming back to you.
I'm just, I'll be brief for a second, I just want to say that I always think of the LCAP as one of a
piece of many, many pieces of information that are really important to make sure we're focusing
on the students that need it most and in my view, it would always be helpful to have these
conversations in the context with the dashboard because recall that the dashboard very specifically
focuses on subgroups and in fact, LEAs are assessed based on those multiple groups and they're ranked
according to their colors and they're also identified for additional assistance based on
subgroup performance so it's, when we talk about the LCAP, the actual template and how we're
planning to do on behalf of subgroups, it sort of gets lost on what the outcomes are but I do think
there is some focus on it already in the template and I think it might be helpful for Lindsay if she
would come back and talk a little bit about that issue because it has been raised by a number of
folks and I know we all share that same concern and then I'll come back in just a minute after
Lindsay answers the question. Of course, thank you, thank you all members for your feedback to
Taking Furious Notes and we always appreciate your feedback as it informs our next steps.
Yes, Member Burr, so if you look at the plan summary section of the LCAP template specifically
in the instructions, the section around where LEAs are required to reflect on their identified
needs, they are directed to refer to the dashboard data to identify any state indicator for which
overall performance was in the red or orange performance category and received a not met,
not met for two more years rating and any state indicator for which performance for any student
group was two or more performance levels below the all student performance and then that is a long,
that has been a requirement and then in addition to that requirement, we now also have the requirement
that LEAs who have been identified based on student performance outcomes for the two or three
year requirements also have to add in a required goal into their LCAP that addresses each of the
student groups that are not performing. Thank you, Lindsay. So hopefully that addresses some
of the concerns that were raised by a number of the groups. I just want just in keeping with that
same theme, the one piece I wanted to mention is that while a lot of attention from the speakers
especially relied on a recent report by PPIC, the Public Policy Institute of California,
about expenditures and pointed to the needs that are identified and a lot of the changes we're
making here about being clear about where the expenditures are being made especially on behalf
of the students that are most in need. The part that sort of got lost in the shuffle in my view
was that in fact student performance has improved, that LCFF is working as it's intended to.
So I encourage folks to look at that. I'll just talk a little bit. There's graduation rate
improvements, the gaps are closing among subgroups, there's improvements in A to G completion, so
those are high school indicators that they looked at, but they also looked at some limited data and
admittedly we know that this data is truncated because of the pandemic, but with respect to
test scores and the elementary grade levels, one of the things that I thought was most important
to share is that the number of low-income students scoring far below standard has fallen notably,
which says to me that the LEAs are focusing most on the students who need it and trying to get them
up to grade level. So while these are very preliminary results, they are important and again
I sort of want to make sure we don't lose the plot line here that what we're trying to do here on
behalf of students who have historically been underserved is working and we need to stay the
course. So I just want to make sure that that didn't go unsaid and with that I would be happy
to move the department recommendation. I'm happy Board Member Patia Bronson to suggest your change.
I think it's a helpful one to include the parenthetical statement about TK to 12 to make sure
and I didn't get the specific line reference, so if you want to add that I'd be happy to take
that as a friendly amendment, but I make the recommendation that's shown on the screen.
And I will second it.
Terrific. Any further discussion of the motion?
I would like to also ask for a friendly amendment.
Um I'm not okay why don't why don't we hear what your thought is but we may need to vote on the
one that's before us so before we we hear but go ahead. As it relates to the issue I raised on
accountability, can we take a look at that verb encourage? I worked in a district where they
where our contract language said we will strive to maintain a ratio of 28 students to one. That's
about as useful as you know lipstick on a pig. So is it possible to change into the verb encourage
to a more transitive verb like should or shall or must instead of encourage?
I'm going to go back to Sue and you know she's the motion maker. I'm sorry I don't understand
the context member Rucker so I need a little bit more context or specific about what you're asking
for. I think you're on mute Patricia.
I did I immediately muted myself after the after I made my comment. Could we go back to the first
slide of the slide one of two on the recommendation? Okay so with um as it relates to the revisions
that are being added in the guidance this is actually related to what's in on number one
on explaining what the what will be happening with the increased and improved services
section. It says that districts will be encouraged to address or to report
how they are directing the funds and I'm recommending instead of using the verb
encouraged in the guidance to change it to district should report or identify how they
report or identify how they direct. It's on page 25.
I don't know if I can second a friendly amendment but I agree with that.
And it may be we might need to do it somewhere outside the bounds of Robert's rules but
yeah maybe we might need to do this separately from this motion but I think it's important
to make that change. So member Burr this is your motion so we'll come back to you. I guess I'm not
comfortable with it just because of all of the feedback that we received from stakeholders on
the very thoughtful and um comprehensive process that went into this feedback so I'd be happy to
have you do it as a separate motion if you want and folks can vote on it but I would like to stick
with the recommendation as written. Well then technically what that would mean is we would
vote on this motion and if the motion passes under Robert's rules I'd be asking for reconsideration
to amend a motion we just approved. I think that makes it more unnecessarily complicated
to do that so rather than hold this up because I think it is important for us to move on the
recommendations and the updated revisions because as I did say this goes a long way to making
improvements I'm just not going to I'm going to withhold the vote and not vote on this motion
because I am concerned about that particular statement and lack of emphasis that should be
in this amended update. I will also note as we get ready to vote that the motion does say that
the CDE will with state board staff look at the language and the wording of the various parts of
the template as it moves towards and I know they're taking account of our comments so I
hope the CDE staff will take account of these comments and think about where those how those
might be incorporated but we will vote on the motion as it is proposed and with that I'll ask
Brooks Allen if he will call the roll. Member Sun. Aye. Vice President Strauss. Yes. Member
Rucker. Not voting. Member Rodriguez. Yes. Member Petillo-Brownson. Yes. Member McQuillan.
I agree with Patricia but yes. Member Glover Woods. Yes. President Darlene Tammond. Yes.
Yes. Member Escobedo. Yes. Member Burr. Aye. Member Bonacca. Aye. Motion passes.
Thank you. This has been a long process of getting from where we started to where we are
and I think a lot of good work in the in the course of it. We're now going to take a 30 minute
break. I'd like to thank Lindsay and Josh for you know the presentation all the work that went
into it and the board members for this thoughtful discussion. We'll come back at 1 10. Please turn
off your microphones and cameras during the break and turn your cameras back on after the
break to reestablish the quorum but do not leave the meeting. Thank you.
Welcome back. I think we have a quorum and I'd like to ask Brooks Allen to call the roll to establish it.
Member Son. Present. Vice President Strauss. Present. Member Rucker.
Member Rodriguez. Here. Member Petillo-Brownson. Here. Member McQuillan. Here. Member Glover Woods.
Here. Member Escobedo. Here. President Darling-Hammond. Here. Member Burr. Here. Member Bonacca.
Here. You have a quorum. Very good. We're going to move to agenda item number six which is the
update to California's Every Student Succeeds Act state plan. We're asked to approve amendments
to the state plan pending the executive director's approval of final revisions
requested by the SBE that we may make here today. The item will be presented by Joe Sands of the CDE.
Joe, please begin. Thank you.
Good afternoon State Board President Darling-Hammond and State Board members.
My name is Joe Sands. I'm the federal policy liaison for the California Department of Education
Government Affairs Division. I am proud to be supported today in this presentation by
Kristen Cruz-Allen and Monique McWane of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division
as well as Cindy Kazanis, Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability
Reporting Division. Today we will be presenting item six update to California's Every Student
Succeeds Act state plan approval of the state amendments to the state plan. Next slide please.
The following topics will be covered in this presentation. We will provide a very brief
background on the Every Student Succeeds Act also known as ESSA. We will also provide the
current definitions for ineffective and out-of-field teachers under California's ESSA
Consolidated State Plan. Finally we will walk you through the proposed amendments to California's
ESSA Consolidated State Plan which includes an update to the definition for out-of-field teachers
based on feedback from the field. Next slide please. The CDE recommends that the State Board
of Education approve the amendments to California's ESSA Consolidated State Plan pending the SBE
Executive Director approval of final revisions requested by the SBE,
correction of any typographical errors, and necessary non-substantive clarifying edits.
Next slide please.
First we would like to provide some brief background regarding the ESSA and California's
Consolidated State Plan. We'll go to the next slide on that.
The ESSA was signed into law by President Obama in December of 2015 and it was a reauthorization
of the Federal Elementary and Secondary Education Act. The ESSA replaced the No Child Left Behind
Act and a major goal of the ESSA is to ensure educational equity and opportunity for disadvantaged
and high-need students and it is meant to supplement state programs. Now I will be passing
the presentation to Kristen Cruz-Allen and Monique McWane of the Educator Excellence
and Equity Division. Thank you very much, Joe. Good afternoon. So the actual ESSA provision that
we will be addressing today is section 1112B2, which requires local educational agencies to
describe how they will identify and address any disparities that result in low-income
and minority students being taught at higher rates than other students in the state.
Ineffective, inexperienced, or out-of-field teachers.
California sought extensive stakeholder input when addressing these requirements in its initial
plan submission, but was asked by local educational agencies to provide additional
specification for the ineffective and out-of-field teacher definitions. Specifically,
local educational agencies asked CDE to specify where teachers with certain certificates such as
provisional internship permits or PIPs or short-term waivers should be reported.
After collaborating with the Commission on Teacher Credentialing, the CDE brought revisions for
ineffective and out-of-field teacher definitions to the board, which contained the specifications
that LEAs were seeking in November of 2019. California had also requested an extension
for providing data related to the equity portion of the consolidated state plan until the data
sharing memorandum of understanding could be executed with the California Commission on
Teacher Credentialing, and the first year of data from the California Statewide Assignment
Accountability System or CALSAS could be verified. These proposed amendments and teacher data tables
allow California to come into compliance with a completed state plan.
I'd like to briefly review the definitions that currently exist
in the California Consolidated State Plan. So the definition for ineffective teacher
is any of the following. An individual whose assignment is legally authorized by an emergency
permit that does not require possession of a full teaching license. A teacher who holds
a teaching credential but does not possess a permit or an authorization that temporarily allows
them to teach outside of their credentialed area. And an individual who holds no credential
permit or authorization to teach in California. To address the specifications that LEAs were
asking for, the certifications on the screen that you're looking at now were added to this
definition and they include provisional internship permits, short-term staff permits or STIPs,
variable term waivers, and substitute permits or teaching permits for statutory leave holders
serving as teacher of record. As for the definition for out of field teacher, in November 2019 it was
revised to read a credentialed out of field teacher is a credentialed teacher who has not
yet demonstrated subject matter competence in the subject area for the student population for which
he or she is assigned. Again to address the specifications that local educational agencies
were asking for, the certifications on this slide that were added are bolded slightly.
Originally we had only listed general education limited assignment permits and special education
limited assignment permits, also known as GLAPS and C-LAPS, but also added to the out of field
teacher definition was short-term waivers, emergency English learner or bilingual authorization permits,
and local assignment options. I would now like to turn it over to Monique McWane who will discuss
the proposed amendments. Thank you Kristen. So good afternoon, I am Monique McWane of the Educator
Excellence and Equity Division. Today we are proposing amendments to California's state plan
related to the teacher definitions which Kristen described and data that was just discussed.
So when the department updated the definition of out of field in consultation with the California
Commission on Teacher Credentially, designation of teachers on local assignment options was added.
If an employing agency is unable to assign a teacher or other certificated employee with the
appropriate credential, they can utilize a local assignment option.
Local assignment options are provisions within the education code and Title V regulations that
permit the governing board of a local educational agency to otherwise legally authorize a fully
credentialed educator to serve in an assignment outside the area authorized by their credential.
There are over 40 different types of local assignment options that are utilized in California,
but only one local assignment option which is authorized in California Code Regulations Title
V, Section 8005B, which allows kindergarten through grade 12 staff to teach courses within
their grade level authorization for which no credential exists. There are only specific
courses where the application of this local assignment option applies. The complete list
of specific courses are posted on the commission's website. Examples of this are teachers that teach
study skills courses and student government courses. Teachers that teach these courses
are credentialed in other areas, but must be placed on this local assignment option to teach
these courses for which no credential exists. Because of this, the department is proposing
that local assignment options authorized in Section 8005B, which allow kindergarten through grade 12
staff to teach courses within their grade level authorization, be exempted from the out-of-field
designation. Additionally, the state plan is amended to add the following data tables
which are listed on your screen related to ineffective teachers to meet requirements
from the United States Department of Education.
The data tables are Table 30B, 2019-20 Ineffective Teachers for Title I Schools
by Minority Student Enrollment. Table 31B, 2019-20 Ineffective Teachers for Title I Schools by
Socio-Economically Disadvantaged Student Enrollment. Table 32B, 2019-20 Ineffective Teachers
by Socio-Economically Disadvantaged Student Enrollment. The amended version of the state
plan, which is Attachment 2, updates column headers in Tables 30B, 31B, and 32B. Additionally,
it corrects a data error in Table 30B and makes grammatical edits in Table 28.
Thank you for listening to our presentation of this item.
I will hand this to back, and President Darling-Tammon, are there any questions?
Let me get myself off of mute. Thank you very much for the presentation and the clear explanation.
And at this point, we want to open, we want to put the slide up for the public comment
and open up the public comment queue. Members of the public wishing to provide comment
should call the phone number listed and use the access code provided on the slide that is shown.
And while we're waiting for members of the public to call in, I want to ask Member Son
if she has any initial comments before me. And then I'll ask board members if they have
any clarifying questions before we go to public comment. Member Son.
Thank you. Yes, so I know that whenever this topic of teacher definitions comes up, it's sometimes
a little bit awkward because I feel like we're always trying to put a square peg in this round
whole because we are needing to follow the federal definitions and titles for these teachers,
and we have to take our credentialing system and our authorizations and try to fit them within those
particular titles. So I appreciate the work that CDE staff has done in partnership with the
Commission on Teacher Credentialing staff getting this data. It is new. I think they're continuing
to work on systems so that we can gather this data, but I am very encouraged that now we have
some information and that we'll be continuing to follow these trends. And the other piece, too,
I just want to encourage, I know this is a very difficult time for our LEAs with teacher shortages,
and it's very difficult to find teachers with the correct authorizations in their subject areas
because of so many teachers who've retired and have left the profession. So I know this is a
very important work, and I encourage that partnership with the Commission on Teacher
Credentialing and in the study that the Commission is also doing to take a look at the needs of
credentialing in California over the next few years. So yeah, so that's my general comments.
Thank you. Thank you, Member Sun. And I'm reminded as you speak that you and I have had the
privilege of serving on both the Teacher Credentialing Commission and the State Board
and watching this process unfold. And that's also true of Member Rodriguez. So we have a perspective
on how important these data are, how important they are for equity purposes, to see where
students are getting access to well-qualified teachers, and to the policy environment where
we're really always trying to understand what's going on so that we can make the investments that
are needed to bring people in and keep them in the profession. So it's wonderful to see the data.
We appreciate the staff's work on this and the fine-tuning of the definitions
to make sense in our system. With that, if there are any particular clarifying questions
only at this point before we go to public comment, I'll see if anyone has any of those,
and then we'll open for more discussion after public comment. I see one clarifying question
coming from Member Rodriguez. Yes, hi. Thank you so much for the presentation. And I understand
we are working within these parameters. I did have a question about the out-of-field teacher,
and I've brought this up before, because I teach AVID, even though I'm credentialed to teach English,
Spanish, and social studies, I'm classified as an out-of-field teacher. And I was wondering,
when you mentioned the study skills, does that qualify under that? And is it the district who
will then add the exemption on their behalf? I can take that one. I also am a former history
social science teacher that taught AVID, so I can feel you, your pain in that situation.
But you are exactly the teacher we're talking about. That would be under local assignment option
800005B. So AVID does count there. And so this would take you out of the out-of-field category.
I take that one, 800005B. That's you. All right. Thank you. Thank you. I always feel so bad when I
have to sign the little paper that I'm teaching out-of-field. I'm like, ah.
No, you do not get reported in these data. Any other clarifying questions?
All right. With that, we'll go to public comment.
We do have one speaker for item number six. Speaker, please state your name and affiliation
for the record. Your time starts now. Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond
and board members. Liz Guian with Public Advocates for the LCFS Equity Coalition.
We support this item and we really appreciate the mock tables that were attached to this item.
But we want to repeat our request that we made in May and July that the board call for a data
quest sample teacher data display with data from the 1920 initial data match so that it reflects
appropriately assigned and fully credentialed teachers and gives us the opportunity to see
the display and review it and comment. The presentation of such a display with actual data
would give us and the public an opportunity to give feedback as the department continues to
fine-tune the presentation of teacher quality data in the dashboard in preparation for the
full data quest rollout in late 2021. We thank you and we thank the department for all its hard work
in this area. Thanks. Thank you. This concludes public comment.
All right. Thank you very much. Is there board discussion at this point? I see Vice President
Strauss. Thank you and thank you so much for, Kristen, for the work and for the whole,
I know this is really challenging and particularly in a secondary school. I just appreciated member
Rodriguez's example, which actually you also have, Kristen. And I think it just shows the challenges
we have in trying and making sure that we have teachers fully credentialed that know the content
and the pedagogy for the grade level that they're assigned. And then there are electives like AVID,
all kinds of different electives and study skill courses that we have to look at local decision
making to make sure we provide the support with teachers who have experience at that grade level
and also understanding that it's a complicated puzzle when you're putting together a student six
or seven period day with teachers and how you manage all that. So I appreciated all the work
to having all these different credentials, but at some time you're going to need local
authorization. I think particularly with electives and support classes, it becomes really important.
And so as we can meet the intent of the law and still give districts the support and flexibility
they need, I think we need to continue to make that a priority. So students get the support
and that we can meet all of our requirements that we continue to add to try to meet student
diverse needs. Thank you. Thank you. Are there any other comments? This is an information item.
And I'll just reinforce the comment that came from
public advocates that, you know, we would love to see the tables as they're being developed as
the reporting structure comes along, because it'll be a very important part of the
actual rationale for this work that will inform the public in some very important ways.
And seeing no other comments, I'm told that we should now take another break, which is a lovely
thing since we just had one. But I think we need to take another little 10 minute break,
and we'll be back at 1.40. Excuse me, President Darling-Hammond, this is an action item.
Oh, it is. Okay. I'm sorry. Then we do need. Oh, yes, we do have to pass this. Yes. Sorry about that.
Let's see if there's a motion. I will make the motion. Thank you very much.
And I'll second it. Thank you. Any further discussion? All right. Brooks, call the roll.
Member Sun. Aye. Vice President Strauss. Yes. Member Rucker. Yes. Member Rodriguez. Yes.
Member Patillo-Brownson. Yes. Member McQuillan. Yes. Member Glover-Woods.
Yes. Member Escobedo. Yes. President Darling-Hammond.
Yes. Member Burr. Aye. Member Bonacca. Aye. That's unanimously.
All right. And I'm going to ask you, Executive Director Allen, whether there is a reason that
we need to take a break at this time, or can we continue on? We can continue. Thank you.
I'm following the script, which caused me to believe this was an information item,
and that we needed to take a break. But we will continue on, because we have a lot to do.
We want to get out of here by dinnertime, and I think folks had a nice lunch break.
So we'll move on to item seven, which is a wonderful item. This is an item on the National
Board for Professional Teaching Standards Certification Incentive Program. It's actually
related to the last item that we just heard, because this is really a way to address the needs
for both getting and keeping teachers in our highest-need schools, where the turnover is often
the greatest. So the CDE recommends that the State Board approve the program Information Criteria
Procedures and Application for the National Board for Professional Teaching Standards Certification
Incentive Program. And this item will be presented by Monique McWane of the CDE. Thank you.
I would first like to hand it to Deputy Cotton
to begin our presentation. I believe she's in the boardroom.
Deputy Superintendent Cotton. I believe I can be heard. Okay, great. You can be heard.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, Vice President Strauss, Superintendent Thurmond,
and members of the State Board. I'm Cheryl Cotton, Deputy Superintendent of Instruction,
Measurement, and Administration Branch, and I have the pleasure of introducing this item.
Today our team will provide a brief background on the National Board for Professional Teaching
Standards, MBPTS, Certification Incentive Program that was included in the 2021 budget.
The program includes incentives for current National Board Certified Teachers, or MBCTs,
as well as a subsidy to assist teachers that would like to obtain National Board certification
with the costs associated with certification. Teachers that are eligible for these incentives
must teach at high priority schools, and we will discuss how the Budget Act of 2021 defines high
priority schools. In addition, we will discuss each program's timeline and application process.
The California Department of Education, or CDE, recommends that the State Board of Education, SBE,
approve the program information, criteria, procedures, and application for the MBPTS
Certification Incentive Program. We appreciate your consideration, and now I will hand it over
to Monique McWane and Kristen Cruz-Allen of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division
to provide additional details of this item.
Thank you, Deputy Cotton. I am Monique McWane of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division again,
and I will be presenting this item with my colleague, Kristen Cruz-Allen, Administrator
of the Teacher Leader Policy Office. Assembly Bill 130 reestablished the National Board
Professional Teaching Standards Certification Incentive Program to award grants to school
districts for the purpose of providing awards to teachers who are assigned to teach in high priority
California public schools and have attained certification from the National Board. This
bill requires the State Board of Education to approve the program information, criteria,
procedures, and application for this program, as mentioned.
Any teacher who has already attained certification from the National Board
is eligible to receive an award of $5,000 each if the teacher agrees to teach at a high priority
school for at least five years for a total of up to $25,000. In addition, this program will provide
a $2,500 subsidy for teachers at high priority schools who initiate and complete the process
of pursuing national board certification to cover the costs of the program.
The sum of $250 million is available from the state budget for these purposes.
Of this amount, at least $25 million must be used to cover the National Board for Professional
Teaching Standards Certification fees for first-time candidates. The remainder of the funds
shall be used to award grants pursuant to the National Board for Professional Teaching Standards
Certification Incentive Program. For reference, if all current 4,331 National Board Certified
Teachers in California were to teach for five years at a school on the high priority school list,
the fiscal cost would be over $100 million. This would leave over $140 million to provide
the subsidies to over 55,000 new candidates in the next five years.
High priority schools. California Assembly Bill 130 also defines high priority schools
to those with 55% or more of its unduplicated pupils classified as English learner,
foster youth, or eligible for a free or reduced price meal. The list of high priority schools
for the 2021-22 school year can be accessed on the department's National Board Certification
Incentive Program webpage. There are currently 6,725 high priority schools based on 2020-21
California Longitudinal Public Achievement Data Systems Information, or CALPATS.
To note, teachers that qualify for the program at a high priority school will not have to change
schools if the school's enrollment data dips below 55% in the subsequent year.
In addition to the incentive for existing National Board Certified Teachers,
the state is also providing a grant subsidy to support the new candidates working in high
priority schools that initiate the process for pursuing National Board Certification.
To be eligible, candidates must meet all eligible criteria set forth by the National Board,
register with the National Board by February 28, 2022, work in a high priority school,
and work in eligible assignments and school sites, which we will discuss on future slides.
To be eligible to enter a National Board Program, educators must possess a bachelor's degree from a
accredited institution, candidates for Career and Technical Education Certificates are excluded
from this requirement in California, have completed three years of successful teaching in one or more
early childhood, elementary, middle, or secondary school, hold a valid state teaching degree,
hold a valid state teaching license, or meet the pupil personnel services credential applying for
early childhood through young adult school counseling certificate for each of the three
years of employment they verify, and if registering as a world language candidate,
the educator must provide official American counsel on the teaching of foreign languages,
certified ratings of advanced low or higher in speaking and writing proficiency assessments.
The candidate subsidy application. Candidate subsidy applications will be available on the
department National Board Certification Incentive Program webpage on board approval. Candidates
need to submit an initial application for the first year of their candidacy.
Candidates do not need to reapply for the subsidy each year unless they change school sites or
districts. Candidates status will be verified annually with the National Board as well as
district staff. Pending board approval, this is the 2021-22 timeline for the subsidy application.
We hope to post the application quickly if the board approves this at this meeting and close
the application at the end of January. In February, we will notify applicants if they are approved
so they have time to complete the National Board registration before it closes at the end of
February. This timeline will most likely be adjusted in subsequent years to provide candidates more
time to apply for the program. I am now going to hand the presentation over to
Kristin Cruz-Allen to present on the incentive program. Thank you. Thank you, Monique.
So California Assembly Bill 130 stated that in addition to classroom teachers, there are other
eligible educators for this program which include educators in a teacher leadership role such as
peer assistance and review coaches, mentors, other teacher support providers, and school
counselors with pupil personnel services credentials. In addition, AB 130 defined
eligible entities working in the following high priority local educational agencies,
including school districts, county boards of education, county superintendent of schools,
and a number of other locations as noted on this slide including state operated programs,
special schools, and regional occupational centers. So again, you must be in a high priority school
but it can be these different types of local educational agencies but they must be high priority.
So applications for the annual incentive program for current national board certified teachers
hopefully will be available on our web page very very soon. We actually have them all the
applications ready to go. If there are any updates that are adopted today, we certainly can make
those before we post. Similar to the subsidy program, national board certified teachers need
to submit an initial application for the first year of their incentive and they do not need to
reapply each year unless they change school sites or districts. And each year CDE staff will verify
that they were in a teaching position at a high priority school for at least 50 percent of their
time and we will also be verifying with national board that they have a high priority school
certification up to date.
And we'll go to the next slide. So let me see, I think we're actually on the next slide.
I apologize. Did I skip a slide? I did. Oh here we go. So again, we hope to open the application
for current national board teachers in January or February of 2022. We will confirm that high
priority national board certified teachers with national board to make sure that their certification
is up to date will confirm again in May with the LEAs that these teachers teach at to make sure
that they completed their school year teaching at least 50 percent of their time. And then in June
CDE hopes to release payment to the LEAs to disperse out to their national board teachers.
And one thing that we wanted to note and was really an intent of this legislation
is that this incentive is really encouraged to supplement existing district incentives.
We've spoken to many national board teachers and districts within California
that offer their own incentives to national board certified teachers, but our hope that this will
supplement and not replace those existing district incentives. And we really encourage
local educational agencies to maintain their existing stipends in addition to what teachers
will get through this program. And also we very much encourage school districts to provide adequate
release time to support teachers to complete their certification process.
And we just want to note some really important research that I think most members of the board
are probably pretty familiar with, but we thank our friends at national boards for providing this
for us. That we know that students that are taught by a national board certified teachers
typically learn more than their peers and this can generate up to one or two months of additional
instruction for students and the impact is even greater at high need schools. We also see that
the research tells us that national board certified teachers remain in the profession longer,
which is you know critical in California where we're fighting to retain and recruit new teachers
to the field. And also new teachers that are mentored by national board certified teachers
exhibit improvement in their practice and generate additional student learning. So we're just very
very pleased that this program has come back. We can't wait to get started. We have a lot of
interest. We held an initial webinar just to say the program is coming and we were coming to the
board today. We had almost 700 people attend that webinar. Lots of questions about eligibility
and great excitement being generated out in the field. And finally I just want to recognize Sarah
Pinsky and Stacey Hicks with the national board who have been our absolute partners getting this
going, this program back in place. They're here with us today in case we have some specific
questions for them. They've just been invaluable and I also want to recognize Dr. Travis Bristol.
We worked with him through the diversifying the teacher workforce as he has led the advisory
board for the California Department of Education and he was newly elected chairman of the national
board of directors and we look forward to working with him in that capacity as well.
And I will hand it over to President Darling-Hammond and if there are any questions.
Let's put up the public comment slide so that we can allow people to queue up. Those who would
like to call in can use the numbers on the slide and the participant access code. And while we're
waiting for folks to form that queue I want to turn to Ida Rodriguez. I want to also note that
member Rodriguez is a national board certified teacher and it's a very rigorous process to
go through where you have to put together a portfolio of your practice with videotapes
of your teaching showing how you plan for your classroom and think about the needs of all the
students demonstrating that on the videotape commentary on that tracking student learning
gains associated with it. It's a very impressive process. It's like board certification in medicine
and this policy could really help us make that possible for many more teachers. So member Rodriguez.
Thank you so much President Darling-Hammond and yes I've been nationally board certified since 2006
and recertified I think six years ago and I first of all want to thank our state legislature and the
governor for making this possible because this is the you know like I'm looking at some items
tomorrow the community schools where we've been talking about deeper learning reaching our students
equity and national board certification is really kind of like the linchpin right because as teachers
we're making it happen on making it happen with our students on a day-to-day basis
and national board certification is by teachers and for teachers right you know I one of my
first leadership opportunities after having certified was serving on the social studies
standards committee right and rewriting the social studies standards and so you know here
I am a national board certified teacher working with other teachers and it's teachers who get to
look at our practice because we open our classrooms via videotape and we get comments that aren't
attached to you know if a personality they're not they're they're you know as as objective as
possible so it's wonderful to see this happening because I think our students will benefit immensely
and especially as you know as we know with certification in California with students
teaching I'm sorry teachers teaching out of their certification area or without licenses
there are our students in the high need schools are the ones that are suffering the most
and we really want to make sure that they have the most reflective practitioners in front of them
and the most teachers who have demonstrated accomplishment in this area and I say that I
emphasize most reflective practitioners because being a national board certified teacher doesn't
make me better than a teacher next to me who isn't board certified it just means that I took some
steps to open up my practice to other people and to myself and really examine you know and and and
and it's continuous because I do this all the time now and it's examining like did this work
did I reach my students how did I do this and um you know this is this is a great step once
teachers certified because the the current standards for teaching are little baby national
board standards right you know I think there's a really nice transition to the updated teacher
standards from five years ago so I'm I'm very excited to see this here thank you
I just want to draw a thread to some of the earlier items we had the concerns raised about whether
the LCFF you know dollars make their way within the school to all the students who need them
that's often about teacher assignment so whether the students with the greatest needs are getting
assigned to teachers with the greatest capacity it's about teacher longevity and and stopping
the churn that happens in a lot of schools and one of the things we know about the longevity and
effectiveness of national board certified teachers as mentors as well as as individual practitioners
is that they stabilize when you have enough such teachers in a school they stabilize
and then grow practice and expertise with their colleagues in the school we heard about the
data that will be out regarding the access that students have to quote effective teachers
and again the more experience the more stability the more expertise in a building
the more students benefit so this is a really important way to transform the school environments
in many schools and in some places entire faculties or grade levels or departments within schools have
gone for board certification together reflecting on and sharing their practice so it is part of a
much more systemic approach to strengthening practice and stabilizing the teaching workforce
in the schools where we are concerned to ensure that students are getting the benefits of the
investments that are being made so with that i don't see any other clarifying questions
i'm going to go to public comment and then we'll come back for discussion and action
we currently have four speakers for item seven
speaker please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
good afternoon state board education members my name is lorraine richards and i'm a classroom
teacher representing the california teachers association cta appreciates that the 2021 budget
act reestablished the nb pts certification incentive program and increased the award amount
to a total of 25 000 for teachers that have attained certification and commit to teaching
at a high priority school for five years cta will always support efforts that provide teachers with
an opportunity for professional learning and advancing their careers thank you very much
thank you caller next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time starts now
good afternoon president darlin hammon and board members i'm tamara simpson california policy
manager for teach plus our teacher leaders are thrilled that the state has revived the national
board certification incentive grant program we provide a letter with some recommendations about
implementation but i want to highlight a few of our recommendations here in developing a long-term
rollout plan we encourage department staff to think about how these grants can incentivize
educator behavior in efforts to facilitate smooth transfers to high priority schools for
interested existing nbcps we recommend either a third application pathway this year or releasing
the 2022 2023 application details early in 2022 with the goal of processing all such applications
by june 2022 we strongly encourage the department to offer technical assistance to lea's
particularly those with several high priority schools finally if the department staff has not
already done so we recommend instituting a teacher advisory process for developing and rolling out
this grant program to make sure that it is responsive to teacher needs and that the grant
has the greatest impact thank you for the opportunity to comment and we look forward
continuing our collaboration with the state board of education
next caller please state your name and affiliation for the record your time starts now
good afternoon this is shilpa ram with public advocates thank you for your presentation on
this item on which our lcf equity coalition sent comments and support last week we believe that
reestablishing this program and offering incentives for board certified teachers to
teach and contribute to high priority schools is much needed to mitigate the widespread teacher
shortage and support students in our letter we encourage the department to take the following
next steps first market and publicize this program as broadly as possible and connect directly with
teachers to ensure that their feedback is incorporated into the marketing materials
second establish a third application process to pave the way for interested nbcps to transfer
to high priority schools in the next application cycle and release details for that cycle if it's
possible and finally offer robust technical assistance to lea's to support nbcps currently
teaching to apply for the annual awards facilitate the transfer of nbcps to high
priority schools such guidance will be invaluable to lea's in developing a strong infrastructure
to welcome and support nbcps in their school communities our equity coalition will be happy
to consult and offer support to the department thank you so much thank you this concludes public
comment all right thank you very much a lot of enthusiasm about this new policy and i want to
open this up to board discussion i see member burr you can start us off okay thank you so much
i too want to offer my deep appreciation actually for bringing this program back having been there
at the birth of it in 2000 under governor davis's major push to try to to provide resources to
highly qualified teachers to teach in schools with the greatest need so i just but i had a
question about the eligibility because i'm just a little bit confused so maybe either christin or
lanique you could put the slide up that talks about it i mean it's really it's my understanding
is that in this current year anyway and i think maybe next year that funding is provided for free
lunch to all students and i know for years and lots of programs we've used this notion of
students who qualify for free or reduced price lunch and i just i just wanted to know how that
was going to work if i have a misunderstanding about who's eligible for that because again as
as we've talked about this morning and in the comments that preceded me we want to make sure
that this these funds are targeted to those schools most in need so i just wanted to clarify the
that's not the slide but it's a slide that talks about eligibility for people to apply
for the incentive funding i think maybe it's though i just saw it there briefly
i think yeah with the 55 here because i read that it says it's classified as english learner
foster youth or eligible for a free or reduced price meal and i didn't know again given the
fact that we are providing and maybe it's a state program versus federal program
but if you could clarify that for me i'd appreciate it that's a really good point um i
know that the the list isn't exhaustive so obviously that everybody was eligible for the
free or reduced price meals this year it's not the list doesn't include all lea's in california
and it was provided to us by cindy kazanis's folks and then we went ahead and we
um filtered the information to find schools with 55 percent or more so it is posted online
and i don't think we have cindy on board for this item to specify for you um the free or reduced
price lunch piece and i apologize but i know that the the data was provided by her office and then
we um we made sure that we found which which sites were eligible from there
and it it's six it's approximately 6,725 schools that are listed as high priority
okay so if you could just clarify that because i think going forward especially
if if if we are fortunate enough to continue providing meals to all students
right i would just want to know what metric or what what we're using here to make sure that
again we're we are truly targeting high priority schools thank you thank you good point member
escapado i want i want to share i believe there's less than three percent national nationally
student i mean teachers who have this certification and probably less in these high priority schools
so we'll love to see you know later on how we've improved the percentages in these high priority
schools because i agree with uh president uh darling hammon that when you have a a significant
number um you know you have that multiplier effect it could really enhance the ability to decrease
achievement gap so this is a great start a lot of work to be done and um i'm really really happy
that this is uh up for approval yeah uh and i'll just note that when we had this program before
back in the day as member burr was recalling there was a study done that found that board
certified teachers were much more equitably distributed across schools in california
than they were in other states so it did have a positive effect uh and so we look forward to
that finding being replicated member glover woods and then member rucker just had a question in
regards to incentivizing teachers for the 2022-23 school year is the current application process
that's being proposed taking that into consideration i know some of the comments
talked about a third application wave but if you could share a little bit about the conversation
related to how we might be able to incentivize more teachers with this in high priority schools
for the 2022-23 school year well i know we have a shortened application window this year
because actually national board their application process closes on february 28 2022
so as monique stated we're gonna try and go live with our state application as soon as the board
acts maybe tomorrow hopefully and and make sure that we get things going so that they can meet
the national board deadline but in the future we're gonna make sure that we open our application
much earlier so there's a lot more time for teachers to apply for the next school year
and we also did consult with the national board on the length of their registration and although
it does seem like a tight timeline this year we believe that the registration process will allow
people to be able to apply so and we didn't want to hold the program a year due to this tight
timeline we wanted to give as many much opportunity as possible so we're hoping for as christin said
a more robust timeline next year a longer timeline and just to be clear there's some people who may
be going for board certification now and using the resources to apply others already have it
and they'll be eligible for the salary incentive right correct correct um i see member rucker
thank you i was going to comment on the subsidy application timeline because it is very very tight
and given everything else that districts are currently being tasked to do during the same
time frame it can be problematic for districts that don't already have the infrastructure in place
to support a professional development project of this scope and magnitude so i'm glad to hear
monique say that um there's going to be some flexibility or a longer arc in the application
going down the line so i appreciate that i was also going to talk to the report that
board president hammon spoke about on the equitable distribution of board certified teachers across
the state of california and california was unique not only at that time but i would
i would suspect and even assert that um status remains pretty much in place one of the things
i did not see here in this report from you all is how you're going to monitor the net change or
impact on the workforce or what the magnitude of impact for this project and this funding is going
to be do you have some way or and is there a plan to come back and report to the board um you know
a year down the road when you begin the new application timeline for the next funding cycle
to report on what has happened where the schools are that are being funded and the types of programs
or certifications that are being supported in this process we can definitely take that under
advisement to bring that back and provide the um information and the data surrounding the program
next year at this time yeah i think that's very important i'm surprised that that was not considered
as part of this report and presentation to the board i think that's very very important to take
a look at especially since we want to say that there is a magnitude of impact on having this
level of expertise and this level of preparation and training in our workforce particularly in
servicing the needs of underserved or students who are those high need students i think it is
important to have that information and to plan forward the other thing i want to say and it's
not directly related to this item so i'm going to apologize up front i want to remind uh the
it's probably important especially given what we just finished doing with item with the
previous item on the l cap that as the title two funds also support this program and that districts
are can be encouraged to use that as write that into their planning with their l cap as well and
again for the districts whose l caps i've read i have maybe this will be an opportunity as they
begin updating their l caps this year that they will consider using their title two funds there
are very few l caps i've read that even mention how they're using their title two funds to support
professional development they just list 47 different professional development activities that never
seem to go anywhere from year to year and this might be an opportunity to create some priority
in the use of those title two funds to add additional support to this program as it rolls out
and Kristen it's been a long time since i've seen you it's good to see you
thank you so much for being here today
thank you and with that i see no other hands raised and i wonder if i could get a motion
to approve this recommendation member rodriguez it's appropriate for you to move this question
and so i'll should i read the recommendation um sure uh the cde recommends that the state that
we the state board approve the program information criteria procedures and application
for the mbps certification incentive program all right do i have a second
i'll second it i saw member glover woods a seconding and member rucker you get a third
you get to 30 uh with that is there any other discussion of the item all right uh
executive director alan can you call the roll
and the um folks
aye vice president strouse aye member rucker yes member rodriguez yes member patillo brownson
yes member mcquillin yes member glover woods yes member escapado yes president darling hamond
yes yes member burr aye member bonacca aye passes unanimously all right and at this point
we will take a break get that cup of tea or coffee or whatever you need to keep going thank you
manik thank you kristen for this item presentation and let's come back in around 2 25 you get 13
minutes all right welcome back uh brooks can you help us reestablish the quorum by calling the roll
of course member son present vice president strouse president member rucker
yes member rodriguez yes member patillo brownson yes member mcquillin yes member glover woods
yes member escapado yes president darling hamond yes member burr yes member bonacca
here everyone's present we have a quorum
wonderful i will go to agenda item eight which is a public hearing regarding the 2021 arts
education adoption of k-8 instructional materials uh and the instructional quality
commission's recommendations uh the cde recommends that the state board act on the following two
recommendations to adopt the two visual arts and one music program recommended by the iqc
and to direct cde staff in conjunction with members of the iqc and our content review
experts as needed to work with publishers to ensure that the iqc recommended edits and
corrections and other publisher errata and administrative updates adopted by the sbe
have been made to their revised instructional materials in order to meet the requirement of
ec section 60200e the cde recommends that the state board specifically find that fewer than
five programs per grade level met the adopt criteria for the adoption and this item will
be presented by mike torrez of the cde mike take it away thank you so much uh president darling
hamond i do want to pass it over to deputy superintendent cotton to introduce this item
thank you dr torrez
i'll go ahead and get started it's great to join you today as we initiate the final step in this
process of the 2021 arts education adoption for instructional materials for kindergarten through
grade eight i'd like to open with a quote from the california arts standards which the board
adopted in january 2019 an arts education helps children and youth make sense of the world
communicate their unique ideas across boundaries and discover who they are as individuals
and as members of various groups students who experience a quality arts education have an
opportunity to engage in complex and and nuanced thinking around meaningful work
these words from elliot eisner's 2002 book the arts and the creation of mind
resonate differently with me now than they did when they were printed in the front matter
of the standards in 2019 today students are making sense of a different dynamic world
that continues to shift in the wake of what we've seen in the two short years since the
board's action now perhaps more than any time in our recent collective memory
the need to communicate unique ideas across boundaries is of paramount importance not only
eisner says to discover who they are but for students to lead the way in innovative approaches
to complex modern problems arts education can embolden these approaches in short
arts education is the meaningful work that begets the meaningful work california students will
perform the arts standards provide the outcomes or the what for 21st century arts learning
the guidance in the board adopted 2020 arts education framework supports the foundational
instruction and assessment to quality arts learning in schools or the how and specifies
the evaluation criteria for the development of high quality instructional materials that accomplish
those goals today we present the findings from the 2021 arts instructional materials adoption
and the recommendations outlined in the instructional quality commission's advisory report
and the recommendations for visual arts and music programs for the state level adoption
i have with me dr dr mike torrez the interim director of the curriculum frameworks and
instructional resources division who will provide an overview of the process and the
iqc's recommendations dr torrez thank you so much deputy superintendent cotton for those
words of introduction and thank you to the board members for this opportunity to share with you
the results of this unique adoption process the completion of this project is a testament to the
work of the instructional materials reviewers the content review experts the cd staff and the
iqc facilitators including commissioners fairchild costa hernandez and jarvis who together engaged in
the state's first entirely virtual adoption training and deliberations i also want to recognize
commission chair rustin and subject matter chair estorga almanza for their work i'll share a bit
more about this later but i'd like to provide an initial thank you to all those who helped ensure
this process was efficient successful and aligned with the outcomes of state-led meetings
so on this slide we do have the provided cd recommendation based on the instructional quality
commission's recommendation the cd does recommend that the state board act to adopt three instructional
materials programs as recommended by the iqc and to direct cd staff in conjunction with members of
the iqc and or content review experts as needed to work with publishers to ensure that the edits and
corrections and other publisher errata and administrative updates adopted by the state board
have been made to their revised instructional materials let me continue with a short recap of
the steps that brought us here today the adoption of instructional materials is dictated both by
statute and in the california code of regulations the next few slides will be an overview of those
major milestones in that adoption process the adoption process officially began in july of 2020
specifically july eight and nine when the state board of education adopted the new arts education
framework the new curriculum framework plays a fundamental role in the adoption process
it elaborates on the philosophical foundations that underpin the standards
including the national core art standards or encast it also articulates the evaluation criteria
for instructional materials at that same meeting in july the board also approved the schedule of
significant events and the reviewer application for the adoption and then on september 24th
2020 following the framework adoption the cd posted an initial bulletin for publishers
interested in participating in the adoption on january 13 to 14 2021 the state board then
appointed instructional materials reviewers and content review experts that were recommended by
the instructional quality commission a total of 44 people were appointed to review the materials and
that represents all five arts disciplines from dance media arts music theater and visual arts
because at that time we didn't know which programs would be submitted title five regulations require
a majority of instructional materials reviewers be classroom teachers in an arts discipline
and per those regulations each of the review panels included at least one
board appointed content review expert the panels also included board appointed curriculum leaders
and community members on january 27 2021 the california department of education hosted the
publisher's invitation to submit meeting where the statutory and regulatory requirements for
participation in the adoption process were explained this meeting was open to the public
and invited public comment ultimately five publishers submitted programs for review three
of those for visual arts and two of those for music in february in february and march the cde
designed an all virtual reviewer training utilizing resources and materials developed from board
adopted content originally used for in-person trainings i'll talk a bit more about those
trainings and subsequent deliberations later in this presentation reviewers had the privilege
of being sworn in by member strauss and trained by cd staff with the support of the three aforementioned
iqc facilitators may 7 2021 was the deadline for providing reviewers with access to the materials
which in this adoption happened to be all digital programs may 7th also marked the beginning of the
independent review period now this period of independent review lasted through july and
included regular communication and timely reminders from cd project leads in this case for arts it was
kyle petty the virtual deliberations began on july 19th with reviewers meeting in zoom and three
panels to discuss and evaluate the five programs that were submitted these programs garnered no
written public comment prior to the deliberations and during deliberations the panels took public
comment twice daily after much discussion and consensus building panels formalized their
recommendations and co-created an instructional material material reviewer content review expert
or imr cre report of findings for each of those programs these reports were forwarded to the
instructional quality commission and were also posted on the cde website i'd like to take a
quick pause here on the timeline to take a moment to talk about the work that was completed by the
staff in the curriculum frameworks and instructional resources division or seaford to prepare for and
orchestrate this first ever virtual adoption process adoptions have until this point involved
contracts with local hotels event spaces air travel event transportation on-site lodging
for reviewers and the division has in the past transported materials including laptops printers
projectors large screens folders reviewer materials and submitted programs to and from
conference rooms each day of the training and each day of the deliberations the training involves
a lot of whole group presentations individual and group reviewer work on specific board approved
content and opportunities to establish a report with fellow panelists the deliberation days are
full with iqc facilitators and cd staff and individual conference rooms working with reviewers
to verbally and manually tally program alignment with each individual content standard and each
evaluation criterion as indicated in the framework this process alone can take one to two days
reviewers then draft questions deliberate on findings and ultimately co-write their reports
of findings so as we all know the pandemic upended this entire in-person process and so
and so with many others including our virtual state board meeting today
yet the division staff worked tirelessly to ensure the process could be adapted to proceed
in a virtual environment like many educators during the pandemic the project leads created
google classrooms for the reviewers and used that platform to arrange materials to prepare
reviewers for the training there were training requirements that reviewers completed prior to
meeting in april including independent learning modules completion of the form 700
and ethics training requirements they use google classroom to share sections of the framework
and arts discipline standards and storm and stored the zoom meeting information
and any relevant files separated in tabs by by day and each day of the training reviewers
attended synchronous sessions public meetings conducted by seaford staff and engaged in
asynchronous modules that extended their learning on content covered or prepared them by front
loading information that would then be covered on subsequent days each of the three panels
necessitated one cd staff to act as a host or technology support and another to moderate in
support of the iqc facilitator additional cd staff were on hand to lend their expertise
to panels on a full breadth of questions ranging from the process of adoptions to social content
violations cd ensured we had backup staff for every role and staff were monitoring virtual back
channels of communication which expedited requests of lead headquarter staff to jump
into any zoom meeting to answer questions quickly and provide clarification as requested
beyond seaford we would not have been able to execute the training and deliberations
without the support of our amazing technology services division and our captioning partner
reviewer materials remained in google classroom during the independent review as did access
information for assigned programs the platform's synchronicity with google documents and google
forms became a crucial step in the success of the deliberations process
now we took what we learned from the virtual reviewer trainings that occurred in april and
applied what we learned to the virtual deliberations three months later in july
enter our newly developed summary tally sheet prior to day one of the deliberations week
reviewers completed the initial tallies using google forms essentially each reviewer completed
a form that asked if the program met or did not meet each of the listed evaluation criteria and
standards the summary tally sheet then showed the ratio of yes to no then highlighting areas of
consensus and disagreement among the reviewers these submissions allowed seaford staff to provide
initial tally data at the outset on the first day of deliberations the process which i mentioned
earlier once took one to two full days to complete the data provided a snapshot of the panel's
overall findings and allowed facilitators to identify contentious points they could use to
inform in-depth discussions again with a majority of reviewers submitting these initial tallies
facilitators could provide a big picture perspective of the program in the eyes of the reviewers
identifying these area of reviewer consensus and disagreement or what we call our hot spots
helped facilitators prioritize the in-depth discussions that took place around certain
standards and or criteria the result was a faster smoother review process in some cases
resulting in groups initiating the report of findings drafting process much earlier than had
been done in the past the sharing of a digital template for these reports also allowed seaford
staff to see the documents creation in real time vastly improving the feedback process and facilitating
more productive revisions we have learned a tremendous amount in this process and we know
different content area adoptions yield different amounts of publisher and public interest
larger adoptions like say mathematics or english language arts may be as successful if they were
held entirely in a virtual setting additionally we know most educators value in-person engagement
and the kinds of learning and productivity that it creates with that said most reviewers lauded
this adoption and the adapted virtual process we sought feedback from reviewers and their
and if we possibly sought feedback from the reviewers and their responses will not only
improve our future virtual adoptions if we do consider these in the future but greatly improve
our ability to recruit engage with and support professional educators without compromising the
work they're doing in their local context and classrooms
and so now i take us back to the timeline of events the iqc hosted a meeting to take public
comment on the adoption and the reports of findings on august 17th 2021 all public comments received
were submitted to the state board of education office the period between august 18th and september
22nd 2021 included the required 30 day period between the public hearing and the next iqc
meeting to discuss the reports of findings on september 22nd to 23rd 2021 the members of the
instructional quality commission considered the recommendations from the imr cre review panels
public comments and individual commission review to determine whether each program satisfied
or did not satisfy the sve adopted evaluation criteria for this adoption
prior to action the iqc conducted two public hearings once during the arts subject matter
committee on september 22nd and another time during the full iqc meeting on september 23rd
at each step in the process the commissioners heard testimony from members of the public
and from publishers and now here we are on this historic day for california arts educators and
students before i share the recommendations of the iqc i do want to point out that the outcome
of this adoption may result in the recommendation of fewer than five of the submitted programs
the sbs recommendations after consideration of the review panels reports of findings
the iqc advisory report and public comment and the aspects of this timeline related to
notifying the public and soliciting publisher submissions does satisfy california education code
section 60200 a which allows the state board to adopt fewer than five programs when fewer than
five satisfy the state board adopted arts education framework and its approved evaluation criteria
for instructional materials
each meeting during this process did include opportunities to hear public comment in the
virtual space of the meetings this included time certain agendized times during the facilitator
and reviewer training and opportunities again twice each day during the deliberations no public
comment was received during the facilitator training reviewer training or during the independent
review period leading up to the deliberations i'll discuss the comments received during
deliberations and at the iqc meetings in in upcoming slides these documents are in the
deliberations folder at fox.com so now you must be thinking dr torrez you've been talking all
this time and we haven't heard any recommendations yet so here we go the recommendations of the
commission are in the iqc advisory report which was provided as an attachment to this item
the commission is recommending three of the five programs that were submitted for this adoption
so i'll start off with the discipline of visual arts the commission recommends the programs
submitted by the art of education university and davis publications inc so that would be flex
curriculum and explorations in art the second edition the commission is not recommending one
visual arts program the one submitted by arts attack also named program title arts attack
the reasons for this recommendation are included in the report but in short the commission felt
that the program did not meet several of the criteria statements in categories one two three
and four and there are five categories mind you the art of education university responded to
reviewer concerns raised during deliberations providing additional resources and standards
alignment information arts attack and davis publications provided responses to the formal
reviewer questions and discussed those responses in a session during the second day of deliberations
arts attack did not provide additional comment even as the reviewers drafted a report indicating
the program would not be recommended this includes opportunities at both iqc meetings davis publications
has submitted publisher errata forms that have been accepted as a condition of the program's
recommendation by the iqc so now let's talk about the music programs quaver ed inc for their program
quaver ed music provided responses to questions posed during the deliberations it also submitted
publisher errata which the iqc accepted as part of its recommendation as a reminder these components
are all located in box.com the iqc is not recommending the music program submitted by opus u inc
named opus u learning the reasons for this recommendation are also included in the iqc
advisory report the commission felt that the program did not meet several of the criteria
statements in categories one two four and five during the review panel's deliberations opus u
provided responses to questions posed by the panel and was given an opportunity to address the panel
regarding these concerns after those deliberations in advance of the august 17th iqc meeting the
publisher did submit a lengthy letter in an attempt to review the review panel's findings
which was then provided to the iqc the arts subject matter committee took the matter up first
and its meeting reflected that its members carefully reviewed the publisher's letter
along with the program but nonetheless concluded that the program did not meet the conditions for
adoption as you know those conditions require alignment with all criteria in category one of
the board adopted evaluation criteria which includes full coverage of grade level standards
additionally as i noted previously the report of findings did not indicate program strengths in
categories two four and five in which publishers must show strengths in order to meet adoption
criteria ultimately both the arts smc and the full iqc unanimously decided not to recommend the
program to the state board of education so let's talk about the iqc advisory report so in general
these advisory reports include a detailed rationale for each decision to recommend or not recommend
a program and includes citations in each of the five categories of the state board adopted
criteria these would be citations for or citations of why it doesn't meet the report also includes
the recommended edits and corrections and social content for each program it is our
recommendation that these recommended edits including the iqc accepted publisher errata
be made as a condition for adoption if the state board elects to adopt these materials
these recommended edits came from a combination of the reviewer panel reports
errata submitted by the publishers and public comment made to the iqc the commissioners considered
all of these sources of input when deciding which edits to add to their recommendation
at this time i'd like to on behalf of the commission thank the board for its support
throughout the adoption process and we hope that the materials you adopt today
will provide support for districts existing and expanding visual arts and music learning aligned
with the arts education framework i'd like to take a brief moment to talk about what the next
steps will be after the board takes action following this meeting there will be a 60 day
timeline for publishers of adopt state board adopted instructional material programs to submit
all edits and corrections to be verified by the cde since digital programs linked to the cd website
do not reflect any of these edits or corrections or those errata submitted by publishers since
they're in the original format that reviewers use to conduct their review the final versions
of instructional materials will not be available until the state board adopted
edits and corrections have been made i'd also like to speak to the recommendations herein by
reminding the board and those in attendance today that local control allows school districts to
choose instructional materials that are in the best interest of their students and their community
these choices also apply to adopting instructional materials the state's process is designed to offer
districts choices of instructional materials to match the needs of their students now not all
instructional materials are alike and that is a benefit for districts lea's seeking to adopt
visual arts and music materials need not restrict themselves to just the state board adopted list
as they conduct their own review of instructional materials the state level review is a first level
review to share with districts the materials that meet the content of the standards the framework
and the criteria districts then engage in their own review of instructional materials to analyze
which programs may best fit their students their programs and their pedagogical needs
so to conclude the cd does recommend that the state board act to adopt the three instructional
material programs recommended by the iqc and to direct cd staff to work with the iqc and content
review experts as needed to work with publishers to ensure that the edits and corrections and
other publisher errata and administrative updates adopted by the state board have been made to the
revised instructional materials and with that i will yield the virtual floor to board president
darling hammond for public comment and moderation of any questions that you may have
all right thank you so much well this is a place where we need to open the floor for public hearing
so i hereby open the public hearing at 251 pm and first we'll hear from any publisher who would
like to comment on this item each publisher will have two minutes following comments from the
publishers we will then move to comment from other members of the public who will each have
one minute and we'll open the phone line for comment from publishers by calling the telephone
number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now please provide your name
and the publisher you are representing for the record and please remember to turn down the
speaker volume of your computers if you are following the live feed and you have two minutes
are there any publishers in the queue yes we have one publisher
please state your name and affiliation for the record your two minutes starts now
my name is scott elliway president of opus u and i wish to comment on agenda item number eight
in terms of my background i've worked for and submitted successful curriculums to this state
board of education via mcgraw hill and pierson i read music at oxford and i'm a fellow in music
at yale university a digital k8 music curriculum entitled opus u learning was submitted the
curriculum rejected california public schools typically do not purchase curriculums that are
rejected by the state board of education the issue for you to consider is that a full review
was not carried out without a full review a week before deliberations is not enough according to
our login matrix the process favors established publishers known to reviewers via brand awareness
we urge you to consider this matter failure will deter other small and unknown publishers from
submitting curriculums to you in the future a level playing field is not possible should you
have doubt about the written public comment that we have submitted to you some 200 pages
we would recommend that you seek counsel from an independent music educator before making a final
judgment on whether we should be adopted or not thank you so much for your time thank you caller
we we do have one um caller from the public in the queue as well
all right we'll go to that okay uh caller please state your name and affiliation for the record
your time starts now
good afternoon martha saragosa diaz representing the californian music educators association
cmea thanks cde and the iqc for their hard work in developing the instruction materials
for the visual arts and music program and the virtual and the virtual visual process used in
developing them we believe the instructional materials are consistent with criteria and the
standards of quality prescribed in the board's adopted curriculum framework and in an alignment
with the content adopted by the board visual arts and music educators look forward to utilizing
these materials in their work of providing standard-based visual arts and music education
cmea requests that the state board adopt the two virtual arts and one music program recommended by
the iqc and staff thank you thank you this concludes public um comment
all right um uh having heard all the public comment i hereby close the public hearing
at 2 55 p.m and we'll now begin board discussion and i first would like to ask our liaison member
rodriguez if she would like to make some initial comments yes hello everyone uh my comments are
my comments are actually first of all complementary to the team that put all of this
uh virtual training and process in place i was incredibly impressed and i actually told dr
torrez that i used some of the uh some of their methods and links like not not related to the
arts but the ideas for my classes and google classroom because it was just so easy to maneuver
and understandable i was actually in between ctc meetings at one point and so like i'd go in the
afternoon and i could find exactly where they were and i really appreciate that and i want to
particularly uh you know compliment um chanin coats cliff rudnick mike tor torrez
kyle petty david amquist let letty krauss erin vertigio i'm not sure if i pronounced her last
name correctly jennifer bentley ken mcdonald jennifer buzolic lisa lipland ashley mitchell
denise figueroa and shani smedley because the virtual process even though it wasn't in person
which i think would you know just upended everything but it just ran so smoothly and
as as a person who was coming in and out i truly appreciate it you had all of the information
that i needed to know what was happening and um the qc commissioners who trained reviewers
and facilitated the deliberations also were incredibly impressive commissioner deborah costa
nandez commissioner lily jarvis and commissioner shea fairchild thank you so much um and to the
subject matter chair commissioner mariana storga almanza i really appreciate all of the work that
you did because your process was very complete thank you terrific uh and at this point i'll open
the floor to um discussion from the board members is there any discussion
uh member rucker well i want to add my compliments to the staff for the work that they did on this
i've had the opportunity to participate and uh support uh textbook adoption processes for
history social science math and english language arts and i had the benefit of being able to
participate in the face-to-face activity but watching how accomplished the process was to
support this work and do it virtually it's just impressive what was considered to improve the
process and to ensure to i'm sorry to assure the engagement of all of the members who were sitting
on the panels i think it is important to note there was the comment from one of the speakers
in the public comment about the relationship of our reviewers and the uh uh companies that
participate in the process mike could you talk a little bit about how the department actually
recruits and supports small publishers to be able to participate in the process
of yes that that is a great question and so we have um in the side deck as i mentioned we do
have a very public process to be able to share with publishers uh the entire process of start
to finish um including all the requirements um to participate in a in adoption process
um that uh that notification that bulletin if you will is made public
in addition to that we do have an amazing publisher liaison um who works in our division
who has connections with publishers and at times sends out um sends out our communications to
hundreds of publishers whether they've worked with cd or not as as you may know it may be difficult
to to find out all of the the different publishers that exist out there but there is outreach to
figure out who who is developing what curriculum and to be able to reach out to them and let them
know that this is the process this is when it starts and this is how you go about doing it and
the first the first way in is through that publisher bulletin followed by the initial meeting
with with potential publishers to go over that information that's great because i do recall
that there was a lot of conversation at the iqc about this process and the members were really
looking forward to seeing this get underway because the development of the framework took
quite some time and we were engaged being in um in developing the framework itself so i personally
was looking forward to uh this process and what the outcome could be just based on listening to
the conversation of the members of the iqc so mike i really do appreciate you taking the time
to explain that process um i do recall when i worked on the math adoption in particular there
was an opportunity of a subsidy for some small publishers to use as a way of helping them to
apply and participate in the adoption process is that something that was also made available
for vendors for this process as well
i'm sorry i got distracted for a second can you repeat the question i said that i recall
during the adoption for the math program there was an opportunity provided in the budget and
by the legislature with a subsidy so that small publishers and vendors had an opportunity to be
supported in their application to participate in the adoption was something similar to that also
provided for the arts adoption so in in our regulations we do have a caveat to subsidize
the the cost for small publishers and there are specific requirements for how a small publisher
can qualify for that subsidy and we do have a history of small publishers being successful
and adopted by the state board of education for history social studies for example there was a
one-man operation so to speak sorry for the non-gender neutral phrase there that that did
succeed in in getting adopted okay thank you very much i appreciate that thank you so much member
rucker any other discussion from members of the board
i think seeing none we could look for a motion
all right may i make a motion you may make a motion okay all right um i was i was waiting
for the screen to come back up but um let's see so i do have the motion on the screen
and everyone will be able to see it
but you can certainly move the recommendation while we're getting it up there okay so i move
the recommendation the california department of education cd recommends um uh the act to adopt
the three instructional material programs recommended by the iqc and to direct cde staff
in conjunction with members of the iqc and our content review experts as needed to work with
publishers to ensure that the edits and corrections and other publisher errata and administrative
updates adopted by the sve have been made to their revised instructional materials
very good do i have a second i will second thank you very much uh let's call the roll for the vote
member son aye vice president strous yes member rucker yes member rodriguez yes member patillo
brownson yes member mcquillin yes member glover woods yes member escapado yes president darlin
hammond yes member burr aye member bonanca aye that's unanimous all right let's move on to
agenda item nine which is a public hearing regarding the 2021 world languages adoption
of k-ed instructional materials and instructional quality commission recommendations
um and there are 10 programs that the cd recommends that we
adopt uh accept the publisher errata not considered by the iqc and its september 2021 meaning
and direct the cd staff in conjunction with members of the iqc our content review experts
as needed to work with publishers to ensure that the recommended edits and correctives
and any other publisher errata and administrative updates have been made to their revised
instructional materials given that the criteria for the world languages adoption categorizes
programs by proficiency level rather than grade level and fewer than five basic instructional
materials were submitted for each proficiency level in order to meet the requirement of ec
section 60200e the cd recommends that the state board specifically find that more than five
programs met the criteria for the adoption and the item is presented again by mike torrez of the
cd mike thank you so much again president darlin hammond and i will again pass it over to deputy
superintendent cheryl cotton to introduce this item thank you dr torrez it is such a pleasure
to stand before you to take the final step in this process of the 2021 world languages adoption
of instructional materials for grades k through eight it is clear to me that california is ready
to expand opportunities for us to unique and diverse student population to acquire world
languages develop intercultural competence and become global citizens students in the 21st century
with all its technological developments live in a global society people all over the world can
communicate in real time organizations and businesses are multinational and new professions
are continually emerging students that are successful in the 21st century will be those
who are proficient in more than just the core subjects these students will be global citizens
with the ability to navigate the international marketplace communicate proficiently and interact
meaningfully with understanding and awareness across cultures these skills understanding
speaking reading writing and signing in world languages as well as in english are essential
for students to effectively contribute to state and national efforts and succeed in business
research and international relations in the 21st century the world languages standards are the
board that the board adopted in 2019 set lofty goals and the world languages framework
this board adopted in 2020 offer up to the minute suggestions and guidance
for language teachers to help their students achieve these goals and today this board is
considering the adoption of instructional materials that can support local educational agencies
as they promote multilingual multilingualism for all students through access to high quality
well articulated world language programs today we present the findings from the 2021
world languages instructional materials adoption the recommendations outlined in the instructional
quality commission's advisory report and the recommendations for world languages
instructional programs for state level adoption
dr torus will provide an overview of the process and the iqc's recommendations dr torus
thank you again deputy superintendent cotton i am i'm very pleased to join you here the completion
of this project is the result of the admirable work of the educators who served as instructional
material reviewers and content review experts the training and deliberations for this adoption was
completed also entirely virtually and credit does go to the iqc facilitators and cd staff
who innovated and worked tirelessly to ensure this adoption was successful i specifically want
to take a moment to recognize iqc facilitators commissioners young fairchild and commissioner
emeritus not not not it's not it's sorry i'd also like to recognize iqc chair rustin and subject
matter committee chair renteria thank you to all as you helped ensure this process was efficient
successful and aligned with our outcomes
all right so for our recommendations the cde recommends that the state board of education act
to adopt the 10 instructional material programs recommended by the instructional quality commission
accept the publisher errata not considered by the iqc at its september 2021 meeting and direct cd
staff in conjunction with members of the iqc and or content review experts as needed to work with
publishers to ensure that the edits and corrections and other publisher errata and administrative
updates adopted by the state board have been made to their revised instructional materials
i'd like to provide an overview of the steps that brought us here today all of which will look
very similar to you as these dates and events are very similar to the arts education presentation
that you just witnessed we've referred to these internally as our dual adoptions since the cd
the iqc and the state board all have conducted these two at the same time under these same
restraints and same same times and same meetings so the state board of education adopted the world
languages framework in july 8 through 9 of 2020 this curriculum framework reflects significant
shifts in instructional approaches intended to bring about optimal performance among students
in world languages classrooms the world languages standards along with the guidance provided in this
framework respond to a call to action to create a more inclusive learning environment in the world
languages classroom the appendices in the world languages standards and the guidance in the world
languages framework call attention to research-based practices that yield evidence of positive impact
on world languages acquisition chapter 13 in the world languages framework articulates the
evaluation criteria for instructional materials in july the board also approved the schedule of
significant events and the reviewer applications for this adoption on september 24 2020 the cd
did post an initial bulletin for publishers who may be interested in participating in this adoption
at the state board meeting on january 13 through 14 the sbe appointed instructional materials
reviewers and content review experts that were recommended by the instructional quality commission
there were a total of 42 people representing a range of world languages that were appointed to
these review to review the materials now title five regulations require that a majority of
instructional materials reviewers be classroom teachers in world languages and per those
regulations each of the three panels included at least one board appointed content review expert
subsequently the panels included board appointed curriculum leaders and community members
on january 27 2021 the cd did host the publishers invitation to submit meeting where the statutory
and regulatory requirements for participation in the adoption process were explained this meeting
was open to the public and invited public comment ultimately there were 11 publishers who submitted
programs for review now as we did for the arts education the cd designed an all virtual reviewer
training week where review reviewers were trained to evaluate the submitted programs for alignment
with world languages standards and the framework and evaluation criteria that were all adopted by
the board reviewers were sworn in by member strauss and trained by cd staff with the support
of two current and one former iqc member as facilitators before mentioned in the earlier
slide the entire reviewer training was open and transparent to the public including periods of
public comment daily the deadline for providing reviewers with access to the materials for the
world languages adoption was may 14 2021 may 14th also marked the beginning of that independent
review period now that independent review period lasted through july and included communication and
reminders from cd staff at this point it was led by aaron vertiglio and currently being led by
alejandro hernandez virtual deliberations began on july 26th with reviewers meeting in zoom and
three panels to discuss and evaluate the 11 programs that were submitted these programs
did not receive any written public comment prior to the deliberations and during the deliberations
panels took public comment twice daily after much discussion and consensus building panels
formalized their recommendations collaboratively created a report of findings for each program
and these reports were also forwarded to the commission and were posted on the cde website
so just as with the arts adoption the staff and the curriculum frameworks and instructional
resources division or seaford prepared training and deliberations materials for the second ever
virtual adoption process that the cd has ever conducted you might remember the first was the
arts before this year adoptions have taken place at local hotels and event spaces these events
involve complex contracts air travel on-site lodging the transport of all materials and equipment
to the event location and oftentimes key staff would need to physically move from one room to
another to share their expertise and answer any questions the attendees would have causing a delay
in getting the needs of the reviewers met so as in the world the arts the world languages
reviewer trainings were modified to be held virtually google classroom was used as the
learning management system for the reviewers in order to arrange the materials to prepare
reviewers for the training reviewers were given tasks to be completed prior to meeting in april
including that independent front loading of learning modules and the required form 700
and ethics training requirements the world languages standards and organized zoom information
the schedules and other relevant files were also made available to reviewers in google classroom
the virtual format opened up some additional opportunities so for example participants were
invited to complete daily surveys which allowed cd staff to revise slides and revisit any steps
in the review process in real time based on need so it was an evolving training the training involved
public synchronous sessions and asynchronous modules that extended their learning on content
covered each of the three included two cd staff members one to act as a host and the other to act
as a support for the iqc facilitator to help moderate in addition additional cd staff were
present to share their expertise answer questions on the review and deliberations process during the
independent review the training materials and access information for assigned programs also
remained in google classroom so this slide may look familiar because it's basically the arts
um summary tally sheet but modified specifically for world languages you'll notice that
instead of grade levels there are performance levels everyone involved in the virtual training
that took place in april learned quite a bit from the process which allowed facilitators and staff
alike to apply their learning to streamline and strengthen the virtual deliberations that took
place in july in the arts presentation i shared the huge time savings from collecting initial tally
data digitally which helped identify evaluation criteria where the reviewers were in agreement
and areas where there needed to be focused discussion the result was a faster smoother
review process in some cases resulting in groups initiating that report of findings drafting much
sooner than anticipated so once consensus reached for each criteria the digital template of the
reports of findings placed in the digital collaborative environment for these reports
allowed seaford staff to see the document creation in real time create opportunities
for instant feedback streamlined the feedback process and lastly zoom features including
reactions also facilitated and expedited the process to garner reactions from the reviewers
all those involved in the process have learned so much about conducting our instructional materials
adoptions virtually and seaford staff specifically envisioned that conducting training and
deliberations in an adoption process virtually can benefit all future adoptions including those
that are likely to involve a greater number of publisher submissions while we acknowledge
that many educators do value those engagement activities the reviewers just applauded the
process and applauded how well things went and we additionally sought feedback from reviewers
to improve future adoptions so that we can improve in real time
so i'll continue now with our timeline of events the iqc did host a public meeting to take public
comment on august 17th 2021 those public comments received for world languages were submitted to the
state board of education the period between august 18 and september 22nd included that required 30
day period between the public hearing and the next iqc meeting in order to discuss the reports
of findings and then in september 22nd to 23rd the members of the iqc considered the recommendations
for the imr cre review panels the public comments and individual commission review to determine
whether each program satisfied or did not satisfy the sb adopted evaluation criteria for this
adoption prior to taking action the iqc did conduct their public hearings one during the
world languages subject matter committee on september 22nd and another during the full
commission meeting on september 23rd over the entire process the commissioners provided
opportunities for members of the public to provide testimony yet no testimony was provided
so that brings us to this exciting day in california for world languages and the students
and educators who will benefit from these instructional materials i would like to take
a moment to highlight though that given the criteria for the world languages adoption
how it categorizes programs by proficiency level rather than grade level fewer than five basic
instructional materials were submitted for each proficiency level in order to meet the
in order to meet the requirement of ed code section 60200e which allows the state board
specifically find that more than five programs met the criteria for adoption
as in the arts process the world languages instructional materials adoption was a very
very transparent process we included opportunities to hear verbal public comment similar to in-person
deliberations each meeting day included time certain agendas public comments no public
comment was received during the facilitator facilitator training during the reviewer training
or during the independent review period that led up to the deliberations
okay here we go so we have three slides of the iqc recommendations the recommendations of the iqc
um the commission is recommending 10 of the 11 programs submitted for this adoption
the iqc has recommended for board approval the three instructional programs submitted
by carnegie learning inc the commission recommends the three programs
novice level novice level and and
alta espanol para hispanohablantes novice and intermediate levels the publishers have responded
to the edits and corrections and the social content findings by in general accepting the
suggestions from the reviewers i will discuss publishers submitted a rather later in this
presentation here i have the next four instructional programs that were reviewed the commission
recommends the three programs submitted by clet usa inc alba y gael reporteros and mapas
all three in the novice level the publisher has responded to the edits and corrections
and the social content findings accepting the suggestions from the reviewers clet usa has also
submitted a short list of publisher errata the commission is not recommending one spanish program
the one submitted by rosetta stone ltd the reasons for this recommendation are included
in the iqc advisory report but in short the commission felt that the program did not meet
several of the criteria statements in categories one two three four and five and mind you there
are five categories for the world languages adoption during the deliberations process this
publisher did inform seaford staff that they would not contest the findings and opted to
withdraw from participating in the process further however since the reviewers had already
conducted the review and deliberations had begun we continued with the process of continuing with
with deliberations creating the report of findings and having the iqc make their recommendation
so now i'm going to talk about the four remaining programs all of which were recommended by the
for board approval the commission recommends the four programs submitted by vista higher learning
in the novice level and intermediate levels and in the novice level the publishers have responded
to the edits and corrections and the social content findings by in general accepting the
suggestions from the reviewers vista higher learning also submitted additional errata and
suggestions for addressing the social content concerns the reviewing panel raised now in general
the iqc advisory report does include detailed rationale for each decision to recommend or not
recommend and include citations in each of the five categories either for or against of the state
board adopted criteria the reports also include the recommended edits and corrections
and social content citations for each of those programs it is cd's recommendation that these
recommended edits be considered as a condition for adoption if the state board elects to adopt
these materials these recommended edits came from a combination of the reports of the panels
of reviewers that the board appointed to evaluate the materials comments from the public that
requested that edits be made to the materials and some errata that was submitted by the publishers
the commissioner is considered these sources of input when discussing and deciding which
edits to add to the recommendation so i do want to take a moment to talk about publisher submitted
errata publishers are not allowed to make any changes to the program after they have submitted
them for review there may be some situations where the publisher has identified edits and
corrections beyond what was found by the review panel this may include the correction of typos
or correction of factual errors the publisher may also submit responses and possible alternate
suggestions to propose edits and corrections identified by the review panel excuse me
me
lastly sorry the publisher may submit responses and possible suggestions for social content
violations identified by the reviewers altogether these are called publisher errata so after
september 2021 meeting the instructional quality commission accepted the errata of some publishers
that had been submitted today we would like to request that the board act
by accepting the errata submitted by the remaining publishers which include carnegie learning vista
higher learning and clet usa i would like to provide a quick summary of the errata these
publishers have submitted as their inclusion stands to strengthen the instructional programs
the reviewer panels recommended for adoption some publishers have submitted errata addressing
findings in the edits and corrections section of the reports and findings to correct typos
incorrect labels headings page numbers and similar errors importantly they have included
additional corrections to errors the review panels did not identify in the reports of findings
and it's totally understandable that the review panels might not have caught every single error
this happens during every review of instructional materials in their errata the publishers have
also provided responses to some of the reviewer findings while they accept the majority of the
findings in some instances they do point out that changing certain terms would simply swap
one acceptable term for another acceptable term here i would like to emphasize that the
world languages standards promote the acceptance of all varieties of a given language as a result
making the edit to a different term might actually limit students exposure to the richness of that
target language the publishers also point out that they cannot make changes on to certain content
as they do not have permission to alter primary source documents once again i would like to
mention that the world languages standards and the guidance in the world languages framework
both embrace the use of authentic materials lastly the publishers submitted errata to address some of
the social content citations identified in the reports of findings so now i'll like to i'd like
to remind everyone of the steps that occur after the state board takes action today so following
this meeting there will be a 60-day timeline for publishers to submit all edits and corrections to
be verified by the cde the final versions of instructional materials will not be available
until the state board adopted edits and corrections have been made i'd also like to remind the board
and those in attendance today that local control allows school districts to choose instructional
materials that will meet the diverse needs of their local educational agencies so lea is
seeking world languages materials to adopt need not restrict themselves to the state board
adopted list as they conduct their own review of instructional materials the state level review
again is designed to be a first level review to share with districts the materials that meet the
content of the standards the framework and the criteria districts then engage in their own local
review of instructional materials to analyze which programs may best fit their needs so with
all of that said on behalf of the commission i would like to thank the board for its support
throughout the adoption process for world languages we hope that the materials you adopt today
will provide support for districts and their expanding world languages programs aligned with
the world languages framework i'd like to conclude with the cde recommendation the cd
recommends that the state board act to adopt the 10 instructional materials programs recommended by
the iqc accept the publisher errata not considered by the iqc at its september 2021 meeting and direct
the cde staff in conjunction with members of the iqc and or content review experts as needed
to work with publishers to ensure that the edits and corrections and other publisher errata and
administrative updates adopted by the state board have been made to their revised instructional materials
that concludes my presentation i now turn things back over to board president darling hamond
for public comment and moderation of any questions that you might have about world languages
all right thank you so much we're going to go right to the public hearing
uh and i opened the public hearing at 3 29 pm first we'll hear from any publisher who would
like to comment on this item each publisher will have two minutes following comments from the
publishers we will then move to comment from other members of the public who will each have one minute
we'll now open the phone line for comment from publishers by calling the phone number and using
the access code provided on the slide that is shown now please provide your name and the publisher
you are representing for the record and please remember to turn down the speaker volume of your
computers if you are following the live feed you have two minutes thank you are there any
publishers in the queue president darling hamond we have no publishers in the queue but we have
one public comment all right please speak your name and affiliation for the record your one
minute starts now
all right there are those ideas representing the california association for bilingual education
kabe thanks the iqc and staff on their hard work in developing these instructional materials
and for the very content adopted process used kabe respectfully request the board to approve
adoption of the 2021 world languages through eight instructional materials these materials
are consistent with the criteria and standards established in the board's adopted curriculum
frameworks and in alignment to the content standards adopted by the board the recommended
instructional materials reflect innovative practices grounded in the use of the target
language that are often faced and guided by the goals contained in the world language standards
if you can't educators teaching world languages and our students will now have updated instructional
materials for which they have rated for thank you thank you caller this concludes public comment
very good um given that there's no other public comment i hereby close the public
hearing at 3 32 p.m and we'll now begin board discussion and i'd like to ask our liaison
member glover woods if she would like to make some initial comments yes i would very briefly
first would like to thank the seaford staff and other cde staff that organized a very thoughtful
and a very organized um review and deliberation process of the time and sacrifice that was given
by the content reviewers the expert reviewers as well as the iqc just really allowed for us to
have in front of us 10 very strong instructional material sets for students that are engaging in
the world languages so very appreciative of that and i do have to say having participated in this
process for reading language arts over 10 years ago nothing was missed by the transfer to virtual
every conversation that took place again was very thoughtful and very well thought out which would
be the same as thoughtful i'm sure so again thank you so very much to everyone who participated in
the process and look forward to any additional board comment you may have discovered a new way
to do these reviews a more economical fashion to do them i have with hands raised member rucker
member strouse and member escapado member rucker first of all i want to thank you even though this
is the second hearing and the second process on adoption that we covered and you essentially
covered the basic outline of the process i do want to thank you for taking the time to take us again
through this process world languages has garnered a lot of attention in the education community and
for me sitting at the iqc meeting along with my state board colleagues and being led through this
particular adoption it was very exciting to hear teachers talk about their own learning on world
languages students and how it translated into what they think about and look at with their own
students who are english learners and for the teachers who are language
instructors what it meant and how it changes what they look at language learning instruction
so it was very enjoyable to me to sit and listen to the conversation and to watch this process
unfold and i'm so happy to see this come to fruition now and we're ready to move this process
so thank you and thank the seaford staff for all the work that they did to carry this forward and
move this process awesome um vice president strouse so um mike i just want to thank you
for a really thorough presentation to go through all the steps it's very complex i think the seaford
team as everyone has said did an amazing job but to think about all the things that you plan for
i've been in the materials adoptions when you went from room to room and to see that you could
go from breakout room to breakout room that you could do a survey and get people's initial
reactions and give everyone an opportunity to follow the process carefully i just want to
thank you and the team that led this work and for all the reviewers who volunteer so much time to
review it i think it will make a tremendous difference for students in california as we
go forward and we know that districts then will have to go through their own process to
now evaluate materials and so i just want to thank you mike for that thorough presentation
and for the process thank you very much uh and member escapado i appreciate the presentation and
just want to share that is more than transmitting language is transmitting culture and i've seen
firsthand when students of variety of races learn a language there's a stickiness factor where
they interconnect and it really breaks so many racial barriers uh so i just applaud your effort
it's it has made a significant effect in the lives of so many children and and created
has created more racial harmony which is more we need more of that right i just want to add one
one one thing is that i know we focus more on spanish and french when you look at the
dual immersion programs in our state yes spanish ranks one but second is mandarin i think french
is third or fourth so hopefully in the future there might be some great publishers that
uh may have mandarin as as a framework for instruction so hopefully i will be able to
look at that material as well thank you i just want to sort of add on to these comments and say
first of all um you know we know so much now about the neuroscience of brain development
and today we've been talking about music art and world language adoptions which at your moments in
time have been considered sort of frills in the curriculum but they are fundamental to the
development of the brain in fact symbol systems music and art world languages all develop neuron
connections and the neurons that you know fire together wire together as they say and make us
you know generally more flexible in our thinking more intelligent as well as more connected to
other human beings as you said member escapado and more connected culturally so it's a very
important set of adoptions i hope that these are going to be central to students learning
experiences in school now just one little fact on that point they found that when people have
more than one language that even when there is in autopsies evidence of things like alzheimer's
those who have multiple languages actually show the signs of that kind of degenerative
disease five years later than people who are monolingual because they've got that many more
connections wired with which to do their mental activity and so as a former musician myself and
someone who has many languages in the family i'm thrilled that we're you know really putting this
kind of work in these kind of materials you know available to our schools the other thing i just
like to note is that many of us have talked about how you know we shouldn't lose the innovations
that have occurred during the pandemic i think this might be one of the innovations that occurred
during the pandemic and that we ought to be mindful of taking advantage of what you've been
able to accomplish here in a very complicated public process that may serve us in good stead
as we go forward if there's no more board discussion i see no other hands raised
i think we can ask for a motion oh member mcclellan did your hand go up yeah i'm sorry to drag
this out that's okay but you know i i appreciate the presentation also in what was stated about
local efforts to accommodate languages offered in each area i mean we're such a diverse state
in our neck of the woods up here in our high schools we offer the urock language
it's articulated to meet the world language criteria in four of our major high schools
along with the talawa language so that local emphasis is so important and what was said
earlier about communicating culture and helping us to bridge the divides of better understanding
with our families and our communities is so important so it's such an important area so i
appreciate the presentation and all the work thank you thank you for that very important comment
if there are no other comments i'll invite a motion
i'd like to make the motion i move that we accept cde's recommendation which is inclusive of
adopting the 10 instructional materials and the publisher errata that was not considered by the
iqc at the september meeting as well as the process outlined on the slide to address any
edits corrections publisher errata or updates excellent do i have a second
okay uh with that uh we'll uh take a roll call vote member son
aye vice president strouse yes member rucker aye member rodriguez yes member or c
member bronson yes member mcquillin ee in new york language yes ee
okay member glover woods yes member escobedo yes president darlin hammond we we
member burr aye member mananka aye the motion passes unanimously
okay terrific all right you've earned another 10 minute break so uh it is
341 and we'll reconnoiter at about well it's actually 342 we'll come back at 352 we'll see you then
welcome back we're in the homestretch uh brooks will you please call the role to
establish the quorum of course member son
here vice president strouse here member rucker here member rodriguez
here member patilla bronson here member mcquillin here member glover woods
here member escobedo here president darlin hammond here member burr here member manaka
here everyone's present we have a quorum all right uh we are going to move on to our waiver
consent calendar waiver items one through eleven uh we'll open up the phone line for the public
comment queue uh members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item should do so by
calling the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now
are there any public comments on any waiver items one through eleven
i am so sorry uh there are no public comments okay um
um
after the public comment i guess i'll ask for a motion on waivers one through eleven
i'll move approval of those waivers i will second thank you very much we'll now hold the
roll call vote brooks please call the roll member son
me
aye vice president strouse aye member rocker aye member rodriguez yes member patilla bronson
yes member mcquillin yes member glover woods yes member escobedo yes president darlin hammond
Yes.
Number Burr.
Aye.
Number Bonacca.
As it knows.
Okay, so now we'll take up the regular consent items, 10 through 15.
Because we have two recusals, we will need to take the consent items up in two votes.
First item 10, Member Sun and Member Strauss, I understand you must recuse yourselves from
this item.
And they seem to be gone.
Please turn off your cameras as they did.
And after Brooks calls the roll, they can come back in.
We'll now open the phone line for the queue for public comment on consent items 11 through
15.
Members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling the telephone
number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
We encourage you, if you are calling, to state your name and affiliation for the record.
If the item you're commenting on, remember to turn down the speaker volume on your computers
if you're following the live feed and speak for one minute each.
Are there any public comments?
There are no public comments at this time.
Okay.
Given that there's no further public comment, I'll ask for a motion on consent items 11
to 15.
I would move approval of the consent.
Thank you.
May I have a second?
Excuse me, member Darling-Hammond.
This was my mistake.
We're just taking a vote on consent item 10 right now because that was my mistake in the
script.
I'm sorry.
Yeah.
Okay.
So first we're going to ask for a motion on item 10.
I will amend my motion to move a motion on item 10.
Okay.
That was a friendly amendment.
And from you to you.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Thank you so much.
Now we'll go ahead and take a roll call vote.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Escobedo.
President Darling-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Member Bonacca.
Thank you.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Member Bonacca.
Motion passes.
All right.
And we can welcome back Vice President Strauss and Member Son.
There we go.
You didn't miss much.
Now we're going to go on to public comments for consent items 11 to 15.
And we'll encourage anyone who's calling in for public comment.
Let's put that slide back up to state your name and affiliation for the record.
Use that phone number and access code on the slide.
Please state which item you're commenting on.
Remember to turn down the speaker volume on your computers.
If you are following the live feed and speak for one minute each, are there public comments
on items 11 to 15?
Yes, we do have one in public comment in the queue.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
Good afternoon.
My name is Michael Jubba and I'm a classroom teacher representing the California Teachers
Association commenting on item 13.
The CTA would like to express our continued concerns with the funding determination process
for non-classroom-based charters.
The process is broken and does not provide the level of transparency that's needed for
the commissioners of the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools nor the members of the
State Board of Education to provide appropriate public oversight on these funding determinations.
Moratorium on new NCBs has been extended until 2025 and this is a time for the California
Department of Ed and the State Board of Ed to begin to renew and update the regulations
that govern this process.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you, Caller.
This concludes public comment.
Thank you very much.
Given that there's no further public comment, I will ask if there is a motion on consent
items 11 to 15.
Do I have a motion?
I move approval of the consent items.
Second it.
Thank you.
We'll now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, call the roll.
Member Sun.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Escobedo.
President Darlin-Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Member Bonanca.
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Motion passes unanimously.
All right.
Agenda item 11.
is our state board priorities item and we're reopening item one to take action on the preliminary
report of actions, the draft September 2021 meeting minutes, the SBE screening committee
recommendations for appointments to the ACCS, CPEG, and IQC, and to report on our liaison
assignments.
The first of those is the SBE draft preliminary report of actions and minutes for the September
9th, 2021 meeting.
While we're waiting for any members of the public to call in, I do have a motion from
a board member or may I have a motion from a board member to approve the September 9th,
2021 state board of education draft preliminary report of action meeting minutes.
That was a long-winded way of asking for a motion.
I move that we accept the minutes.
Thank you very much.
Can I have a second?
I will second that.
Thank you very much.
Are there any public comments?
There is one in public comment.
Caller, please state your name and affiliation for the record.
Your time starts now.
My name is David Page and I'm calling on behalf of parents and teachers and community members
of Lincoln High School community in San Diego Unified School District.
On the 325 of 21, we filed a complaint directly.
Excuse me.
We'll need you to call back during the final public comment period.
You can you may only speak to the item at hand at this time.
Thank you.
All right.
Any further public comment?
No, no more.
No more public comment.
Okay, well now hold a roll call vote.
Brooks, can you please call the roll?
Member Sun.
Aye.
Vice President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Oops.
Yes.
Member Petillo-Brownson.
Member McQuillan.
Yes.
Member Glover-Woods.
Member Escobedo.
Yes.
President Darling-Hammond.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Motion passes unanimously.
Terrific.
We'll go on to the State Board Screening Committee recommendations for appointments to the ACCS,
the CPEG and the IQC.
We got a lot of acronyms here.
If we could get the public's comment slide up again, we will open the phone line for
public comment.
And members of the public wishing to provide comment on this item may do so by calling
the telephone number and using the access code provided on the slide that is shown now.
And while we're waiting for any members of the public to call in, I'll ask Vice President
Strauss, who has chaired this year's process, to share the recommendations from the State
Board Screening Committee regarding appointments to the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools,
the California Practitioners Advisory Group, and the Instructional Quality Commission.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
So first I have to completely thank our screening committee members, Ting Sung and Cynthia Glover-Woods.
We all together, we reviewed almost 100 applications for the different screenings that we did.
We do have two more screenings that are getting posted, one for the Advisory Commission on
Special Ed and one for the two positions on Instructional Quality Commission.
But we reviewed the applications.
We had a separate meeting to decide who we were going to interview and then separate
interviews for each of the commissions.
Let me just say, since we've gone remote, the interviews are done by Zoom now, not by
telephone.
And it is really actually, this is an improvement in the process, because we can see people,
we can talk and introduce ourselves, it felt really personal and connected.
So with that, I'm going to give you a summary of our recommendations.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, this is an addendum that's been posted.
We are recommending a reappointment to a two-year term and as chair of ACCS, as specified
in the addendum, Mike Walsh, currently a member of the Butte County Board of Education.
He's the co-founder and CEO of Beacon Results.
He represents governing boards of school districts.
We're recommending reappointment of a one-year term, as specified in the addendum, for Gail
Garbellino Mojica, Placer County Superintendent of Schools, for Placer County Office of Education,
representing the county superintendents.
Also Jared Austin for a one-year term.
He's the executive director and co-founder of Karos Public Schools.
He represents parents and guardians of charter school students.
And appointed for a two-year term, as specified in the addendum, Derek King, superintendent
of Excelsior Charter Schools, representing charter schools.
So that's for ACCS.
For the California Practitioners Advisory Group, we're recommending reappointment for
a one-year term.
We have four reappointments, as specified in the addendum, Bootsy Battleholt, teacher
in Los Angeles Unified School District, representing teachers from a traditional public school,
Diane Grotejohn, an accountability administrator for Lifelong Learning Administration, representing
charter school leaders, Tarina Small, a teacher at Sciatec, representing teachers from a charter
school, and Janelle Woodward, who's assistant superintendent of teaching and learning division
of Pleasant Unified School District, Pleasanton, representing principals and other school leaders.
So those four are reappointed for a one-year term.
Appointed for a three-year term, as specified in the addendum, Babatunde Elore, executive
director of accountability and communications from Modera Unified School District, representing
parents of students currently enrolled in K-12 schools.
Gabriela Tavitian, the assistant superintendent of educational support services from East
Whittier City School District, she's representing superintendents or other administrators.
And Amy Wynn Hernandez, superintendent of Central School District, representing superintendents
or other administrators.
Todd Collins, who's self-employed, he's a member of the Palo Alto Unified School District
governing board, and he's representing members of local school boards.
Those three, those four were for a three-year term.
Now, these two are represented for a two-year term.
We tried to balance the terms, so we rotate some off each year, as specified in the addendum.
Sonia Rody Boonchoy, he's the associate superintendent of instructional services for Davis Joint
Unified School District.
He represents superintendents and other administrators.
And Sheila Neen Cruz-Gonzalez, she's currently the deputy director of Californians Together
and a member of the Azusa Unified School District governing board.
She's representing members of local school boards.
So we had a lot of appointments to CPAC.
For the Instructional Quality Commission, we appointed for a four-year term, as specified
in the addendum, Marcy Winnower, an instructional support teacher.
She has specialist in math and science, computer science, Los Altos High School District,
representing teachers, and our student member for a one-year term, as specified in the
addendum, Mira Chacredale.
She's from Northgate High School, Mount Diablo Unified School District, representing students.
So those are the recommendations by the screening committee for appointments to the
commissions.
That was a mouthful.
It was a lot of work.
A lot of work.
I want to thank the members of those committees and ask if Member Glover-Woods or Member
Son may also want to add any comments since they participated in all of that.
Well, I think that Vice Chair Stroud is amazing, getting us through all of those interviews.
She's got the process down and she got us through all of the screening of the paperwork
and the interviews.
So thank you very much, Vice Chair Stroud.
And also just looking at the applicants, I think that it's wonderful to see that educators
from throughout California and their interest in serving on these committees.
And so it was a fabulous experience.
It's my second year in a row and enjoyed both times thoroughly.
Thank you.
Member Glover-Woods.
Just to thank you to everyone who applied for all of the different commissions.
Just really appreciate the time that was put forward in completing applications and for
those who participated in the interviews.
Again, just very great educators and community members that have an interest to serve at
this level.
Terrific.
Are there any clarifying questions before we go to public comment?
Seeing none, we'll see if there's any public comment.
There are no public commenters.
All right.
So we can see if there's any other board discussion.
And if not, I'll invite a motion.
So I move approval of the screening committee appointments and reappointments to the ACCS,
CPAC and IQC.
Thank you very much.
And do I have a second?
I'll second.
Thank you very much.
Any further board discussion?
I'm instructed to ask you to raise your hand in the participant panel of Zoom.
So this is a different way of doing this.
I'm not sure why we're varying our process, but I'm trying to find out how to raise my
hand too.
If you are.
Okay, we're all here.
And, Brooks, it says you still have to call the roll.
Yeah, that's right.
All right.
So everybody's learning how to use Zoom.
So that's good.
There's a lesson every day.
Member Sun.
Aye.
President Strauss.
Member Rucker.
Yes.
Member Rodriguez.
Aye.
Member Paquilla Brownson.
Yes.
Member McQuillan.
Member Glover-Woods.
Yes.
Member Escobedo.
President Darlene Hammond.
Yes.
Member Burr.
Aye.
Member Bonacca.
Motion passes unanimously.
All right.
Now you can all lower your hands.
This is a performance task so we can all get ourselves back to where we were.
All right.
Thank you so much, Vice President Strauss, for all your work and that of the committee
and getting us all these wonderful members of these committees.
We appreciate them as well.
They have a lot of work ahead of them.
Some of them have already been involved and they know that and others will find it out.
And they give us a lot of great and important advice.
So we appreciate the process.
I'm now going to go to our board member liaison reports.
Any liaison activities that were not related to any items on our November agenda?
And we'll go again in reverse alphabetical order.
Member Sun.
Okay.
Thank you.
So most of the work for the state board this month has been on the screening committee
as we just went over.
Also, you saw the assessment item and the federal ESSA item were also items
that were covered in today's agenda.
Just wanted to report that California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee
met last month on the no, September 29.
We are continuing our work on the state plan for CTE, the Career Technical Education,
and CTE has engaged jobs for the future.
An organization that will help us through that work.
Oh, and our next meeting is on the 19th of December.
That's it.
All right.
Vice President Strauss.
So I do have a few things to share in addition to screening.
So when the IQC met in September 22nd, 23rd, we had our new IQC student commissioner,
Juliana Garcia.
She's a senior at John F. Kennedy Middle College High School in Corona Norco Unified School
District.
And she's talked, we had her introduce herself and she talked about seeking changes in
instruction and curriculum for her peers, advocating for curriculum that deals with,
that addresses non-diverse issues and wants to have changes.
And she's been involved in nationwide youth organization to communicate.
And to advocate.
So I think we're very, very fortunate.
As she said, she wants to diversify our narrative.
So she will be an important student voice on our IQC as well.
There was a wonderful presentation at that meeting on specialized media and technology
for Braille, audiobooks.
I don't think all of us realize the whole department at CTE that deals with that.
So if you're interested, you can go back to the IQC recording of the meeting.
But I just wanted to highlight that.
And then as I said, the IQC, we're going to be screening in December for two more IQC
members and one member of the advisory commission on special ed.
So please look for that if that's relevant of your interest.
Both member Rucker and I attended the NASB, the National Association of State School
Boards of Education.
And a couple highlights.
They really want to, they recognize obviously this is a really pivotal time in public
education and that state boards can address policy during this time and looking at the
state board role in leveraging policy.
So just so you know, if you're interested, it's free.
You can go on the website for the NASB 2021 conference.
And some plenary sessions were recorded that talked about leading in the time of
uncertainty, digital access for students with disabilities, policy levers for teacher
education programs, renewing the promise of equity and excellence, supporting school
leaders through the pandemic recovery and beyond.
And that's important.
I know they are exhausted as well as teachers as well.
And then the final one, finding joy in public service.
So I thought, you know, you might want to just kind of look at a recording on that.
I also represent California for the Western region and the delegate assembly.
And then the special ed advisory commission did meet on the 27th of October.
And that's also taped if you're interested.
But the IEP program template and alternative pathways to diploma.
There was an update on that.
It's funded in a 2021 California state budget act to take a look at that.
Really important.
It's being handled by Sacramento County office and West Ed.
Very interesting presentation.
And then special ed funding system study update.
That's a process that's also going on that I think.
I wanted to share a couple key findings.
Those of us who look at funding issues with special ed.
No, here are some key findings that won't surprise you.
But the cost of achievement increases as students have multiple needs.
That English learners represent a larger proportion of students with disabilities
later in K-12 education.
That our statewide cost high cost pools to support LEAs with high cost special
education programs are among the lowest funded pools in the nation.
And that the nonpublic school placement patterns that the current funding formula
actually incentivize placement in nonpublic schools.
Which I thought was really interesting.
And that white students were more likely to be placed in nonpublic school settings.
And that students with emotional disturbance, autism, specific learning disability,
other health impairment are the ones more likely.
So I thought that would be interesting to share.
They did talk a lot about promoting inclusive practices.
Appropriate early intervention and identification.
And making sure that the funds get to the students who have the greatest need.
Also there was a discussion about the family empowerment center expansion.
Was part of a budget program as well.
Enhancement program.
And there was like $5 million to increase the family empowerment center.
So that was important.
And that's a budget enhancement.
I just wanted to talk quickly about the CSU has a committee called closing.
The center to close the opportunity gap.
And their work, which was also funded by a budget trailer item.
Also links very much with the work we're doing.
And I think Francisco actually knows some about it.
Because there's a partnership with Chula Vista Elementary is one of their partners.
They talked about.
But they're talking about looking at professional preparation of educators.
Talking a lot about schools that serve high concentrations of black Latinx.
And socioeconomically disadvantaged students.
Looking at models that blends practitioners and interest holders from across the state.
And they've done a lot of review.
They're starting a website.
They're curating some materials.
They've had an education summit.
And they're going to be disseminating materials.
I think it might be really relevant.
I know certainly with Superintendent Thurman's task force as well.
The equity issues.
They're looking at resources.
And then how do we build capacity?
Which all of us are talking about.
For both pre-service teachers and teachers in the field.
And so I just think this opportunity for regional hubs.
They have one at San Diego State and at Cal State Fullerton.
Will be really helpful in sharing practices to close the opportunity gap.
So I just wanted to share that as well.
So that ends my report.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Member Rucker.
So I'll begin my report by saying I got a text message from Board Member Ting Tsang
asking me to make a correction.
So November 19th is an important day in history.
That was the day the Beatles released their album.
The Magical Mystery Tour was also the day Abraham Lincoln delivered his Gettysburg address.
It's my birthday, but that's also the day the California Workforce Pathways Joint
Advisory Committee will be meeting.
Not on December 19th, but on November 19th.
So I wanted to make sure I did that.
Board Member Strauss talked a lot about the work that's going on with the ITC.
So I don't need to comment on that.
But I do want to draw attention to something that I think is a pretty big deal for the
Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee.
We have been spending quite some time as a group having meetings to take a look at data
and doing a really in-depth data study.
As a matter of fact, a joint study session with our community partner groups to look
at the development of the new California State Plan for Career Technical Education.
So I really do want to take a moment just to congratulate the work that's being developed
by department staff in preparation for this meeting.
They have pulled together a lot of data, not only from our state's data system for accountability,
but they have framed and recalibrated some of the data points that we have required as
part of the work for the applications for the two funding streams that we are primarily
responsible for overseeing and monitoring.
At this next upcoming meeting, we're actually going to see a data report that's looking
at state accountability assessment data at the claims level.
What I'm really looking forward to in that conversation is it's the data that's reported
at the claims level that's most directly related to what we hold these programs accountable
for in the performance of students who come through their programs.
So we'll have an opportunity to really look at what is the instructional impact of these
programs on moving students toward proficiency on those standards.
So it promises to be a very promising meeting, not only the joint study session with our
community partners, but the work that's going to take a look at how to frame that discussion
on accountability.
So I think that's going to be a very exciting meeting.
And that ends my report.
Thank you, Ting, for giving me the chance to say that.
Happy birthday in advance.
Member Rodriguez.
Yes, thank you.
So the California Summer School for the Arts, we had a board meeting on October 21st.
And I want to share a few of the highlights.
The new executive, well, he's not that new anymore.
Matthew Gallagher has come in with a lot of enthusiasm and has demonstrated his enthusiasm
with a lot of work.
He completed a six-year dashboard so that there's data to show our student demographics,
who's participating, the race ethnicity demographics, financial aid, student enrollment.
And so he has put together a report, which I am happy to share in an email with Brooks.
And so he can pass on to all of you.
And also prompted from some of those conversations is the strengthening development of a DEI
committee, which was established in spring of 2021.
I alluded to it a little bit in my last update, but the committee has been very active.
They're really looking at not only geographic, socioeconomic, racial and ethnic
representation from throughout the state.
Because as you'll see in the dashboard, a lot of the representation, it's really heavy
in the Los Angeles area.
And one of the things that I mentioned to Matthew when I went through the board,
what do you call that?
The like when you're introduced, I'm completely blank.
Yes, when I was talking to him and I said, you know, I was the visual and performing
arts coordinator at my former school and I had never heard of the California Summer
School for the Arts.
And we have a lot of very talented students down here.
And so anyway, he and I will be meeting next week to talk about ideas on how to reach
more rural, more, you know, areas that are a little further removed from the cities
and to be able to recruit students from communities like ours as well.
They're also looking for a location.
The CalArts responded to the request for proposal, but they're looking at the whole
money situation and that's in the works right now.
So and I believe that the summer school has met at CalArts all of the time in the past.
And so I think it's a bit of an economic and visiting various other sites.
So that is my and there's also a student survey, sorry, that was conducted by Professor Emeritus
of UC Santa Cruz, David Harrington, and he surveyed students over the past several years.
And 97% of the students believe that the summer school helped them a lot with their educational
and career goals.
We all know how important the arts are for development, for humanity, right?
You know, building those neural pathways and also careers.
We're in California where there are a lot of opportunities for whether it's visual and
performing arts or animation, and a lot of these students actually go into careers like that.
You know, and there's one of the responses to the young lady who spoke this morning
who was talking about the preparation once students graduate, right?
We can, there are definitely a lot of opportunities here with
the summer school for the arts for our students.
And I will move on, I'm trying to rush through this, to the CTC meeting.
We only met for one day and moved the October meeting into September.
So an announcement, teacher residency capacity grant request for applications is now open.
The governor signed the budget in July 2021 and it includes $350 million in funding
for competitive grants to support a collaborative partnership between
an eligible ally or a consortium with one or more commission approved
teacher preparation programs offered by a regionally accredited institution.
For more information, visit the CTC's website.
The RFA is due to the commission by 5 p.m. on February 14th.
And there are some wonderful residency models
that, you know, happening at the state where teachers are really benefiting from the experiences.
And also there's a, the local solutions to the shortage of special education teachers,
local solutions as it's called grants, were included in the 2018-19 state budget.
And the commission reviewed the report as of now how things are going.
There were some narrative comments in the annual reports.
Some of the participants were a little disappointed about not being able to complete
what they set out to do because of the distance learning,
right, you know, so that that interrupted their plans a little bit, but they will continue.
In the narrative comments included in the annual report and emails received,
the grantees expressed overwhelming enthusiasm and gratitude for the local solutions grant program
and the opportunities that the funds have provided them.
Many programs have identified promising practices such as signing bonuses,
tuition reimbursement payment, and strong mentoring programs
that are already improving special education in the grantee alley A.
So I wanted to highlight that.
And also the commission has been working, so this is a member Patil Bronson,
towards transformative work in early childhood education.
Over the past several years, to set the foundation and the context for the work proposed,
there are an array of credentials and assignments that could be adjusted and repurposed
to meet the changing workforce needs.
And so this was only an information item, but, you know, there was a lot of talk about the
possibilities on how to either laterally move or best prepare teachers or use already existing
credentials to support the opportunities for preparation of the EC workforce.
And that is that is all.
Those are the highlights.
Thank you.
Member Patil Bronson.
I'm going to pick up on the last committee report around CTC and talk a little bit about
a emerging or actually now well underway effort which CDE has undertaken.
And really also just start by commending the leadership of Sarah Neville-Morgan,
who has been convening a series of working groups between CDE, CTC, and a
variety of other stakeholders across educational partners, excuse me, across
state agencies, community organizations, and different representatives from both
LEAs as well as community-based organizations in the early learning space.
All of this is focused on what is the implementation effort necessary in order to
properly launch the UPK universal preschool and universal transitional kindergarten
investments that were approved, which were exciting and are going to be birthed and need
the full implementation resources to be successful as they're brought in into
This means in part thinking about local implementation practices, leverage
research that we know of best practices from other states, and what actually drives fair
and just child outcomes across socioeconomic and also that provides for integrated learning
environments. And then to the last point that board member Rodriguez was just describing around
workforce, thinking about how do we leverage the incredible asset that we have in that the early
learning teacher community has tended to be more socioeconomically and racially diverse,
and how do we help folks come into the TK space who have BAs who are in line or alluded to
the multiple subject credential already have the 24 units of ECE specific education.
Similarly, how do we actually make sure that state preschool programs are also well launched
and have the workforce that they need in order to continue that pipeline of education so that
in the best forecast of what we would want as kids enter the TK to 12 system in California,
they'll have had the benefit for low income kids of a widely expanded state preschool program,
as well as a universal transitional kindergarten program for fours.
There's also been a lot of discussion about sort of what are the communication
vehicles that are necessary in order to share broadly. And I think this is really just an
exciting space for being able to bring to bear the best learnings that we've seen from so many
other states that have gone down this also figure out what is the California way in the space
to make it successful. Lastly, I'll just mention that later this month we'll also be
the early childhood policy council meeting in two weeks, and that will be
likely focused a little bit more on zero to three and thinking about how do we ensure that learning
knowing that learning begins at birth, how do we leverage the possibilities
to actually ensure that that pipeline of learning continues
in the full zero to five space and then is continued in the P to three aligned space.
And that concludes my report. Terrific. Thank you. Member McQuillin.
Not as much as others to report on. I'll be thankful at this hour of the day, but
as we heard this morning, the students that reported out on the from the
Sabe, the student advisory board on education, I had the pleasure of working with them and preparing
them for those presentations. It was fantastic. It was just a pleasure to work directly with the
students. And my goal is to see some representation from above San Francisco from districts up here
at that student conference and maybe applying next year to be our student representative. But
there were definitely some Bay Area reps that made the application process. That was a real pleasure.
We also heard this morning in the superintendent's report that
Assemblyman Ramos has been very busy and he's sponsoring some new legislation on American
Indian education in California. It's really exciting. It's early in the process and he
took a lot of input on that. And also the governor signed a task force that's rather unique
that is going to look at protecting items worn at graduation by American Indians and making
recommendations of what those items are if a student wanted to wear a feather or something
representing their tribal tribe in California that they can do so during graduation. There's a task
force that'll be set up to do that. Looking forward to having some input on that. And then
I'm also looking forward to the big day on November 19th
for the joint task force on CTE coming back together. And a birthday I guess too.
So thank you, that's all. Thank you so much and thanks for all the support you gave the students.
That was wonderful and I'm sure all that coaching really made them more confident and ready to do
this presentation. So that was terrific. Member Glover Woods.
I don't have anything additional to report. Both items I would have shared were on today's agenda,
world languages and the work of the screening committee. So nothing else to report at this time.
Well job well done because we got both of those over the finish line. So thank you. Member Escobedo.
Yes, I've been part of the WestEd group for the last year or so. It's been an impressive group.
They've facilitated an intersegmental working group that developed a comprehensive technical
and legal framework for the new cradle to career public data system to provide information on
students as they progress from early education to college and into California's labor market.
Now this system will allow for linking data on academic success, persistence, school quality
and socioeconomic indicators and will enable state regions and state educational systems
to better understand how educational programs contribute to student learning and
workforce preparedness. This new cradle to career data system was funded by the California
legislature. I believe it was in the summer of 2021 the system is being built. It's underway
and really looking forward to seeing it in place. We had our first in-person board meeting for over
almost two years. It was great to see everyone. Actually I'm looking forward to seeing everyone
this board as well. We had our meeting about a week ago in Phoenix and we were hosted by the Helios
Education Foundation which is one of the largest educational foundations in Arizona.
They support some of WestEd's work. For example, Helios recently published a brief on college access
and attainment strategies and programs for men of color. One of the features that really struck me
was the decision theater in this building and this I felt like I was like in an Epcot venue.
I mean I was surrounded by screens and it was probably the most interactive data visualization
experience I've ever seen. So we had two superintendents that was able to highlight
their districts in one screen and then another screen we're able to see the amount of violence
students are exposed to, lead content, air quality. Another screen you got to see some of the
socioeconomic indicators and another screen you might have been able to see the work and industrial
profile of that area. The beauty of this experience was that the superintendents
were able to manipulate some of the data by saying what would happen if I increased my
graduation rate by 10% and how would that affect crime and how that would affect
taxes. For example, the amount of taxes a city is able to gain. It was remarkable. I've never seen
how data could create a story so visually. A great experience, a lot to learn
and I think it's very powerful not only for districts but also for mayors and decision
makers to really see that education is an investment. It is not an expense. It isn't
an investment because it affects every facet of our society. So that was a great experience,
the decision theater and that is my report and I will report again tomorrow
with the community school agenda item which will be number one.
You know, that sounds like something that would be such a huge benefit for civic engagement and
policymaking generally. So thank you for describing that. I'm going to find out more. Member Burr.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond. I was also thinking as Member Escobedo was reporting
that it could be perfect for the next LCAP iteration. There you go.
Per board member Sun's recommendations this morning that we do something that is engaging
and is meaningful to the participants so we would love to learn more about that.
My report on accountability took place this morning about the LCAP template.
I'm just going to talk briefly about the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence
board met last week. We also met in person. It's quite the opportunity. People are elated to see
each other in person. We were able to meet at the Sacramento City Unified School District and we
thank Superintendent Aguilar for that opportunity. So just a few highlights. As you all know,
a former colleague, many of our former colleagues, Matt Nava was appointed as Executive Director of
the Collaborative and he not surprisingly hit the ground running. As he told us in the interview,
he was going to do a 90-day plan. He's been actively engaged in engagement and strategic
planning effort. I think he's interviewed more than 140 of our educational partners
to identify the sort of classic strengths, weaknesses, opportunities, and threats to the
CCE. It's sort of a perfect time to reflect back. We've been in existence six or seven years.
And as he said, we're now in our teenage phase. I hope not the unruly teenagers, but we are
certainly in a place where we have a pretty good idea about what we should be doing. We've been
given lots of tasks by the legislature and the governor, but we need to step back and say,
are we really being responsive to the folks who were supposed to be assisting? So from that work,
he's going to be developing a mission, vision, and values statement. We have the mission statement
already, but doing some refinement there. There's a two-page presentation that's on our website if
you're interested in looking in more detail. We also had a very robust presentation by the
professional learning team at CCE. They're also doing, they're part of the strategic engagement
and strategic planning, and they're developing their objectives going forward, especially around
professional learning that's based on evidence and best practice, that is a rapid response to
support teaching and learning, and to be sure that they increase accessibility too, and the use of
all of the resources. We had a really nice presentation from the Los Angeles County Office
of Education on how they have actually been using one of the sort of centerpieces of work that was
created in response to the pandemic, the Field Guide for Accelerating Learning. So it was great
to hear how the folks on the ground are actually using this just vast wealth of materials that
CCE created in response to needs of the pandemic. Going forward with respect to the professional
learning unit, they're really going to be focusing on universal design for learning
and making sure that all of our LEAs have access to those approaches and are able to implement the
universal design for learning. We had a big presentation on the budget and the trailer bill,
lots of responsibilities for CCE, but the one I'll highlight is the $50 million grant program
that is provided for professional learning to support, again, learning acceleration in the
main areas of math, literacy, and language development, and the CCE staff are busy
working on the RFP for that. Those grants go out to LEAs, so I'll keep you updated on that.
And then finally, we just spend some time acknowledging our former executive director,
Tom Armolino, and again, want to congratulate Tom on his retirement. Our next meeting will be
December 2nd, and that will be a virtual meeting. That completes my report.
Perfect. And member Banaka.
Thank you. Recently, I've been attending and speaking at quite a few student advocacy
conferences. So in late September, I was a speaker at the San Benito CAS conference with
their superintendent's student advisory council, where I talked about ways that students can engage
in statewide advocacy and heard some of their ideas for changes in education. I was also a
panelist at the Stockton student advisory conference and the CASC region 10 conference,
where I heard student proposals on issues relating to education and gave feedback.
I really enjoyed being at these conferences and hearing so many different student perspectives
on issues ranging from mental health to equity to curriculum, because it really helps inform my
perspective and helps me understand what students in the state are feeling and what they're thinking
about our education system. And then last but definitely not least, over this past weekend,
I attended the student advisory board on education and helped facilitate the selection process for
the upcoming student board member. And I know we already went over this, but I just wanted
to reiterate how talented and accomplished every single one of these semifinalists
are. And I think that we're really lucky to have these students be in the running
for our next student board member. And that'll be all for my liaison report.
Terrific. Thank you. And I'll just add a couple of things. I mean, a lot of ground has been covered,
but part of what's going on now, of course, is that we had this amazing budget last year with
so much investment in education. And we've heard about TK and about investments in the teaching
force and special education and the community schools we'll hear about tomorrow. So there's been
a lot going on to sort of figure out how to implement all of this work in a way that will
actually be effective, that will get to the people who need it in ways that they can use it.
And I think that's going to continue to be a part of our challenge over the next several years. Much
of this funding is expected to play out over the next five years. And so there's a lot to figure
out in terms of how people can take it up, integrate it. I think the board has been very
mindful about all the ways in which we can be sensitive to the overwhelming experience that it
is to be in a school district right now as a leader, as a teacher, and so on. And then, well,
these changes are important, adding another grade, adding TK. And with the infrastructure bill that's
about to pass in Washington, there'll be significant resources for three- and four-year-old
universal pre-Ks. So if we just want to think even a little bit more aspirationally,
redesigning schools to be community schools so that they can integrate these services. So
I'll just say that that's going to be an ongoing thread of work for us. I would just add a couple
of points to what's already been mentioned. On the investments in the teaching force,
I day talked about the funding for teacher residency programs, which a number of districts
have found has really helped them in the pandemic to have programs of teacher education that are
bringing people in, training them for a year, bringing them ready to start at the district
as well prepared as a teacher with a couple of years of experience because they've been
rooted in a very integrated approach to their training from excellent mentor teachers. That's
supplemented also by Golden State Scholarships, which have a significant amount of money will
support people coming into teaching for up to $20,000 in scholarship support if they teach in
the fields and places where they're most needed. And all of these things are kind of getting off
the ground. We want people to be able to know about them, use them, address the shortages that
they may be experiencing of teachers in that process. And so that's going to be another big
part of the process coming up. The ETS negotiations we already heard about. Community schools we'll
hear about tomorrow. So I'll save comments for that. I'll just add on the special education
front that in the budget was in addition to some funding for the special education functions
themselves, expectations for redesign of funding and governance that are part of the anticipated
activity this coming year for additional investment in special education. Work has been going on in
the alternative diploma. Many of our students with special education programs, particularly those
who are taking the alternative assessments have not had a pathway to a diploma that holds up
their ability to access jobs and go forward in their life in many cases. So that's another thing
that's being worked on and thought about and talked about to get to the place where many other
states are where we do have an alternative diploma that allows students to meet the standards of
ways that are appropriate for their learning differences. And finally, I would just note that
in the work on pre-K and thank you very much, Member Patia Bronson for helping us get so excited
about what's coming down the pike there. There is a lot of work going on. I'm part of the kitchen
cabinet that Sarah Neville Morgan has convened. She's got the most amazing set of interactive
collaborative partnerships to bring many people around the state, researchers from various places
and folks who are working on the ground together to get this right and subsidies for training the
workforce, credentialing and collaboration with the future credentialing commission
and rethinking or extending, elaborating the pre-K foundations into a framework that goes from
early childhood all the way through the primary grades are part of that activity. So we've got
a wonderful start on a very coherent approach there that we're all looking forward to seeing
unfold and giving all of our learners such a good start on their educational careers.
With that, this concludes item one. We're going to take up item 16, general public comment.
Public comment is invited on any matter that's not included on the printed agenda.
We'll open up the phone line for the public comment queue and members of the public,
I think we want to see the slide, there it comes. Members of the public wishing to provide comments
on this item may do so by calling the number shown on the public comment slide using the access that
is shown there and we'll give it a moment for folks who may want to comment to get themselves
organized and in the queue. We'll encourage anyone who is wanting to comment to state their name and
affiliation for the record, turn down the volume on their computer if they're following the live
feed and limit their comments to a minute each. Do we have any further public comments?
There are no public comment at this time and this is the Sound of the South officially signing off.
Thank you very much. We appreciate that. You do such a good job with that in such a polite and
supportive way to our callers. So this ends today's session and we'll continue our meeting
beginning with the closed session tomorrow morning to discuss or take action on the following legal
matters, EE at all, Disability Rights Education and Defense Fund versus State and Related
University of the United States Department of Justice Complaint and Office of Administrative
Hearing Complaints and California's for Equal Rights Foundation at all versus the state.
And with that, I bid you a fond adieu and we'll see you early tomorrow morning at 8.30 a.m.